Aber eine USB-C-Karte hast du noch nicht besorgt?
Eine USB-C-Karte, also...
Du als alter, flammender USB-C Befürworter.
Na ich hab halt kein USB-C Device.
Aber uns hier die ganze Zeit den hol ich, den USB-C hol ich ums Maul schmieren, wie toll das ist. Und dann das Ganze aussitzen, ja ja.
Wie kann man nur den HDMI-Stecker absägen oder den Adapter da rausschmeißen? Du hast mal auch gesagt, das wäre auch eine coole Entscheidung, dieses HDMI-Teil rauszuwerfen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
David hörst du noch zu?
Das ist natürlich echt geil. Das ist wirklich die geile Sau. Das ist aber auch wirklich mal richtig geil. Piffig. Unter den Scheißhaufen ist auf jeden Fall einer der Wärmeren. Ach ja, die Temperaturen steigen.
Ich hätte mir mehr erhofft. War das wirklich nur so wenig? Was?
Vom Supercut? Na ja, siehst du mal, ich...
War gar nicht so viel.
Ja, ich wollte euch gar nicht in die Irre lenken. Das habt ihr von ganz alleine gemacht. Ihr wolltet ja Space Grey und jetzt habt ihr Space Grey, jetzt müsst ihr das auch ausbaden. Ja, ich bin noch im glücklichen Aluminiumland.
Hätte man ja auch ein Aluminium haben können.
Ja, aber dieses Wenn schon, Denn schon. Der Apfel leuchtet nicht mehr. Soll ich noch weiter bohren?
Dein Apfel leuchtet auch nicht da mit deinem FreeBSD-Aufkleber.
Was? Achso, ja stimmt. Was?
Aber ich weiß, dass er leuchtet. Schrödingers Apfel.
Ja, ja, das ist so wie mit Sex in der Küche. Ich könnte den jederzeit haben, aber hat man natürlich nicht. Ach ja, die Welt. Hallo, hier ist Freak Show Nummer 197. Wir nähern uns einem Überlauf.
Wie, was für ein Überlauf?
Was für ein Überlauf? Nein, ein Dezimalstellen-Überlauf. Ein doppelter Dezimalstellen-Überlauf.
Der Überlauf ist aber eher so bei...
D-D-Ü.
Bei 99 oder bei 9999.
Da müssen wir aber kürzere Sendungen machen.
Da muss eine alte Frau lange für Podcasten.
Ja, ist euch klar, wie lange es diese Sendung schon gibt?
Ja, das haben wir in jeder dritten Sendung jetzt.
Skip, skip, skip. Ja und, was ist es?
Ja, irgendwas in den späten 90ern. Nee, 2007 oder so.
Nee, es rauschte gerade ein Jubiläum wieder durch.
Ja, zehn Jahre oder was?
Neun.
Neun, echt? Ich hab 2008 angefangen, nicht lieben?
1.
April.
Nehmen wir uns wird nächstes Jahr.
Mal die Feste feiern, wie sie kommen.
Ja, genau. Mal gucken, welche wir davon nehmen zum Feiern. Alle, wie immer. Ja, wahrscheinlich. Insofern gibt es noch keine Versprechungen, nur Ahnungen. Und ja, ihr habt es schon gehört, Dennis ist da.
Ja, war wieder.
Und Hucke ist da.
Stimmt.
Und der Rest ist aushäusig. Krank, bereist.
Ja, nicht wirklich, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, oder auch zu Hause, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Nicht hier auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber nur ein bisschen.
Ja, ist eigentlich auch ganz nett, wieder ein bisschen Platz und so.
So hat ja keiner die Fanta weg.
Genau.
Ja, Roddy hat sich ja entschuldigt, mit zu wenig geschlafen und so. Und das hab ich zwar eigentlich auch, aber ich dachte mir, man muss ja hier die Fahne im Wind halten, ne?
Stimme der Jugend.
Ja, die Stimme der Jugend ist ja frisch vom Meer eingereist.
Genau, vom Boot.
Genau, du hast Segelscheinchen gemacht.
Ich bin jetzt Day Skipper, yeah. Nee, das ganz Fiese ist, also dieser Schein heißt ja Day Skipper und ich hab...
Du darfst nicht nachts fahren, heißt es?
Na ja, also wenn es sicherer ist, nachts draußen zu bleiben als reinzufahren, dann darf man auch draußen bleiben. Also dürfen ist dann sehr weiches Kriterium, also ist sehr weich definiert. Nee, aber ich hab seit Tagen jetzt diesen Urpunkt...
Dürfen oder müssen ist weich definiert?
Na Day Skipper heißt halt, dass du eigentlich, wenn du ein Boot chartest, wofür du den Schein brauchst, dass die dann dir nicht... Also wenn du sagst, ja ich würde jetzt gerne mal von der Küste Portugal nach Madeira fahren, dann ist halt ganz klar, du bist vier Tage am Stück auf dem Meer, das heißt, das überschreitet quasi den Day Skipper Horizont und dann wird dir das Boot in der Regel nicht geliehen.
Aber mit einem eigenen dürftest du schon?
Mit einem eigenen darfst du eh machen, was du willst. Nee, ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, aber letztendlich sagen die meisten Skipper, ne, auch wenn du dein eigenes Boot hast, was du für Meilen aufschreibst und was du machst, dann ist alles scheißegal. Aber Bootchart, dafür brauchst du es halt auf jeden Fall. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das versicherungstechnisch oder irgendwie relevant ist, aber ja. Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt diesen fiesen Ohrwurm die ganze Zeit und denke mir, es muss doch schon mal jemand gegeben haben, der diesen Beatles Song quasi in so einen Day Skipper Song, also Day Tripper heißt der Original. Ich bin jetzt auf jeden Fall schon ganz beschäftigt, einen Cover Song davon anzufertigen, selber dann.
Wovon denn jetzt?
Na diesen Beatles Song, Day Tripper, in Day Skipper um Münzen quasi.
Es gibt einen Beatles Song, der Day Tripper heißt?
Natürlich. Ich merke schon. Anyway, ja, aber ich habe auf jeden Fall jetzt dieses Scheinchen und jetzt dürfte ich sozusagen eben Boote ausleihen und die, also das Scope ist sozusagen, dass du deine Touren so planst, dass du jeden Tag oder jeden Abend in einem Marina wieder landest. Und halt deine Touren oder deine Zwischentrips auch immer nur tageweise planst und eben nicht so lange überfahrten machst, weil bei dem Schein ist halt so eine Nachtfahrt und so ist einfach noch nicht mehr drin. Und deswegen, weil das nochmal so ein eigenes kleines Universum für sich ist, ja.
Aber der ist jetzt auch weltweit gültig?
Ja, also es geht da mehr wie bei Führerscheinen darum, welches Land oder welche Juristik oder welches Charterunternehmen die Scheine anerkennst, sozusagen.
Ja. Das ist alles so ein bisschen wie bei den Tauchscheinen, oder?
Kann sein, ich kenn dich nicht so.
Also das ist nicht gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, aber um Tauchzeug zu und so weiter und dass du irgendwie dann dich irgendwo zum Tauchern anmeldest, wollen die sehen, ob du schon mal getaucht bist oder nicht. Dazu zeigst du deinen Schein und dann sind die zufrieden. Wenn du den nicht hast, dann sagen die dir, nee, dann darfst du aber jetzt hier nicht Tiefsee tauchen machen, sondern nur hier bis wenige Meter und so weiter. Und wenn aber Schein hast, dann darfst du, aber das ist alles nicht so gesetzlich, sondern mehr so diese ganzen Rentals da, die dir Zeug vermieten, so ne?
Genau.
Im Horandum of Understanding.
Und zum Geld verdienen natürlich.
Ich hab halt den britischen, also diesen Royal Yachting Association-Schein gemacht, weil der eben so weltweit am anerkanntesten ist, weil eben die Ausbildung bei den Briten wirklich sehr viel praxisorientierter ist als eben zum Beispiel bei den Deutschen, wo wie das dann immer so ist, also wenn du den Offshore-Schein, ich weiß nicht, wie der jetzt in Deutsch heißt, ob es der SSS ist oder so, der... Ach, keine Ahnung, ich hab mich damit gar nicht beschäftigt, weil die Terminologie und alles, das ist so konvolutet, aber du musst halt quasi so viel Theorie erst mal quasi studieren, bevor du überhaupt das erste Mal auf ein Boot treten darfst, so in Anführungsstrichen.
Deutschland halt.
Aber bei den Deutschen ist es halt auch so, und auch bei ganz vielen anderen europäischen Ländern, dass du halt so viel lernst, was du aber, wenn du zum Beispiel wirklich nur so Day-Tripper-Cruises machen willst, also so kleine Kurse, brauchst du halt eigentlich alles dieses ganze Wissen nicht, und die Briten haben das halt einfach so gestaffelt nach quasi, was willst du tun, wohin willst du, was ist das Scope, was du wissen musst dafür, und es ist eben, wie gesagt, sehr viel praxisorientierter, die ganze Ausbildung, und ja, das kann ich jetzt auch nach dem Kurs bestätigen. Wir haben auf jeden Fall, es war ja sogar ein Kombikurs, das heißt, die Theorie und die Praxis waren gleichzeitig sozusagen auf dem Boot, deswegen auch ein bisschen länger als eine Woche, normalerweise ist es, glaube ich, nur eine Woche, und ja, aber der Dayskipper ist eben auch insgesamt noch sehr entspannt, also die nächste Stufe, der Yacht-Master, der wäre dann schon ein bisschen straffer oder ernster im Prüfungsprogramm, das ist jetzt wirklich, also ich würde sagen, jeder von euch könnte jetzt so einen Dayskipper-Schein auch relativ easy bestehen oder bekommen. Es gibt da auch nicht eine wirkliche Prüfung, sondern das ist eher so ein Assessment. Also du wirst halt die ganze Zeit da schon so beobachtet, was du so tust und wie du deine Routen so planst und Anlege- und Ablegemanöver und dann sagt halt der Instructor, also ja, ok, das hast du jetzt alles gut gemacht, bitte schön, hier ist der Schein. Bei dem Yacht-Master ist es dann so, du machst, glaube ich, 14 Tage geht das oder auch auf jeden Fall einige Tage und 10 Tage davon ist der Ausbilder an Bord und die letzten vier oder zwei Tage kommt dann halt wirklich einer von der RYA eingeflogen, egal wo du das machst, ja dann kommt halt so ein Typ da an. Ja und der setzt sich dann halt aufs Boot und dem bietet es dann so einen Tee und einen Keks an und so und hältst ihn so bei Laune und dann sagt er dir so, ok, hier ich schmeiße mal grad eine Boje über Bord und jetzt mal Mann über Bord manöver oder Person über Bord manöver und dann will er halt sehen, dass du die richtigen Schritte so machst und dann greifst du zum Motor Startknopf, wenn der nicht an ist und dann sagt er, gut, aber Motor geht nicht, jetzt musst du es unter Segel machen und der challenge dich halt so die ganze Zeit und versucht dich so aus deiner Komfortzone dann rauszubringen, um zu gucken, wie du so reagierst und da ist es dann eben auch so viele Leute, die schon irgendwelche Segelerfahrungen haben. Ich bin jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal mit gesegelt und konnte mir schon ein paar Meilen aufschreiben. Also du kannst halt dich jederzeit für so einen Jachtmasterkurs bewerben, wenn du halt so ein Zettel hast, wo drauf steht, dass du genug Meilen hast, aber so ein Prüfer, der findet relativ schnell raus, ob du wirklich die Erfahrung hast oder ob du immer nur mit gesegelt bist und die Meilen halt aufgeschrieben hast. Genau und ansonsten funktioniert das dann ähnlich wie beim Fliegen, also du brauchst halt immer so eine gewisse Meilenanzahl, um auch so für die nächste Stufe dich zu qualifizieren. Und ich brauche jetzt 810 Meilen, glaube ich, für den Yachtmaster.
Die muss man wirklich vorzeigen, sonst lassen sie dich nicht, oder wie?
Genau.
Wie viele Seemeilen?
800.
Das ist schon ordentlich, oder?
Da muss man schon ein bisschen segeln, oder?
Genau, also ich habe jetzt mit den jeweils zwei Wochen Trips, die ich so die letzten vier Mal gemacht habe, habe ich glaube ich jetzt knapp...
Aber warst du da nicht nur Gast?
Na du bist ja auch Watch-Leder, das heißt du hast das Steuer in der Hand und hast auch Nachtwache oder sonst was und das wird dir dann schon angerechnet. Genau, und du kriegst halt bei so einen Touren üblicherweise dann von dem Skipper so ein Formular ausgefüllt und abgestempelt und unterschrieben, dass der das jetzt sozusagen bezeugt, dass du diese Meilen abgeleistet hast, aber wie gesagt, wenn du dein eigenes Boot hast, dann kannst du halt in dein Logbuch schreiben, was du willst. Das prüft halt erstmal so keiner, sondern...
Also Huckel hat die 800 Seemeil natürlich schon hinter sich.
Nee, ich hab jetzt durch die paar Trips, glaube ich, komme ich auf knapp 300. Und dieses Jahr mache ich ja aber vier Wochen Segeln und da sind ja zwei lange...
Hast du die Überführung mit? War die schon?
Die Überführung, was?
Na, wollte die nicht? Ist doch das gleiche Boot. Na, die sollte doch jetzt hier über den Atlantik rüber oder nicht? Das war die schon oder kommt danach?
Das ist im November erst.
Ach so, alles klar.
Nee, ich fahre von Portugal nach Madeira und fahre von Madeira zu den kanarischen Inseln.
Und Verrot und Ferretaventura und so.
Genau, und dazwischen sind halt einige Seemeilen und da sind auch ein paar Tage mal ohne Landkontakt nötig und da kommen dann schon ein paar Meilen zusammen. Aber ein Hörer hat ja...
Und wenn du die 800 dann zusammenmachst, dann kannst du nochmal dahin latschen und sagen, jetzt will ich einen Master machen oder frisst du den einfach?
Nee, nee, dann musst du diesen Kurs nochmal machen und diese besagte Prüfung mit dem älteren Herrn, der Tee und Kekse haben will. Ich glaube so 2000 Euro.
Und jetzt der erste Durchlauf?
1500. Aber es sehnt auch, wie gesagt, dadurch, dass es Theorie und Praxis ist und du musst für die Verpflegung jetzt bei dem Kurs nichts bezahlen, Benzin und Liegegebühren sind dann auch schon mit drin für das Boot. Also es ist insofern okay, aber ja. Genau, und ein Hörer meint ja dann gleich, ah, dann können wir jetzt ja hier so Podcasts auf dem Boot machen oder Hörer treffen, Segeln und so weiter und so fort. Und Podcasts auf dem Boot wäre eigentlich tatsächlich eine total gute Möglichkeit, so unten schön im Bootsalon setzt man sich nieder.
Na mal gucken, jetzt wo ich das Steuerthema fast durchhabe, könnte ich mir mal wieder neue Ziele setzen.
Neues Steuer.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin jetzt so im letzten Jahr ein bisschen meinem Freund mal hier gemütlich über den Wannsee rübergetuckert, das war jetzt keine große Reise, aber ich muss sagen, so die Entspannung setzt extrem früh ein. Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert. Also wenn man jetzt so mit der ganzen Seglerei nicht so viel Berührung hat, ich bin halt eigentlich ein totales Landei, fand ich das schon ganz interessant und das ist natürlich auch eine ganz brauchbare technische Herausforderung, einfach mal dieses System zu begreifen. Also mit dem Wind und den Strömungen und all diesen ganzen Tiefen und Regeln und den anderen Teilnehmern, gerade auf dem Wannsee, da kriegst du ja die Tür nicht zu oder rausstell die ganze Zeit irgendwas an dir vorbei. Große Boote, andere, Pipapo und ist schon beherrschbar und muss natürlich sich dann auch mal ein bisschen reinwerfen in das Thema. Aber so dann diese Optionen und von daher kann ich dann die Entscheidung auch sehr gut nachvollziehen. Ist schon einfach mal auch eine ganz interessante Freiheitsaspekt. Ich mein, so ein Autoführerschein bringt einen ja dann immer so in der Hinsicht ganz schön weiter. Da hab ich mich einige Zeit darauf ausgeruht, weil mir so Segeln nie in den Sinn kamen eigentlich. Aber das einfach mal so, auch gerade in Berlin. Ich meine, das unterschätzt man nicht. Ich meine, wir haben hier einfach richtig geile Wasserwege. Du kannst schon in dieser Stadt durch diese durch Spree und Havel und Wannsee und Müggelsee und so weiter. Du hast einfach wirklich auch viel Wasser. Gerade wenn du dann nach Brandenburg ausrückst, Mecklenburg, Seenplatte, Pipapo. Du kannst da auch nennenswerte Distanzen machen. Du kannst auch interessante Ziele erreichen. Und das halt auf eine sehr entspannte Art und Weise.
Also das war ja sowieso das erste Mal, als ich da bei der Elisa mit gesegelt bin. Dieser tiefen Entspannungseffekt ist wirklich unfassbar. Und gerade noch im Besonderen, deswegen wollte ich jetzt auch diese Langstrecken mit segeln, wenn du halt wirklich kein Land siehst und jetzt auch so mal ein paar Tage komplett raus aus diesem Zivilisationsding bist, wo nicht mal 3G oder so noch auf dem Telefon ist die ganze Zeit. Du kannst ja nicht viel machen. Entweder du hältst das Steuer, machst irgendeinen Kurs oder kurbelst ein bisschen an den Segeln rum, aber das machst du ja jetzt auch, was weiß ich, also nicht alle 3 Minuten. Ansonsten sitzt man dann halt so und guckt so aufs Meer und das Funkeln der Wellen und das Schaukeln und dann macht man ein Schläfchen und dann macht man mal ein Käffchen und dann isst man mal was und dann hält man wieder das Steuer und dann schläft man noch eine Runde und dann isst man echt so nach so einem Tag einfach so total ausgerollt, wa?
Und trotzdem ist man halt müde, weil natürlich...
Der Körper ja trotzdem auch die ganze Zeit so immer...
Die Luft und du bist die ganze Zeit irgendwie am Machen.
Und wie siehst du aus mit so Seekrank und so? Hatte sie gar nicht oder nur am Anfang oder?
Ne, wir sind ja im Solent gesegelt, also diesem Stückchen Wasser zwischen dieser Isle of Wight und England und da waren jetzt eh nicht so viele große Wellen. Also ich würde auch sagen, auf dem Wannsee und so, da kommst du, außer wenn du ganz empfindlich bist, nicht in die Verlegenheit. Aber mir wurde schon bestimmt zwei oder drei Mal in den vier Jahren mal übel, aber gespielen habe ich noch nicht. Also das ist wirklich sehr typabhängig. Wie gesagt, es gibt Leute, die schon beim Schaukeln im Hafen sich übergeben, ganz beliebt. Vorletztes Mal meinte eine Freundin von einem Freund, die da auch mitgekommen ist, habe ich sie auch so ganz ausführlich gefragt, wie ist das mit deiner Seelkrankheit und wird dir schlecht, wenn du hinten im Bus sitzt oder wenn du im Auto auf dein Smartphone guckst. Da gibt es ja auch so Kandidaten. Ich war schon mal vor Jahren auf so einem Segelboot und da ist mir nur so ein bisschen schlecht geworden. Also du meinst, du hast so eine Kontrolle? Ja, ja, ne, doch, das wird schon passen. Und was war irgendwie echt? Sie geht aufs Boot, wir legen ab, wir fahren raus und die ersten paar, also nicht mal großen oder sonst was spektakulären Bällen, sondern wirklich nur so fortgeschrittenes Schaukeln, sagen wir mal, da wurde sie schon kreidebleich und es war klar, das wird wohl nichts. Und die ist dann irgendwann halt ausgestiegen, ist mit ihrem Freund dann mit dem Bus das letzte Stück immer so mitgefahren und dann haben wir uns in den Mariners wieder getroffen.
Das heißt, man kann auch mit irgendwelchen Pillen dann nicht nachhelfen, man kriegt das dann nicht mehr weg. So easy, oder?
Na ja, wie gesagt, wenn du halt so super empfindlich bist, dann helfen dir die Pillen auf Dauer nicht. Also die machen dich halt dann auch im Zweifel müde, sind ja auch Antihistamine ganz oft, so wie bei Heuschnupfen. Und dann penst du halt die ganze Zeit und dann hast du aber auch von dem Segeltrip nicht so viel. Also das Geile ist wirklich beim zweiten Mal Segeln, da sind wir von Elba nach Corsica gesegelt. Es war so Sonnenuntergangsstimmung und wir sind hinter Elba gerade so vorgefahren und plötzlich kam so der Wind so genau aus der optimalen Richtung. Die Wellen waren nicht zu hoch, aber das Boot lag so richtig schön mit Schräglage im Wasser. Fett Wind und irgendwie hat halt voll Spaß gemacht, durchs Wasser zu reiten quasi, aber ich weiß zum Beispiel die Dame, die da sich so schnell, also die kannst du knicken, ne? Also das muss man halt irgendwie, wie gesagt, auf dem Wannsee und so, ist ja jetzt schon mal ganz gut so, um überhaupt mal die generelle Wasserschaukelkompatibilität zu testen. Aber ja, irgendwie, auf dem Meer ist es dann auch nochmal ein...
Es ist ja auch alles sehr relativ. Ich hab zum Beispiel, ich bin so ein notorischer Fahrer, also wenn ich in einem Auto sitze, dann sehe ich mich eigentlich nur am Steuer. Für Beifahrersituationen bin ich irgendwie nicht gemacht. Und wenn ich dann doch mal Beifahrer bin, und sei es nur im Taxi, hab ich das schon öfter gehabt, dass mir im Taxi schlecht geworden.
Alles klar, du bist beim Segen raus.
Weiß ich auch nicht, glaube nicht.
Also, auf Ferien warst du ja wahrscheinlich schon ein paar Mal. Ich bin zum Beispiel, wenn ich früher auf Ferien gewesen bin, und das Wetter war so ein bisschen stürmisch, und die Fähre war auch schon gut am Wanken, dann war ich der, der dann trotzdem draußen stand und so das Spektakel so hier reingefahren hat. Deswegen war ich mir schon einigermaßen sicher, dass ich da okay bin.
Natural Born Sailor.
Aber wie gesagt, die Skipper sagen, jedem wird mal schlecht, auch den härtesten Seemann kommt mal irgendwann hoch. Und wenn es nur dadurch ist, dass alle unten sitzen und den Sturm aussitzen und einer fängt an zu kotzen, dann sitzt er in dieser kleinen Kabine und der Eimer geht rum.
Als ich in Neuseeland war, wollten wir auch mit der Fähre von Nord zur Südinsel. Und dann ist die Fähre ausgefallen, weil Sturm war. Dann haben wir gewartet, bis die endlich wieder fährt. Und dann ist irgendwann die erste Fähre wieder gefahren. Aber Sturm war natürlich immer nochmal so, dass maximal Sturm, wo eine Fähre noch fahren darf. Und die haben wir genommen. Meine Fresse, war mir schlecht. Also selbst als wir danach an Land waren, hatte ich noch 36 Stunden, lag ich einfach nur flach. Und es ging nix. Also es war wirklich, ich weiß nicht, so starke Kopfschmerzen irgendwie. Gekotzt hab ich komischerweise auch nicht. Aber mein Hirn war so durch. Weil nachts Fähre, nichts gesehen, kein Horizont zu orientieren. Ich hab mich vornehin gesetzt, weil es ging ja so geil hoch und runter. Hab das ja noch nicht gepeilt. Und irgendwann wurde mir so ein bisschen komisch irgendwie. Und da war sozusagen alle Anfängerfehler und unglücklichen Momente, so wie nachts und so, und Riesenfähre drinnen, nicht draußen und so. Ich denke, bei so einem kleinen Boot hat man mehr Überblick und Kontrolle. Weil das Gehirn mehr weiß, was losgeht, abgeht und man sich darauf einstellen kann.
Also die Male, die mir schlecht geworden sind, waren auch unter Deck.
Also bei großem Fernsehen ist auf jeden Fall der Trick. Hinten sein, draußen Horizont irgendwie angucken, damit man weiß, ob es gerade hoch oder runter geht oder was so passiert, damit das Gehirn sich gleich darauf einstellen kann. Weil du merkst es ja irgendwie nicht so, wenn du im Schiff bist, dann weißt du ja nicht, ob es gerade runter geht oder hoch geht.
Und beim Segelboot hast du dann eben auch noch diese Schräglage. Das ist auch höchst irritierend, weil wenn es jetzt nur gerade wäre, dann hättest du wenigstens einen Bezugspunkt, aber dann liegt das Booteil 35 Grad im Wasser oder so. Es schaukelt noch nach vorne und nach hinten. Oder wenn du so Querwellen hast, dann geht es ja wirklich wie so ein Gyro quasi in alle Richtungen. Und dann bist du unter Deck hast deinen Bezugspunkt nicht.
Das heißt, es geht hoch und runter, aber gleichzeitig kippt es noch mal links und rechts, je nachdem, wie es gerade in die Welle drückt.
Ja, und dann läufst du eh schon wie besoffen durch das Boot, weil ich habe mal irgendwann ein Video gemacht, da haben dann zwei Freunde, wollten irgendwas ganz von vorne holen. Und dann habe ich einfach nur von oben runter gefilmt und versucht das so mit dem Horizont gerade zu machen. Oder quatsche mit dem Boot, dass es sozusagen auf dem Video alles gerade aussieht und dann einfach nur gefilmt, wie die dadurch sich das Boot hangeln, als wäre gerade sonst was los. Sehr witzig. Aber ansonsten genau dieser Freiheitsfaktor ist auf jeden Fall ganz großartig und vor allen Dingen dann noch im Meer, wenn du halt wirklich in Buchten und Inseln und Ecken kommst, wo die meisten Leute eben nicht so hinkommen. Und das ist schon auch sehr befriedend. Und jetzt auch die neuen Tage, also kaum war ich von dem Boot wieder zurück und ich hatte auch so eine mega ätzende Heimreise. Und dann bist du da wieder so in der Stadt und dann ist so dieses schon nach neun Tagen das Gefühl, ich brauch ein Boot, wo kriege ich ein Boot her? Wie komme ich zurück aufs Boot?
Im Endeffekt ist das Wetter noch nicht so, dass man nach einem Boot schreit.
Ja, das Wetter in Südengland war sogar besser als hier. Also ich habe einen kleinen Sonnenbrand gehabt. Anyway, genau, also Day Skipper ist am Start und wir können jetzt zumindest auf einem Boot passen halt leider nicht so viele Leute. Deswegen sind wir eigentlich mit unserem Freak Show Team beim Würden wir das Boot schon voll machen. Deswegen Hörer segeln.
Soweit sind wir noch nicht.
Soweit sind wir noch nicht. Die MS Freak Show.
Wir können natürlich Hörerinnen des Monats ausrufen und dann...
Ja, also so ein Segelboot, was nicht so ganz neu ist, sagen wir mal acht, neun Jahre alt. Wenn du das charters, kostet es im Mittelmeer. Und das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal in der Saison. Kostet halt so 2000 Euro pro Woche. Also ist schon auch jetzt nicht...
Muss ja nicht gleich Mittelmeer sein. Wir können ja auch mal schön über den Wannsee schippern.
Aber dafür hab ich ja keinen Schein.
Wie, dafür hast du keinen Schein?
Nein, Berlin im Speziellen und Deutschland sowieso ist halt eins der wenigen Länder, wo du für Binnensegeln volles Programm Segelschein haben musst.
Ach so, du hast jetzt weniger drauf, als die, die jetzt hier durch den Wannsee schuppern?
Andere Sachen. Also die Binnensegler, die können dafür nicht auf dem Meer segeln. Also können sie schon, aber... Also das Segeln an sich ist ja auch nicht das Problem. Also segeln kann, wie gesagt, gefühlt jeder. Weil das ist schon relativ intuitiv. Da ist so ein Stück Fetzen in der Luft und der Wind kommt aus einer Richtung und das muss man jetzt irgendwie so hinkriegen, dass der Wind in diesen Fetzen reingeht. Also selbst wenn man nicht die Aerofoil oder diese Tragflächeneffekte und so in Betracht zieht, dann ist das trotzdem einigermaßen erschließbar, wie das geht. Aber die ganzen anderen Sachen, was du schon meintest, die ganzen Regeln, Vorfahrtsregeln, Schilder, Mücken. Genau, und Karten lesen, Kurse planen. Vorfahrt regeln. Ich hab jetzt ja in Tidengewässern meinen Schein gemacht. Das ist halt nochmal eine ganz eigene Kategorie. Tidenberechnung, Tidenströmung. Weil so ein Boot hat ja ordentlich Tiefgang, so ein Segelboot, um es aufrechtzuhalten. Und dann gerade in England, da in diesem Bereich, das ist extrem wichtig zu gucken, ob du, wenn du da ankommst an deinem Zielort, auch noch genug Wasser unterm Kiel hast. Oder ob du da wegkommst zu der Zeit, wo du wegfahren willst. Und ob dir die Strömung hilft. Oder ob du, ok, morgen ist kein Wind, die Strömung kommt uns entgegen. Das heißt, wir würden gegen die Strömung an Motoren.
So, der Chat meint, deine Aussage stimmt nicht mehr. Es gibt auch in Deutschland keinen Unterschied zwischen Sportboot, Führerschein, Binnen und See. Beziehungsweise es wird jetzt sehr bald geändert.
Also in Berlin war es auf jeden Fall immer besonders so. In Brandenburg waren sie da schon sehr viel relaxter. Aber ich wüsste halt nicht, ob jetzt ein Binnen-Segel-Bootverleih einen Dayskipper-Schein von der RYA anerkennen würde, als jetzt Schein. Zum Beispiel die Deutschen sind halt auch wirklich so mega... Stock... Rektum etc. Außer dein Funkerzeugnis, das ist dann auch wieder so ein Thema für sich. Also die finden es halt total doof, dass jetzt ein deutscher Staatsbürger einen englischen Funkerschein macht. Ja, das sollen die doch bitte schön beim deutschen Segelverein oder sonst was machen. Was aber natürlich auch wieder primär kommerzielle Interessen hat als praktische. Weil dann kriegen sie jetzt ja nicht die tollen Prüfungsgebühren usw. Das ist alles ein totaler Käse. Ich hab einfach keinen Bock auf deutsche Segelscheine wirklich. Und deswegen, wenn ich damit jetzt mit diesem Dayskipper-Schein nicht auf dem Wansi segeln darf, dann hat der Wansi halt Pech gehabt. Aber wie gesagt, in Brandenburg müsste es eigentlich gehen. Und wie gesagt, wenn es sich jetzt hier auch ändert, kann es auch sein...
Weiß ich jetzt, in Berlin ist es noch mal anders als in Brandenburg. Wie kann das denn sein?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab mir das mal durchgelesen, aber es hatte auf jeden Fall so eine besondere Betonung auf, du musst so einen Binnensegelschein machen oder so.
Also ja, es ist eine Änderung ab 1. Mai 2017, könnte sein, dass sich diese Lage entspannt.
Okay, aber ich werde trotzdem die britischen Scheine weitermachen. Also die Deutschen interessieren mich wirklich 0,0. Binnensegeln halt im Prinzip eigentlich auch nicht, weil wenn du dann eben auf dem Meer schon mal so unterwegs warst und eben diese Freiheitsgrade und Bewegungsspektren erlebt hast, dann erscheint mir See gerade so richtig mega derbe.
Ja gut, also wenn das für mich interessant ist, dann ist das natürlich auch eine wunderbare Familienausflugsoption und von daher müsste das dann eigentlich die Priorität sein.
Wobei gerade hier so Schweden, Dänemark, was ja auch in Schlagdistanze ist von der Autofahrt und so, da gibt es halt auch super viele kleine Inseln. Und da zu segeln, das sind auch sehr beliebte und bekannte Segelreviere genau für solche kleinen Familien-Cruises sozusagen, weil du dann wirklich auch alle paar Nase lang irgendwo anlegen kannst und eben nicht deine Kids da zwei Tage lang am Stück auf dem Boot gefangen halten musst.
So, wenn man da so viel berechnen muss, dann kann man ja sicherlich auch die moderne Technologie zu Hilfe nehmen, oder?
Oh ja, absolut. Also der Segel-App-Markt, der sprudelt nur vor sich so hin. Das ist halt auch ganz interessant, weil auch beim Segeln so diese Tradition versus Moderne, das ist auch so ein interner Debattenprozess, also auch in der Lektüre zu so einem Segelschein, da wird dann gesagt, naja, also es gibt ja schon GPS, ja. Und natürlich benutzen wir das GPS jetzt, ja, aber...
Man sollte trotzdem noch die Sterne lesen können.
Na, die Sterne brauchst du beim Coastal-Segeln nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ganz sinnvoll natürlich auch mal, ohne das GPS klarzukommen. Aber die Argumentation ist dann, ja, was ist, wenn das GPS ausfällt? Aber jetzt guckst du eben in deine Hosentasche und hast halt GPS und GLONASS in deiner Tasche und wenn du fünf Leute an Bord hast, hast du acht GPS-Devices und GLONASS-Empfänger irgendwie am Start. Also die Chance, dass sozusagen wirklich zu irgendeinem beliebigen Zeitpunkt kein GPS oder GLONASS fix möglich ist, ist sehr gering. Ja, aber nicht, dass du trotzdem in der Ausbildung lernst, du hast halt auch noch klassischen, wenn du den Yachtmaster Ocean machst, also wirklich Ozeanpassagen, dann musst du auch noch den Sechs Tanten bedienen können. Aber wie gesagt, für alles andere gibt es dann halt natürlich viele Apps und da gab es ja dann auch den Schritt von Pixel-basierten oder Bitmap-basierten Karten und das war der erste Schritt der Digitalisierung. Aha, wir nehmen jetzt die ganzen Papierkarten und machen die, scannen die mal ein und geben die als Bitmaps raus. Und dann hat es natürlich auch nicht lange darauf gewartet. Genau. Und da gibt es jetzt so diverse Möglichkeiten. Eine tolle Sache, die mir auch ein Hörer geschickt hat, ist, dass es von OpenStreetMap auch die OpenSeaMap gibt, wo sie sozusagen genau das Gleiche machen und sozusagen OpenSource-basiert oder Crowdsourcing-basiert die ganzen Seekarten nach kartografieren, was ich ganz spannend finde. Allerdings habe ich so ein bisschen meine Bedenken, die zu benutzen oder mich darauf allein zu verlassen, weil ganz viele Informationen, die in diesen Karten drin sind, die müssen halt richtig stimmen. Und bei so einer Crowdsourced-Map weiß ich nicht, ob ich das so 100% für bare Münze nehmen kann, weil der Aufwand, den in diese Seekarten reinstecken, ist schon wirklich ziemlich enorm. Und die werden halt jedes Jahr aktualisiert und auch sehr gründlich. Anyway, aber OpenSeamap ist auf jeden Fall der erste vielleicht Einstieg damit. Und dann gibt es so zwei Apps für die Navigation. Das eine heißt Navionics. Die machen nicht nur Segel-Apps. Ich glaube, die gibt es auch so für Fahrradfahren und keine Ahnung was. Und die andere heißt iSailer. Ich bin ein Navionics-Freund. Bei beiden Apps musst du sozusagen für dein Segelgebiet auch teure Karten kaufen. Also eine Karte für ein Jahr kostet dann 33 Euro und beinhalte zum Beispiel nur das Südenglandgebiet. Aber dann eben mit unendlichen Details zum Reinszoomen und Informationen. Und die zeigen dir dann auch die Tiden an und die Strömung der Tiden und die Windrichtung und den Wetterbericht. Du kannst deine ganze Wegplanung damit machen. Also wer sich noch nicht so mit Segel-Navigations-Apps auseinandergesetzt hat, Navionics ist auf jeden Fall für mich der absolute Gewinner. Ice Sailer ist nicht so geil. Da kann ich jetzt gar nicht so genau... Ich könnte jetzt stundenlang darüber reden, aber die Hörer, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Segler wir unter unseren Hörern haben, die das erstens noch nicht kennen und zweitens...
Immer mehr als man denkt.
Außerdem dient das ja auch, um den Leuten das schmackhaft zu machen.
Ja, wobei erst mal Segel lernen, dann Navionics benutzen. Aber was ganz cool war, ich sollte ja bei meiner Kursplanung auch nicht die Apps benutzen natürlich. Und wir haben auch nicht GPS benutzt, also nur mal ab und zu zur Kontrolle. Aber was ich halt immer gemacht hab vor den Touren, ich hab sozusagen die Route auch bei Navionics oder diese App halt eingegeben und getrackt. Und dann konnte man halt hinterher überprüfen, ob meine auf Papierkarten geplante Route mit so den Kursen und den Winden und den Strömungen dann am Ende auch so übereinstimmen. Und das war halt ganz nützlich auf jeden Fall. Also du kriegst halt eben auch genau dieses Tracking-Feature dazu. Und eben, was wirklich sehr komplex werden kann, diese Tidenberechnung ist halt, oder was es komplex macht, ist, dass natürlich nicht jedes kleine Nest und hinter Tupfingen kriegt seinen eigenen Tidenkalender. Sondern die machen das immer nur für die großen Häfen. Und dann gibt es sozusagen für alle anderen kleinen Orte, das sind dann die Secondary Ports, gibt es sozusagen nur so Korrekturangaben in Bezug auf den Standard Port. Also sagen wir mal, Portsmouth ist der Standard Port, dafür gibt es den kompletten Tidenkalender mit Spring und, wie heißt das auf Deutsch? Nib, also wenn...
Springtide, wenn das schneller...
Also Spring ist, wenn Sonne und Mond gegenüber sind und Nib ist halt, wenn der Mond und die Sonne rechtwinklig stehen quasi.
Also ob die Flut verstärkt wird oder nicht und so.
Genau, dann kriegst du halt für diese Secondary Ports eine Kurve und die Korrekturen, wie viel früher oder später kommt die Flut, wie viel höher oder niedriger ist die Flut und dann kannst du das in so einem Diagramm alles eintragen und abtragen und nachmessen und so weiter. Und das kann echt, sitzt du für so eine Tour manchmal eine Stunde oder so. Springnib und Midtide, okay. Und das macht halt diese App dann auch für dich. Also diese ganzen Tiden-Berechnungen, das kannst du dir dann auch alles schenken. Aber lädt halt auch zur Faulheit und zur Bequemlichkeit ein.
Und zum Nichts Verstehen, denn weil man nur noch abliest.
Ja, sozusagen. Zum Beispiel bei diesen ganzen Charter-Tours, also auch bei Elisa ist es so, da tippst du halt alles in das GPS ein, die ganzen Wegpunkte, und dann kannst du halt irgendeinen Dödel ans Steuer setzen und sagen, hier fahr einfach diese Linie hinterher. Und das GPS sagt dir auch den Cross-Track-Error, weil durch Tiden-Strömungen wirst du nach links und rechts auch manchmal verschoben von deinem ursprünglichen Kurs. Musst du dagegen korrigieren, das kann man alles auf Papier und sich schon vorher ausrechnen, aber bei so einer Charter-Tour, wo halt viele Anfänger sitzen, dann klickst du die Wegpunkte rein und das macht das dann alles für dich.
Dann dauert es eigentlich auch nicht lange, dann besiegelt Schürfer hier Self-Driving.
Es gibt auch Segel-Audiopiloten.
Wollte ich doch sagen, wenn man nur ein bisschen Lenkrad drehen muss.
Also ich mein, wie gesagt, um das jetzt mal hier mit den Apps so ein bisschen kurz zu halten, dieses Navionics, finde ich, ist die beste Routenplanung und alles, was damit zusammenhängt, Windrichtungen. Ja, ich pack dir gleich einen Link rein. Genau, Gezeiten, Wetter, den ganzen Spaß. Und dann gibt es halt noch so ein paar Apps dazu. Zum Beispiel gibt es, so ähnlich wie beim Flügen des Flight Raider, gibt es natürlich auch so ein Sea Raider, oder Shipfinder heißt das, glaube ich, wo man sozusagen alle kommerziellen Schiffe sieht, die so unterwegs sind.
Das war als Pirat voll nützlich, oder?
Auch das, genau, weil die haben dann richtig Fotos und was sie so üblicherweise für Cargo und so haben, das steht da alles drin. Das wird über AIS gemacht, heißt das System. Und das ist halt für dich als Segelboot durchaus sehr praktisch, weil theoretisch müssten, wenn du segelst, müssten alle motorgetriebenen Schiffe dir ausweichen.
Die müssen dir ausweichen?
Ja, weil sie halt steuerfähiger sind oder manövrierfähiger, weil sie halt einen Motor haben. Aber in der Praxis, so ein Tanker hat halt einen Bremsweg von so und so viele Meilen und wenn dir das Ruder bewegt, bis dann der Kurs geändert ist und so weiter und auf dem Radar von so einem Tanker bist du halt so ein kleiner Furz. Und selbst wenn sie dich dann rechtzeitig sehen und versuchen würden dir auszuweichen, solltest du dich nicht darauf verlassen. Deswegen, das Gesetz ist, sie müssen ausweichen, die Regel ist, du weichst aus. Und gerade in der Nacht, wo du halt dich wirklich nur an Lichtern orientieren musst oder kannst, das ist halt auch mega gut, wenn du dann halt mit so einem...
Was hat dein Segelschiff für eine Nachtbeleuchtung?
Na, es hat Navigationslichter, das heißt...
An so einem Dauerlicht oder wie?
Nee, es sagt, wo links, also wo Port und Starboard ist und wo hinten ist.
Und wo hinten ist.
Und das nutzt du dann auch für die Vorfahrtsregeln.
Das heißt, nachts sind immer drei Lichter an? Oder blinken die?
Und dann, wenn du einen Motor an hast, dann machst du halt noch ein Motorlicht dazu an.
Was heißt Motorlicht?
Das ist einfach noch mal eine Lampe, und die sagt an in der Nacht, ah, der fährt unter Motor.
Das heißt, du musst ausweichen?
Genau. Also nee, ja, nee. Also wenn du so Kleinstboote siehst, und eins fährt mit Motor und eins fährt mit Segel, dann muss immer das Motorboot ausweichen.
Ja, dazu muss man ja wissen, ob der Motor an ist und das ist eine Lampe. Und damit man die alle unterscheiden kann, sind das alles unterschiedliche Farben?
Echt nicht? Es gibt, wenn es ein großes Boot ist, dann haben die die, also wenn es über 50 Meter ist, glaube ich, dann haben die zwei weiße Lampen an. Also ein Schiff, Motorschiff. Wenn es ein kleines ist, nur eine. Und dann gibt es nochmal ein paar Spezialbeleuchtungen, aber...
Deswegen auch, weil du meintest irgendwie diese, was hast du gesagt, Port und...
Starboard.
Und Starboard. Und deswegen noch die Lampe, wo die anzeigt, wo vorne und hinten ist, weil wenn die keine unterschiedlichen Farben haben, kann man durchs Port und Starboard nicht an die Seite erkennen. Das heißt, man muss sich an dem Dreieck der Lampen orientieren. Ich dachte, die machen das mit Farben.
Naja, die eine ist halt grün, die andere ist rot. Wenn du rot siehst, heißt das, du machst Platz. Wenn du grün siehst, heißt das, der andere muss Platz machen. Du siehst so ein Boot von rechts kommen und dann siehst du die rote Seite sozusagen. Hoffentlich ist das richtig. Und das heißt, wenn du das rote Licht von ihm siehst, dann bist du ausweispflichtig.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Genau. Aber wie gesagt, mit diesem AIS, die modernen Boote haben heutzutage auch einen AIS-Empfänger und ein Sender selber, also auch ein normales privates Segelboot, sendet diese Signale. Und das heißt, andere Schiffe sehen das auch, aber zum Beispiel Elisas Boot hatte das bisher nicht und die älteren Boote in der Regel haben kein AIS on Board. Aber du kannst halt immer in Küstengebieten bis, weiß nicht, 10 Meilen oder so, kriegst du noch minimales Internet.
Und dann kannst du dein iPhone, die AIS starten und das macht das alles.
Genau, und dann siehst du halt, was so viele Schiffchen um dich rum sind. Durchaus auch sehr praktisch. Und dafür gibt es Shipfinder oder Marine Traffic heißt die App. Aber es gibt es auch im Internet. Da kann man mal gucken, was so viele fette Containerschiffe...
Also das rein ins Chatten.
Ja, ich sammel das mal hier kurz. Ich musste parallel noch dann die Links kurz suchen. Also warte, Navionics hatten wir, Navionics, Shipfinder.
Wir hatten ja auch vor einiger Zeit hier mal den Jens-Uwe zu Gast. Ich schau grad mal, warst du da eigentlich dabei? Nee, da hast du nämlich gefehlt.
Ich hab gefehlt, ne?
Nee, du warst dabei.
Aber ich hab ja schon von aus dem Club.
Genau. Hast du wahrscheinlich gehört? Nehme ich mal an. Die Sendung ist schon eine Weile her jetzt. Das war September 2014, da war Jens-Uwe da. Jens-Uwe zur Erinnerung ist derjenige, mit dem ich auch den CRE mal über Segeln gemacht habe.
Den hab ich auf jeden Fall.
Wo viele Leute dann vielleicht erstmal den Eindruck haben, jetzt wird Segeln erklärt. Darum ging es jetzt nicht um Segeln lernen, sondern es ging halt, wie auch, sondern es ging halt so um den Lifestyle Segeln, den er ja sehr ausgiebig führt. Lifestyle Segeln. Der macht das jetzt schon seit, weiß nicht, seit 15 Jahren irgendwie ausgestiegen.
Aus dem Boot gestiegen und seitdem kommt er nur runter zum Einkaufen.
Quasi. Also er ist halt in der schönen Zeit, ist halt immer irgendwie Karibik irgendwo, Amerika, diese ganze Ecke. Und wenn die Hurricanes kommen, dann packt er das Teil halt ab und dann ist er mal wieder bei uns. Und ja, so nebenbei programmiert er halt auch eine App fürs Segeln, die vielleicht an dieser Stelle noch mal erwähnt werden sollte, die heißt WeatherTrack. Und ich bin ja nun wirklich kein Experte hier, weathertrack.us, noch im schnieken iOS 6 Design, ist aber aktiv entwickelt. Ich weiß, er ist erst dran. Ich hatte erst vor kurzem nochmal mit ihm drüber gesprochen und ich hoffe, ich kriege das jetzt so richtig zusammen. Das coole ist, dass er sich halt wirklich diese ganzen, Grip heißt das glaube ich, dieses Format, diese Formate, er lädt also diese ganzen Grip-Kram runter und rendert das alles auf dem iPhone und macht sich da sozusagen seine eigenen Vektormaps und hat sozusagen wirklich die ultimative Wetterdaten-Information mit allen, mehrere Strömungen und Pipapo, was man halt so braucht, wenn man wirklich so richtig in der wilden See ist. Und ja, keine Ahnung, wie sich das jetzt zu anderen Dingen verhält, aber meine Erkenntnis ist, dass das sozusagen unter Hardcore-Seglern auch durchaus ein Companion ist, den man schätzt.
Das habe ich auf jeden Fall so was gesucht. Das ist gut zu wissen, dass du das hier nochmal erwähnst.
Ja, check das mal aus, ob das sozusagen was ist. Ist ja nicht nur Segler, sondern auch Hardcore-Programmierer der ersten Stunde. Wer sich dafür interessiert, hört euch nochmal die Sendung an.
Hat er auch mit DMC über Filesystems gemacht?
Genau, Filesysteme, also Filesharing-Protokolle, also AFP, SMB, den ganzen Kram haben wir mal durchgekraut, weil das ist ja sozusagen seine alte Heritage. Damit hat er sein Geld verdient seiner Zeit und das war dann auch genug damals, um dann halt umzusteigen vom Berufsleben auf Segeldasein, dauerhaft. Manchmal läuft es gut. Das war Freak Show 140, der Supersensor greift an. Und da erklärt er das auch alles, was er da ganz genau macht. Das ist wohl ein ziemliches Hardcore-Tool, so wie ich den Uwe kenne. Der geht halt ans Eingemachte. Der weiß, was er tut.
Ich check das mal aus.
Not your usual App-Programmer.
Noch eine App, die das iPhone gleich mitbringt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ist Barometer.
Ich glaube, bei dem iPhone 6 ist es dabei, weil der auch den Sensor hat.
Genau, und das ist tatsächlich auch ein nützliches Tool beim Segeln, weil du schreibst halt in das Logbuch auch üblicherweise gerade den Druck, weil es ja fürs Wetter und die Wetteränderung interessant ist. Und üblicherweise hast du in den älteren Segelschiffen halt diese analogen Barometer, wo keiner weiß, wie genau die überhaupt noch sind. Und wenn du auf drei unterschiedliche Segelboote im gleichen Marina gehst, dann zeigen die auch alle drei so leicht was anderes an. Und da kannst du dann halt auch immer schön mit dem iPhone-Sensor auftrumpen, weil der auch so hyperempfindlich ist. Hat man ja hier mal das, wenn du das iPhone mal hochhältst und dann wieder auf den Boden legst, dann siehst du ja schon den Druckunterschied quasi. Und das kann man auch ganz gut dann benutzen, um mal eine schiffsunabhängige Druckabnahme sozusagen mit zu protokollieren.
Also gibt es da auch so eine App, die das sofort laufend misst und wegschreibt?
Das nicht, das wäre ja für seinen Weather Track eigentlich ein ganz sinnvolles Feature.
Wenn das nicht schon drin ist, dann weiß ich, wie sich das so entwickelt hat.
Und ansonsten, also viel mehr Apps brauche ich jetzt persönlich nicht. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch noch so eine App, die heißt Windy, die zeigt dir so eine, ja, wie sagt man, Kompassrose oder so was an und zeigt dir dann auf so eine etwas alternative Art und Weise an, wie im Tagesverlauf der Wind so bläst. Das ist auch für die Kitesurfer wahrscheinlich ganz interessant. Oder die Kiteskater auf dem Tempelhofer Feld. Das ist auch ganz interessant, aber die klassischen Windkarten, so mit ganz vielen Pfeilen über der Karte, die dann so die Richtung und die Stärke angeben, die reichen eigentlich auch vollkommen aus. Ja, aber wie gesagt, das Ding ist eben auch, wie heißen die, Raymarine ist der eine große Hersteller von diesen Schiffsnavigationstools und der andere ist Garmin, die so beide ganz groß in diesem Bootsbestückungsmarkt sind. Und das ist halt unfassbar teuer, was die für diese Geräte, die müssen ja wasserdicht sein und so weiter und dann vom User Interface und wenn die ein Touchscreen haben, Hölle, weil das natürlich so ein Touchscreen ist von gefühlt 1998, so von der Haptik und...
Willst du sofort aufschrauben und ein iPad reißen.
Und das Ding ist halt, zum Beispiel bei dem Einbot, was wir dann hatten, da war auch schon der iPad-Halter überm Steuerrad quasi anmontiert und Elisa macht das ja auch überwiegend mit einem iPad. Also da ist zwar ein Garmin GPS-Tracker auch dabei, aber ich würde auch wahrscheinlich, wenn ich so ein eigenes Boot hätte, mir dann irgendwie so eine fette, korrekte Halterung mit Stromversorgung direkt ans Steuer bauen, weil auch die Karten-Updates, die sind halt viel teurer. Hier bezahlst du halt einmal 33 Euro im Jahr für so eine topaktuelle Karte, die auch dann für das Jahr immer geupdatet wird. Und da zahlst du glaube ich so 150 bis 200 Euro für so eine Karte und hast noch dieses beschissene User-Interface und so weiter und so fort.
Die Hardware kann doch gar nicht schneller und so.
Genau, und die Hardware kostet auch das Zehnfache. So nach dem Motto. Genau, das war's eigentlich auch schon mit den Apps, die ich jetzt bisher so kennengelernt habe. Ich hab natürlich hier einen eigenen Screen auf meinem iPhone mit Segel-related Apps. Da sind so Wetter-Apps und diese Navigations-Apps und einen Tiden-Planer. Und natürlich ganz wichtig die Knotenreferenz, die Seemannsknotenreferenz. Naja, es gibt halt so sechs Knoten, die man regelmäßig braucht. Und dann gibt es noch so ein paar die...
Ach so, Knoten im Sinne von Knoten... Seile. Ah ja, das ist aber ein gutes Thema, weil ich hab verschiedene Knoten-Apps, die jetzt sozusagen vor dem Ausstehen bei der 64-Bit-Umstellung. Was würdest du denn sagen, ist so... das ist super, weil ich meine Knoten brauchen wir ja nun beim Segeln am laufenden Meter, und da muss man das ja auch irgendwie drauf haben.
Absolut, genau.
Aber ich merk ja auch so im gepflegten Gartenleben, insbesondere wenn man irgendwie versucht, seinen Kindern schlau zu kommen, wie sie denn jetzt irgendwas anzubinden haben, sodass jetzt irgendwie die Kinder nicht gleich stranguliert werden, etc.
Und da muss ich gleich mal auch ein Plädoyer für, wer auch immer, den Lehrplan an Schulen und so weiter. Also, nee, nicht Plädoyer, sondern ein Aufruf. Weil es gibt, jetzt wo ich mich da auch nochmal für den Schein vorbereitet habe, hab ich mir auch noch so mal die ganzen Knoten nochmal so rein gefahren wieder. Und es sind einfach extrem praktische Knoten, die einfach zu binden sind, die einfach wieder aufgehen, die einfach bombenfest halten, wenn sie halten müssen, um verschiedenste Dinge zu erledigen. Und alles, was du so in deiner Schule oder Kindergarten lernst, ist halt, wie machst du dir die Schuhe zu?
Und noch nicht mal das richtig.
Und noch nicht mal das richtig. Und dann, weißt du, so Doppelknoten, das ist dann noch, was alle auch noch irgendwie machen, wenn es irgendwie so richtig fest sein muss, aber auch irgendwie nicht richtig und dann kriegt man es nie wieder auf und so weiter. Totaler Scheiß! Es gibt so geile, korrekte, einfache Knoten, die dir Tausende Probleme lösen. Willst du eine Slackline an zwei Bäumen richtig bombenfest machen? Oder zwei Seile bombenfest miteinander verbinden? Das ist wirklich auf gar keinen Fall ausnahm.
Ja, irgendwo was ranhängen, was dann aber sich nicht weiter zuziehen darf.
Genau, oder es gibt einen Knoten, den machst du an einem anderen Seil fest und der hat nur in eine Richtung Halt. Das ist halt, wenn du so ein Seil irgendwo an der Kurbel eingespannt hast und dann sind noch diese Stopperklemmen. Und manchmal ist der Zug so stark, dass du die Klemmen halt nicht mehr aufkriegst. Das heißt, was du dann machst, ist, du machst ein anderes Seil an dem Seil vor der Klemmen fest, gibst dir mal so einen kleinen Entlastungsdruck, damit du die Klemmen aufkriegst. Dafür brauchst du halt einen Knoten, der an einem Seil hält und in eine Zugrichtung sich dann nicht mehr bewegt. Und so lauter, so geiles Zeug. Und niemand lernt das, warum auch immer.
Ja, das ist in der Tat, das müsste eigentlich ein eigenes Fach sein. Stattdessen hatte ich Altgriechisch. Da kann ich vielleicht noch einen Satz.
Okay, ich hab fürs Outro heute dann das perfekte Video.
Noch eins. Nicht verraten.
Ja, also das Video, aber machen wir gleich. Also, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Es gibt tausende Apps, wo gezeigt wird, wie man angeblich Knoten toll macht. Ich würde sagen, alle sind scheiße. Ich hab keine einzige gefunden, die wirklich so, wo du von der grafischen Darstellung als auch dem User-Interface irgendwie sagst, ja, so hab ich mir das vorgestellt. Die einzige App, die ich jetzt eigentlich noch drauf gelassen hab, ist tatsächlich Knotz 3D. Und die ist auch nicht geil, aber sie ist, wie du vorhin im Intro schon so schön wiederholt sagtest, von den Kackhaufen, ist das eigentlich besser, wenn der wärmer ist? Oder ist kalt nicht eigentlich besser?
Es wird dabei auch nochmal gezielt offen gelassen.
Also auf jeden Fall sagen wir mal, der weniger schlimme ist Knotz 3D. Weil zumindest, wenn du dann den Knoten gefunden hast, den du gerne hättest in diesem beknackten User-Interface, dann ist diese dreidimensionale Darstellung schon ganz hilfreich, um zu sehen, was da passiert.
Ja, aber ich tue mich meistens immer schon mit dieser Kategorisierung schwer. Ich sehe jetzt gerade hier auf dem Screenshot von der Webseite von Noskrizi, Boating, Camping, das ist nicht meine Anforderung. Meine Anforderung ist, ich will einen Knoten der folgende Eigenschaft. Ich will über die Eigenschaften auf den Knoten, ob der jetzt beim Camping oder beim Climbing oder keine Ahnung, ob der dekorativ ist, pisst die Wand an. Ich will einfach eine App haben, die mir einfach in dem Moment den Knoten, die Lösungen liefert, dass es sich nicht löst. Und zwar auf die richtige Art und Weise.
Also es gibt, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel Dinge an Steben festmachen, Seile an Seile festmachen, also Schlingeln, Schlaufen, die sich entweder noch weiter zuziehen oder die sich nicht zuziehen.
Oder wo man auch nicht rankommt oder wo es nur ein dünnes Loch ist.
Oder all solche Anforderungen halt. Ja, sowas habe ich noch nicht gefunden. Wenn einer der oder eine der Hörerinnen das kennt, da wäre ich auch sehr dankbar für. Andererseits, es gibt eine Webseite, die ist auch eher aus der Kategorie letztes Jahr 1000 in Sachen Gestaltung und Benutzerfreundlichkeit. Das heißt animatedknots.com glaube ich. Und da gibt es zumindest eine sehr umfassende Liste von wirklich allen möglichen Knoten. Und ich würde sagen, wenn du dich dann halt so mal, was die halt ganz schön gemacht haben, da steht zu jedem Knoten, wofür der ist und woher er kommt und warum und wieso. Also du kriegst sozusagen zumindest eine ganze Menge Kontext dazu. Und wenn du halt zum Beispiel wirklich sagen würdest, okay, ich guck mir jetzt die... Hier unten gibt es nämlich so eine kleine Kategorie, so was Hitches, Bends, Loops, Stoppers, Slide Grip. Da kommst du zumindest schon mal so grob in die Kategorie rein. Und wenn du dir dann, genau, wenn du dir dann zu den ersten Paar halt, die dir irgendwie sinnvoll aussehend erscheinen, einfach auch noch durchliest, wofür die sind und wofür sie eingesetzt werden, dann macht man sich halt im Prinzip so eine eigene kleine Hitliste. Beim Segeln sind es wirklich sechs Standardknoten, die immer kommen und damit löst du halt eben auch schon den Großteil aller Probleme.
Die haben aber auch eine App.
Ja, wahrscheinlich natürlich. Aber es ist, glaube ich, auch nur ein Rapper um diese supergute Webseite.
Deswegen gibt es das auch für Windows.
Ja, kann sein, dass ich mich täusche, aber ich glaube, es war so. Aber auch die haben halt dann auch die Knotenanimierung, also wie man den dann bindet, der ist okay. Man kommt damit klar. Es könnte schöner sein, aber es funktioniert. Aber auf jeden Fall auf der Seite, da hast du gefühlt wirklich alle Varianten bis hin zu Kinky Sailing.
Oh Gott, jetzt ist doch der Podcast wieder nicht jugendfrei.
Kreativer Umgang mit dem Medium halten. Also da sind auf jeden Fall ein paar Knoten dabei, wo da stehen dann zwar so Anwendungsfälle wie ja, also damit könnte man, da könnten jetzt also die Füße könnten da so rein, dann könnte man eine Person damit vielleicht irgendwie irgendwo hochziehen oder so, aber es ist so, ja okay. Aber vielleicht ist man da so als moderner Großstädter auch irgendwie zu vorgebeten.
Ich brauch nur Hip-Sock-Knoten. Muss schick aussehen, wenn ich meine Krawatte so binde.
Aber meine Empfehlung wäre tatsächlich, guck dir ansonsten einfach die Kategorie Boating, Hiking und Climbing an. Du wirst feststellen, da sind viele Knoten, die sich auch überlagern und dann hast du da auf jeden Fall auch die ganzen Problemlöser mit dabei.
Das ist ja geil hier, ein Eis-Splice. Wow, das sieht ja fancy-schmancy aus.
Ja, sowas ist dann das Advanced-Level, wenn du wirklich auf dem Boot lebst und irgendwann anfängst, deine eigenen Seile zu splicen und so. Und zu verbinden, also kannst du halt auch zwei unterschiedliche Seile so miteinander knüppern, dass die zu einem werden und so.
Es gibt auf YouTube ziemlich geile Videos von so riesengroßen Maschinen, die so große Schiffstauern machen. Und die müssen sich ja so ineinander verdrehen und so. Und da gibt es so Dinger, die kommen so in so einen riesen Raum, so tonheilend groß. Da sind dann irgendwie zwölf so riesengroße Rollen schon mit Seilen, die schon irgendwie abendig sind. Und die werden dann wiederum zusammengedreht, um dann wieder so einen riesen Tau irgendwie für so einen Megadampfer zu machen. Und das sieht schon geil aus, was da so abgeht. Auch hier in Berlin im Technischen Museum, da ist das gleiche Ding in klein, wie so ein Miniseilchen machen und wie sich da auch schon jede Rolle um jede andere so drumrum drehen kann. Und du kannst ja auch selber ankurbeln, dieses Teil, das ist nicht motorgetrieben, sondern du kannst da selber drehen und dann entsteht da so das Seil. Das ist schon ein cooles Zeug, fand ich. Ja, such mal raus das Video.
Ich poste dir jetzt ja auch mal ein Video noch kurz in die Show Notes rein oder in den Chat, weil also dieser Trucker's Hitch, das ist ein real existierender Knoten, der beim Segeln eigentlich so gut wie keine Anwendung findet. Aber da gibt es halt so ein Video von I'm on a Boat oder so, du weißt schon so ein bisschen. Und das Witzige ist eigentlich, es gibt schon so ein witziges Video über diesen Trucker's Hitch, wo so eine Folklore-Band den Knoten vortanzt. Und dieses Video ist jetzt sozusagen noch auf Segeln bezogen. Und er guckt auch dieses Video von dieser Folklore-Band, die tanzt, um rauszufinden, wie man diesen Knoten macht. Und dieses Lied ist einfach golden. Also jeder Segler, auch von dieser Crew jetzt, also von der Dayskipper Crew, niemand kannte dieses Video und alle lagen am Boden vor Freude, weil das ist einfach schön gemacht. Also du kannst es auch anspielen, das funktioniert auch ohne Video, aber mit Video ist es noch besser. Für die, die dann später mal... Also du kannst ja nur mal kurz so anspielen, wie es so klingt. Ah nee, jetzt genau.
Da kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern.
Ich hab das schon gesehen.
Genau, das ist jetzt dieses andere Video, wo ich es schon vortanze.
Na ja gut.
Und so weiter. Ihr könnt euch dann mal noch mal in Ruhe zu Gemüte führen, ist auf jeden Fall sehr witzig.
Ich will keine Seildreh-Videos auf die Schnelle.
Also auf jeden Fall könnt ihr gerne uns noch mal, falls ihr noch Tipps habt für kategorisierte Knoten-Anleitungen, gerne noch ein paar Kommentare hinterlassen. Wie gesagt, Animated Notes war wirklich am Ende das, wo ich am öftesten rauf geklickt habe.
Vorhin wurde hier noch kurz die Wikipedia-Seite Knoten-Theorie aufgerufen. Das finde ich auch bemerkenswert. Allein schon der Einstieg hier. Die Knoten-Theorie ist ein Forschungsgebiet der Topologie. Sie beschäftigt sich unter anderem damit, die topologischen Eigenschaften von Knoten zu untersuchen. Eine Fragestellung ist, ob zwei gegebenen Knoten äquivalent sind, also ob sie ineinander überführt werden können, ohne dass dabei die Schnur zerschnitten wird. Knoten-Theorie beschäftigt sich im Gegensatz zur Knotenkunde nicht mit dem Knüpfen von Knoten in der Praxis, sondern mit mathematischen Eigenschaften von Knoten.
Womit Leute ihre Zeit verbringen.
Meine erste Postkarte nach Hause hier von Klassenfahrt irgendwie in Grundschule war von Amrum, war natürlich auch eine Postkarte mit den ganzen Knoten drauf, weil fand ich geil.
Ja, ist auch super. Ich finde auch so ein richtig gut gemachter Knoten, der dann auch genau das liefert, was man in dem Moment einfach braucht. Das hat einfach, das liefert einfach eine irre Befriedigung. Und du hast das schon gut gesagt. Also das ist etwas, das gehört in die Schule. In der Schule müsste es eigentlich so ein Fach geben. Leben. Das ist eine ganz gute Bezeichnung. Ich war gerade noch am suchen, wie man das jetzt so realität.
Wir Nerds haben dann auch wieder andere Ansprüche als Leute, die jetzt heutzutage Kunst machen und andere Leute, die keine Ahnung was machen. Also jeder hat ja natürlich irgendwie, denkt sich Scheiße, warum ist das, was ich jetzt mache, warum habe ich das früher nicht ordentlich in der Schule gelernt? Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man da so...
Realitätskunde.
So Life-Hacks, einfach so Sachen, die einfach geil sind irgendwie und die vor allem täglich irgendwie aus diesem Internet rauspurzeln. Ich meine, da musst du als Lehrer eigentlich auch nichts dafür mehr machen, als YouTube-Videos gucken den ganzen Tag und die dann irgendwie vermitteln. Und ich meine, knuten mal ehrlich. Also, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal eine... Ja, da kannst du dich wahrscheinlich ein halbes Jahr mit beschäftigen. Und ich meine, weißt du ja, wie das ist, wenn du das irgendwie sowas so 8-Jährigen vorgießt. Oh, wow! Ich meine, danach kannst du dich wahrscheinlich in deiner Wohnung nicht mehr frei bewegen, aber...
Nee, weil du püschfest gedingstfristig... Irgendwie sowas? Mit kinky nods. Die Wörter kinky sailing.
Naja, also könnte es schlimmer kommen, ne? Weil irgendwann brauchst du den Scheiß halt auch mal. Also es sind so Momente... Auch so Pfeifen. Ich kann ja nie laut pfeifen.
Pfeifen muss pfeifen können.
Könnt ihr laut pfeifen?
Ich kann nicht so...
Wir können es alle nicht.
Die lautesten hier, die mit zwei Fingern oder irgendwie komischen Griffen im Mund, die dann wirklich so brachial laut sind, das hab ich nie gecheckt, wie das geht.
Genau, so was gehört auch an die Schule.
Das machen die da auch, nur ohne Lehrer. Du hast die falschen Kumpels gehabt.
Natürlich hatte ich die falschen Kumpels. Aber das ist einfach wichtig. Also es ist hilfreich.
Stimmt schon, ja. Also vor allen Dingen, wenn du mal gerade Pfeifen-Signal geben willst.
Ja, also als Notsignal. Ich meine, wie machst du dich laut bemerkbar? Das ist gar nicht so einfach, weil laut schreien ist im Wesentlichen eine Eigenschaft deiner Stimme. Aber laut Pfeifen ist eine Kunst und die kann man erlernen. Und da kriegst du halt einfach den lautestmöglichen Sound. Also ich kenne nichts Lauteres, was Menschen von sich geben können, als so ein richtiger...
Whistle.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt. Wie nennt man den? Ja, Pfff. Ich meine, ist auch ein Pfiff, aber das ist ja nicht laut. Aber so richtig dieses laute Pfeifen, da gibt es bestimmt auch irgendwie eine Wikipedia-Seite zu, oder? Pfeifkunde, Pfeifkunde.
Ich weiß, dass ich mich beim Üfen immer voll gesabbert habe und dann habe ich gelassen.
Ja, also genau, das ist aber tatsächlich eine Frage, die mich schon eine Weile begleitet. Wie lernt man das mit diesen Fingern da in der Gusche zu pfeifen? Gibt es da auch animatedwhistles.com oder so?
Das ist viel Geduld und Üben und so. Ich konnte mal so die beiden Hände zusammen machen, so dass die Daumen nebeneinander liegen und dass da so ein Spalt ist und da so rein pfeifen. Und das wurde mit ziemlich viel Üben auch ziemlich laut, aber das ist dann auch als Kid. Dann rennst du jeden Tag so rum und pfeifst da die ganze Zeit bis du irgendwann das drauf hast, wann so die richtige Stelle ist, aber hab ich auch verlieren kann ich irgendwie nicht mehr. Hab mal probiert und das geht nicht mehr.
Ich weiß halt überhaupt gar nicht, was diese Finger da im Maul überhaupt sollen, beim Pfeifen.
Ich glaube, der Trick ist, dass du die Zunge irgendwie rollst. Das ist auch das, was man mit einer Hand macht, so einen Ring quasi rein, legst irgendwie deine Zunge in so eine feste Position und dann schaffst du quasi dieselbe Konzentration wie eben so in einer Flütte auch, oder eine Trompete, also du baust quasi deinen Mund um, um da diese Luftverengung zu schaffen, dass wenn du da halt Luft raus donnerst. Aber ich meine, das ist so wie Flaschen mit einem Feuerzeug aufmachen, das hat man dann halt irgendwann raus oder halt Schuhe zu knoten. Das hätte ich ja jetzt nicht gedacht, das hätte ich ja auch glaube ich schon irgendwann schon mal untergebracht, aber dieser Ihen-Knoten, dieser Ihen-Not.
Was meint ihr denn für den Schuhreiz?
Genau. Neu relativ, also den gibt es jetzt auch schon lange.
Also eigentlich der den normalen Knoten macht, den man schon hat, aber er wickelt ihn halt anders, was viel schneller geht, das war der, oder?
Na er hält auch viel besser. Also es gibt ja, also Ihen...
Ich bin der Meinung, das ist genau der, den ich schon mache, nur ich mache ihn halt auf die langsame Methode und er macht den ultraschnell irgendwie.
Ja, also es gibt Ihen, die Schuhles-Side, können wir ja nochmal erwähnen, das ist ja in dem Zusammenhang...
Ja auch schon mal, ne?
Ja genau, hatten wir schon mal und da gibt es ganz viele Knoten, die auch sagen wir mal so dekorativ sind und pipa po. Aber der Knaller ist einfach dieser Urknoten von ihm, der Ihen-Not. Und den habe ich mal gelernt und ich kann gar nicht mehr anders meine Schuhe zumachen. Den mache ich nur.
Aber auch so wie er den macht, weil ich meine...
Genau so.
Okay, weil ich habe es mal verglichen und so wie ich meinen Schuh binde, das ist genau dieser Knoten so, bloß dass ich das nicht so fix mache wie er, sondern so ganz normal mit einem umlegen, den anderen und so weiter. Aber da kommt genau der Knoten bei raus.
Ja gut, den kannst du effizienter machen, so wie du das machst.
Aber das ist nicht so leicht, das muss man halt auch eine Weile üben. Das ist nicht so von heute auf morgen.
Das ist einfach. Also ich würde sagen der Ihen-Knoten ist wirklich sehr einfach und vor allem ist es ja dann auch sofort genauso einfach ein Doppelknoten. Und der Ihen-Knoten ist halt gleichmäßig. Du hast halt nicht dieses komische Rumwickeln, denn dieser normale Rumwickelknoten ist halt irgendwie inherent asymmetrisch. Und der Ihen-Knoten ist halt symmetrisch, hält sehr gut und lässt sich sehr leicht auch wieder aufmachen und lässt sich auch als Doppelknoten leicht aufmachen, aber hält halt trotzdem Bombe. Also Leute, ich habe das schon mal gesagt, ich sage es nochmal, lernt diesen Ihen-Knoten. Für euch ist einfach, ihr werdet einfach der Freak Show ewig dankbar sein und ihr werdet euch fragen, was ihr eigentlich die anderen 30 Jahre in eurem Leben vorher gemacht habt mit euren Schuhen, weil es hätte einfach alles so schön sein können. Wenn ihr mal ordentlich Pfeifen gelernt hättet und ordentlich Knoten gelernt hättet und all diesen ganzen Klimpeln.
Dann müssen wir wieder mehr über Max reden, oder?
Ja, du hast recht. Lass mal wieder mehr. Aber wir wollten auch noch über Geld reden. Ja, wollen wir es nicht vorher noch machen? Ja, wir haben keine Ahnung. Also ich bin natürlich jetzt in letzter Zeit häufiger mal gefragt worden, wie ich denn das jetzt so mit Flatter sehe.
Ach, das Geld, ja verstehe.
Genau, das Geld und überhaupt und diese ganze, ich habe mich da jetzt wirklich schon längere Zeit nicht mehr zu geäußert. Das heißt nicht, dass ich mich nicht mit dem Thema beschäftigt habe. Wer unser Treiben schon eine Weile verfolgt, weiß ja, dass ich da bei Flatter immer sehr dahinter stand hinter der Idee, tue ich im Prinzip auch immer noch, das gleich mal dazuzusagen. Jetzt ist es halt so mit Flatter ein bisschen schwierig geworden. Also vielleicht noch mal kurz die Idee. Die Idee von Flatter ist halt, man organisiert halt Geldbeschaffungen und Verteilungen im Internet, um Leuten, die welches brauchen und die in irgendeiner Form irgendwelche kulturellen Dienstleistungen erbringen, die halt mit so einem Geldregen zu besorgen. Und dahinter steckt halt der alte Traum des Micropayments, der ja auch schon so fast so alt ist wie das Web. Also wir haben schon immer so ein bisschen überlegt so, ja es wäre ja mal schön, wenn man so jenseits der über steigerten Transaktionsgebühren und aufwendigen Zahlungswege etc. einfach einen Weg finden kann, wie man also die Gießkanne über das Netz halten kann und dann idealerweise möglichst genau die Fleckchen trifft, wo halt die hübschesten Blumen wachsen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das eigentliche Ziel. Da hat sich dann in den letzten Jahren auch eine ganze Menge getan. Da gibt es dann so einerseits diese ganze Crowdfunding-Bewegung, die ja nicht so ganz unerfolgreich war mit Kickstarter etc. Ist natürlich dann wie alles erst mal ein bisschen total überhypt worden und dann kam so der Post-Hype und dann war das alles scheiße und scheitern ja alle und kriegt meine Produkte nicht und überhaupt ein Crowdfunding ist tot. Das ist immer genau der Moment, wo es interessant wird. Übrigens ist, das kann ich leider noch mal dazu sagen, bei Kickstarter, habt ihr das mitbekommen? Das ist ja offenbar eines der wenigen Projekte, wo die Leute ihr Hirn noch behalten haben. Also man hat ja, gerade wenn es um Geld geht, alle irgendwie durchdrehen sehen. PayPal, lalalala, alle sind irgendwie evil geworden und Money, Money, Money und Revenue und Hass nicht gesehen. Und Kickstarter hat tatsächlich seine Geschäftsform geändert und ist jetzt eine der wenigen Companies in den USA überhaupt, die ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht ganz genau, wie die offizielle Bezeichnung ist, muss ich gleich mal nachschlagen, aber im Prinzip so eine Art gemeinnütziges Unternehmen geworden ist. Das heißt, dass sie halt quasi ein anderes Profit-Modell haben und ich habe so ein Interview gelesen mit den Faunern und die halt so, ja wir wollen halt irgendwie was, wir wollen halt auch mal was ändern und es geht hier jetzt nicht nur darum, die meiste Kohle abzuziehen. Keine Ahnung, wie es jetzt so im Einzelnen persönlich so ergangen ist. Die werden sicherlich nicht so gelitten haben unter dieser ganzen gehaltenen Phase, aber heißt ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt, dass dann alle unbedingt jetzt diesen Weg gehen. Also das könnte dann auch noch mal sehr interessant werden mit Kickstarter in the long run und vor allem macht es so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, als ob das Projekt, das war vielleicht eh klar, auch nicht weggehen wird. Also es wird irgendwie immer da sein und ich bin da jetzt sehr viel gespannter, wie sich das entwickelt als vor kurzem noch. Aber Crowdfunding ist ja jetzt nicht so ein Modell, um dauerhaft Projekte oder einzelne Personen mit so einem Funding zu versorgen, sondern da ging es halt immer um das Projekt, um das Ziel. Ich will Produkt X machen und dafür brauche ich eine Anschubfinanzierung und dafür, dass ihr mich daran unterstützt, da gibt es dann irgendwie Wimpel und Kapitassen, Aufkleber und Perks halt, was in dem Zusammenhang, glaube ich, auch als Incentive ganz gut funktioniert hat. Flatter war dann im Prinzip ein ganz anderer Ansatz von Leuten, die halt auch sehr viel mehr so das Internet geatmet haben und das Web auch und dann halt so diese Idee gehabt haben, naja, okay, du machst dir halt eine Flatrate und das finde ich auch nach wie vor einen der bestechenden Gedanken dabei. Du sagst einfach, wie viel Geld bist du bereit dem Netz zu geben? Das legst du fest, du schiebst deine Funs halt so hin und sagst, okay, was weiß ich, hier 10, 15, 20 Euro, wie viel auch immer, pro Monat kann ich mir einfach leisten. Also ob ich die jetzt irgendwie in Milchcafés absetze oder ob ich die halt einfach mal übers Netz regnen lasse, macht für mich persönlich jetzt nicht so den entscheidenden Unterschied und unter Umständen fühle ich mich halt auch grundsätzlich schon mal besser, weil ich es halt eben nicht in Milchcafé investiere. Und Flatter wollte dann einfach dieser Verteilungsmotor sein, wollten sozusagen einen Mechanismus gebären, der genau dieses Geld einnimmt und dann eben diese Gießkanne macht, aber eben die Gießkanne dabei so feintunen, dass ihr eben die richtigen Stellen trifft. Und da war dann die ursprüngliche Idee halt diese Flatter-Buttons, sprich das Ganze im Web zu machen. Das Ganze ist ja gestartet vor acht Jahren.
Schon eine Weile her auf jeden Fall.
So die Größenordnung, oder was? Ne, sieben Jahre. 2010 war es jetzt glaube ich fast nicht so ganz klar. Und es ist eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wie ich finde, schon so die richtige Antwort gewesen auf das Web, wie es damals war. Blogs waren da ein Ding. Das heißt, diese ganzen Präsenzen der Leute, an die jetzt hier eigentlich primär gedacht wurde, waren eigentlich so eigene Webseiten, eigenes Auftreten im Web, vor allem halt Blogs und dann eben auch Podcasts, die auch eine gewisse Hoheit darüber hatten, wie sie jetzt sich ins Web abbilden. Das heißt, man hat eine Blog-Software genommen, Flatter konnte sich dann relativ gut einblenden und auf einmal tauchten überall diese Flatter-Buttons auf und dann war halt das Credo mit klickst du halt einen Button für irgendwas, was du gut findest und dann ist halt die Person im nächsten Monatsturnus im Verteilungssystem mit drin. So, das ganze ist in den letzten Jahren ein bisschen gegen die Wand gefahren, dadurch, dass wir natürlich das Facebook oder sagen wir mal etwas allgemeiner das Plattformenproblem bekommen haben, dass wir einfach gesehen haben, dass dieses ganze Self-Hosting aus vielen auch nachvollziehbaren Gründen vollkommen ins Hintertreffen geraten ist und dass die Plattform-Anbieter einfach da den längeren Hebel hatten und die Leute einfach sich im Wesentlichen da tummeln. Wenn du heute irgendwie auf der Welt rum fragst, ob die Leute irgendwie das Internet benutzen, sagen die ja, nee, Internet benutze ich nicht, ich benutze Facebook. Das meinen die dann auch ganz ernst, weil die halt irgendwie, weil das für sie was anderes ist und überhaupt nicht schnallen, was das überhaupt miteinander zu tun haben könnte. Ja und dann gab es dann mal diese zweite Phase und das war dann das andere Versprechen, was bei Flatter eigentlich da war, dass es ja einfach so automatisierbar war, dass man eben gesagt hat, ja okay, lass uns quasi zumindest im Falle des Medienkonsums, sprich Podcasts in unserem Fall, baut man das doch einfach direkt mit ein. Dann haben wir es ja mal geschafft, das irgendwie da bei Instacast unterzubringen und dann kam Instacast mit diesem Feature in den App Store, man konnte quasi direkt aus der App diesen ganzen Flatterkram machen, sodass automatisch alles quasi angeklickt wurde, was gehört wurde oder wie auch immer man das eben dann im Einzelnen konfiguriert hat. Und das ging total durch die Decke. Also das waren so drei Monate, wo man gemerkt hat, so wow, das war jetzt genau der Kick, der gebraucht wurde. Also in meiner Perspektive war das so eine Verdreif, Verfünf- bis Verzehnfachung der Aktivität innerhalb von drei Monaten. Also waren dann mehr Klicks, das heißt jetzt nicht in demselben Maße mehr Geld, weil es ist ja nicht automatisch mehr Geld drin, sondern nur so mehr Verteilungsdynamik. Aber hätte das halt angehalten, dann bin ich mir relativ sicher, hätten wir dann ein paar goldene Jahre gehabt. Kam aber nicht so, weil, nächstes Plattformproblem, Apple hat einfach zu viel Video zu Martin Hering, der auch schon mal hier gesagt hat so, ja, schöne Idee, die du da hast, aber nö. Und dann so, ja, warum? Ja, sagen wir dir nicht, weil, geht nicht und lass es einfach sein und nein, brauchst auch nie anfangen zu diskutieren, unsere Antwort ist einfach nein. Apple sah halt das nicht als erforderlich an, das zu erklären, ist aber schnell erklärt, da macht jemand was mit Geld auf eine Art und Weise, die unter Umständen ein Konflikt gerät, mit dem wir das hier uns mit dem Geld gedacht haben, wir brauchen das nicht, also lassen wir es erstmal weg. Klassischer Marktausschluss ist natürlich ein Problem. In der Android-Welt gibt es das Feature noch, es gibt hier Podcast-Client, hier Antennapod, etc. Also diverse, ich kann sie jetzt gerade nicht alle aufzählen, aber es gibt so vier, fünf verschiedene Podcast-Apps, die haben diese Integration und da funktioniert das im Prinzip auch noch genauso und das ist eigentlich auch gut so. Nur wissen wir ja auch, trotz der angeblich so hohen Android-Zahlen, die Dynamik, diese User-Dynamik, die steckt auch im Wesentlichen immer noch in der iOS-Welt. So oder so, dadurch, dass einfach Flatter an der Stelle eben ganz klar einfach eine Grenze gesetzt bekommen hat, die zumindest sagt, so hier geht's in dieses Universum, kommt ihr nicht rein, ist damit natürlich diese ganze Dynamik dahingewiesen. Das hat dann auch Flatter so ein bisschen, glaube ich, Probleme bereitet. Waren sie dann also noch in den ersten drei Jahren nach Start so mit Investment und 15 Leuten da in Schweden aktiv, ist das Ganze halt auf die zwei Kern-Founder zusammen geschrumpft, die das so nebenbei, neben ihrem sonstigen Leben noch betrieben haben, bis heute eigentlich auch am Laufen gehalten haben. Irgendwann dann halt eine 2.0-Version gemacht haben, die gut gemeint war, aber die dann wiederum andere Probleme mit sich gebracht hat.
Dass man hier dieses S nicht mehr direkt auszahlen konnte, sondern über diese andere Auszahlbude da. Nicht PayPal, sondern...
Ja, das ist, sagen wir mal, Version 1.1. Also ursprünglich lief das Ganze nur mit PayPal. Dann haben sie sich halt bemüht, weil viele Leute halt gesagt haben, PayPal ist evil, scheiße, doof, was auch immer. Choose your color. Übrigens eine Meinung, die bei Flatter auch genauso vorherstellt. Ich meine, es ist irgendwie Petersunde und wir wissen Petersunde, PayPal und so weiter. Da gab es schon immer laute Kritik, nur die Optionen waren halt jetzt nicht so zahlreich. Dann kamen halt Moneybookers in Europa mit auf den Markt und machte den Eindruck, zumindest erstmal eine Alternative zu sein. Das war dann im Prinzip so ein bisschen dasselbe in Grün. Leicht andere Kosten, Service-Dienstleistungsbezahlstruktur, aber lief am Ende aufs Gleiche raus. Dann gab es halt diese beiden und später, das war dann so der erste blöde Schritt, den sie so gemacht haben, haben sie dann irgendwie PayPal rausgeschmissen, weil sie an einer neuen Lösung gearbeitet haben und haben dann so PayPal so ein bisschen vorzeitig rausgeworfen.
Und haben dann Skrill genommen.
Genau, Moneybookers, Skrill ist dasselbe.
Ach so, echt?
Die haben sie unbenannt. Also Skrill ist dieses Moneybookers, genau.
Ja, das war auf jeden Fall ein scheiß Move, weil vorher konnte man sein Geld zu PayPal schieben und dann konnte man irgendwann bei eBay mal irgendwas mit PayPal bezahlen und ich musste das nicht erst auf mein Konto schieben. So als sie dann Skrill genommen haben, musste ich es erst von Flatter zu Skrill schieben. Da konnte man aber nicht wirklich irgendwas mit bezahlen. Das heißt erst von da auf mein Konto, um es dann wieder ausgeben zu können. Also es ist dann so viele Wege gelaufen, das war ein bisschen nervig. Und jetzt haben sie aber inzwischen auch Moneybookers Skrill wieder rausgeschmissen. Jetzt kann man direkt auch sein Konto überweisen von Flatter, richtig?
Richtig, wobei es jetzt weniger ein Haben rausgeschmissen ist, als vielmehr, es war ja am Anfang etwas Confusing mit Flatter, weil du hattest ja im Prinzip zwei Kontostände immer. Wenn du irgendwie deine Flatter-Webseite angeschaut hast, dann hast du so, was du eingezahlt hast zum Verteilen, das war so der eine Amount, und das andere ist, was du bekommen hast. Und man wunderte sich halt immer so, könnte die beiden Zahlen nicht zusammenzählen? Konnten sie nicht aus einem einfachen Grund. Rechtlich war nämlich und ist, also ich weiß gar nicht, wie es jetzt ist, aber ich glaube der Status hat sich nicht geändert. Rechtlich handelt es sich bei Flatter um einen sogenannten Money Agent. Money Agent ist so eine Definition im Rahmen des Zahlungsverkehrs, die man sein kann, der also auf EU-Ebene definiert ist, der aber nur in UK rechtlich auch wirklich umgesetzt worden ist. Deswegen gab es auch immer noch so ein Flatter UK Büro, was das dann irgendwie proxymäßig gehalten hat. Und als solcher darfst du aber quasi nur Geld durchleiten. Dieses Zusammenführen des Kontos.
Du darfst keine User-Konten führen, weil dann wärst du ja eine Bank.
Genau.
Das haben die bei Bitcoin auch alle. Das ist genau das Ding.
Genau. Und das ist Confusing, aber das ist halt einfach so ein Ding. Hätte man lösen können, wenn man eine Bank gefunden hätte, mit der man einfach mal über das Internet sprechen kann, was aber auch irgendwie nicht einfach ist. Also dieses ganze Bankensystem ist nach wie vor in Europa, trotz SEPA, alles so nationalisiert. Und die haben einfach zahlreiche Anläufe dort gestartet. Haben aber einfach keinen Partner gefunden, mit dem das auch einfach nur technisch gegangen wäre. Geschweige denn, dass die sich dann auch so ohne weiteres auf so ein Internetunternehmen mit hier, wir haben ja mal eine tolle Idee mit Geld, einfach mal so einlässt.
Also in den ganzen Bitcoin-Unternehmen genau die gleichen Probleme. Also hier Bitwaller und so auch irgendwie eher so im Ausland ihre Standorte und nicht hier, weil es geht nicht. Dann brauchen sie eine Bank als Partner, weil sonst kannst du keine Konten führen oder kein Geld verwalten. Und das sind genau die gleichen Probleme. Und jetzt gerade geht es vielleicht ein bisschen dank Blockchain, weil da stehen die Banken ja so ein bisschen drauf. Das ist sehr hip und macht sich ja gut auf der Webseite. Aber da hat Flatter jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder schlechte Karten, weil die ganzen Bitcoin-Leute oder Blockchain-User das irgendwie bei den Banken abgreifen, die Connections. Und die Banken gerade gar keinen Bock auf Flatter haben, weil sie andere haben.
Ja gut, ich meine Flatter ist jetzt einfach nicht so ein großer Player, dass sie jetzt in irgendeiner Form irgendeine durchdringende Macht darstellen wird. Das ist jetzt ein kleines Projekt geworden, geblieben, je nachdem, wie man es sieht. Tatsache ist, sie wollten halt eine Anbindung an das SEPA-System haben. Und das haben sie jetzt dadurch gefunden, indem sie halt einen anderen Dienstleister genommen haben, nämlich MangoPay. MangoPay stellt dir quasi eine Wallet als Dienstleistung bereit. Das heißt, die haben den Status, um so eine Wallet zu führen. Und die haben auch diese ganzen SEPA-Connections. Und du bindest dann quasi nur noch diese Wallet über eine API ein. Und das war dann quasi neu, aber das war dann genau das, was sie brauchten. Weil ihnen ging es ja nicht darum, selber unbedingt das Geld zu halten. Ihnen geht es ja nur um die Verteilungsmechanik. Und die haben sie ja implementiert. Und dann, nach dieser Umstellung vor zwei Jahren, zwei Jahren, weiß ich es gar nicht, zwei Jahren, lief es dann eigentlich so, wie man es haben wollte. Man musste halt nicht mehr über PayPal gehen. Und damit hat es halt auch dieses...
Aber die Userzahlen waren auch schon deutlich gesunken, ne?
Ja, vermutlich. Also ich kenne jetzt keine konkreten Userzahlen, aber ich habe es natürlich auch so ein bisschen gesehen daran, wie die Aktivität jetzt bei mir anbrandet. Und es hat sich dann noch erstaunlich lange gehalten. Erst jetzt die letzten 12, 18 Monate nimmt es doch sehr stark ab. So, jetzt Breaking News. Gar nicht so Breaking. Aber dadurch sind halt viele jetzt auf das Thema nochmal aufmerksam geworden. Hat ja ausgerechnet Ayo, also die Bude, die AdBlock Plus macht, dieser AdBlocker, der einen etwas schlechten Ruf hat.
Ja, man kann noch mal kurz erklären warum, weil sonst geht das vielleicht unter. Also es gibt ja diesen AdBlock Plus, also vorher gab es AdBlock, die haben dann halt AdBlock Plus rausgebracht. Damit kann man ganz praktischerweise, kann man Werbung blocken im Safari, Chrome, Firefox, da gibt es hier wahrscheinlich auch alles und der blendet prima die Werbung aus. Aber der hat sich dann sein Geschäftsmodell so überlegt, dass er das ja ausnutzen will, dass er auf Millionen von Computern, dass da seine Extension drauf ist. Und zwar hat er sich das mit dem Konzept gedacht, dass er Acceptable Ads irgendwie einführen will, indem er, ich glaube er hatte ein Deal mit Microsoft dann auch gemacht, das ist seine Vorzeigekunde, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, dass er sagt, hier Microsoft zahlt ein bisschen an die GmbH und dafür lassen sie halt Acceptable Ads von Microsoft halt durch. Also welche, die wohl nicht so animated GIF mäßig sind, die nicht so ganz so doll stressen sollen, das nennen sie dann Acceptable und die kriegt der User dann, der eigentlich dachte, er hätte einen Werbeblocker, der kriegt die dann trotzdem. Das heißt, er setzt sich sozusagen, mähnen sie Mittel zwischen deinem Browser und den Seiten, die du aufrufst, rein, um dann aber zu verkaufen, dass er manche Werbung dann doch durchlässt. Ich finde das ein sehr fragwürdiges Geschäftsmodell und deswegen hat das bei sehr, sehr vielen Leuten angeeckt. Und da ist ja auch sehr, also er streitet sich auch mit sehr vielen Firmen um. Ich glaube mit Axel Springer, die mochten das auch irgendwie nicht. So da ging auch der ganze Streit irgendwie los und die klagen sich da hin und her.
Ja, das ist so die Situation. Und dann haben irgendwie Ayo und Flatter zueinander gefunden, weil sie halt so gegenseitig so ein bisschen die Chance ineinander sahen. Ich teile das nur begrenzt, muss ich sagen. Also die Idee ist halt, Flatter dadurch zu revitalisieren oder überhaupt erst mal zu einer anderen Anwendung zu bringen, wenn man sagt, okay, wir sind jetzt quasi der Verdienstausfall für die Medienseiten. Ja, man tauscht quasi dieses, ich will nicht von dir Werbung und Malware in den Browser geschüttet bekommen, aber dafür bin ich bereit, auch eine Mikrospende zu machen. Und die auf dem Flatter-Modell basierend insofern ja sehr sinnvoll ist, als dass es eben eine Flatrate ist. Ich zahle nicht für jede Webseite, ich sage nur, überall wo ich geblockt werde, hinterlasse ich quasi so einen Klick und damit nimmt es eben Teil an dieser Gießkanne, von der ich aber am Ende nichts Besonderes merke. Also umso mehr ich benutze, umso kleiner werden meine Anteile, aber es gibt zumindest welche. Und das finde ich ja an sich nach wie vor ein sehr charmantes Modell, weil es die Sache einfach so einfach macht. Man sprach ja von Anfang an bei Flatter davon, dass sie halt einfach die mentalen Transaktionskosten senken. Das finde ich ist eigentlich nach wie vor ein wichtiges Ding, nicht nur jetzt bei solchen Bezahlsystemen generell. Sachen, die einfach sind und die einfach wenig Friktion haben, während du sie benutzt, die du im Idealfall einmal einrichtest und danach im Wesentlichen gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenkst. Das sind so die Sachen, wo die Leute dann halt auch mitgehen. Weil du willst ja nicht dich auch noch die ganze Zeit damit beschäftigen. Und schon dieses Aufladen des Kontos und so, das war halt alles ein bisschen blöd. Ja, in der aktuellen Situation auf der Flitter-Webseite, sie haben halt vor allem viele Features rausgenommen. Gut, manche hat man vielleicht nicht gebraucht, aber es ist halt irgendwie auch in dem Sinne nichts gekommen. Und ich habe zum Beispiel auch immer von Anfang an gesagt, Leute, wisst ihr nicht, dass eigentlich die wichtigsten Leute für euch die sind, die im Prinzip davon profitieren, weil das sind die Leute, die ein Interesse daran haben, das auch irgendwie in die Welt zu bringen. Also bitteschön, dann baut doch mal euer System auch so, dass diese Leute sich auch in eurem System präsentieren können. Wieso gibt es da keine Profile-Seite? Wieso kann ich da nicht schreiben, hallo hier, ich bin präsent auf Flitter, das sind meine Projekte, finde andere Dinge, lalala. Und das habe ich eigentlich von Tag 1 eingeklagt und kam nicht. Was dann kam, war Patreon in den USA. Und Patreon hat genau das gemacht. Ja, lustigerweise eigentlich auch nichts anderes als das. Das finde ich auch irgendwie so absurd, dass eigentlich Patreon ist so ein Dienst, wo ich mir echt so ein bisschen am Kopf fasse und frage so, warum soll ich das eigentlich benutzen? Also mich fragen das ja immer wieder so. Warum bist du denn nicht auf Patreon? Ja, weil Patreon mir keine Dienstleistung bereitstellt, die ich mir nicht selber problemlos auch bereitstellen kann. Also wenn Leute sich dafür entscheiden, mich finanziell zu unterstützen, dann können sie das direkt bei mir tun. Dauerauftrag, Paypal-Spende.
Also Konto hast du alles da auf der Seite.
Steht alles auf Metaebene.me. Hinten natschnatsch, ne? Ja, ich mein da gehst du einmal hin und dann kannst du halt selber überlegen, wie du es machen willst. Und Dauerauftrag ist nun mal in Deutschland zumindest die einfachste Form der Geldüberweisung. Ist in der Regel Transaktionskosten frei und im besten Fall reduziert. Kostet also auf jeden Fall nicht so viel Geld wie Paypal. Ich biete das halt trotzdem auch noch mit an mit Paypal, weil es einfach auch Leute gibt, die das bevorzugen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Oder wenn sie im Ausland sind, vielleicht auch nur die einzige Möglichkeit ist das überhaupt zu machen. Paypal hat natürlich da an der Stelle auch starke Nachteile. Nur Patreon wiederum nimmt halt Geld davon noch mal ein, deren Cut ist glaube ich auch 10%.
10?
Ja, das ist schon so. Ich meine, wenn man das mal ausrechnet, das ist so viel für die dann in der Regel auch nicht so, weil wenn du siehst, weil die müssen ja auch noch weitere Transaktionskosten, komme ich auch gleich nochmal dazu, dazuzahlen, also da fällt auch schon nochmal so einiges an, was auch finanziert werden muss und irgendwo musst du halt diesen Cut von nehmen. Klar, wenn jetzt Millionen Leute das benutzen, dann ist das eine andere Geschichte. Flatter hat einfach auch gesagt, zehn Prozent kann man mal mit anfangen.
Die wollten mal runtergehen, sind aber nie runtergegangen.
Genau, sind aber nie runtergegangen, weil Flatter war halt auch nie profitabel. Also Flatter hat da nie den Flatter-Jungs nie Geld gemacht, was sie nicht schon vorher ausgegeben haben durch privates Investment oder eben, indem sie halt da zeitweise eben Investoren gehabt haben, die sicherlich auch nicht so viel davon gesehen haben. Nur Patreon ist halt so an der Stelle für mich halt auch noch so ein Klumpfuß, weil du musst dann halt da präsent sein. Dann musst du dann auch noch, wenn du irgendwelche Sachen veröffentlicht, musst du die dann mehr oder weniger regelmäßig dann da auch immer noch posten. Das geht dann irgendwie auch nicht automatisch. Ist ja immer einfach mal so ein Feed schnappen und dann, ja hier ist mein Podcast, dann zeig das auf deiner scheiß Seite. Dann sind mir die gegangen, nein, muss man einfach in der Hand, mach das mal drei Monate lang nicht, stellen sie halt die Zahlungen ein und so ein Kram. Dann ist halt auch so ein bisschen da diese Crowdfunding-Denke mit irgendwie, jetzt muss ich auch noch irgendwelche Perks und dann auch noch irgendwelche Versprechungen machen, was man dann noch irgendwie anbietet, was auch rein rechtlich noch mal ein Riesenproblem ist, weil wenn du dann irgendwie anfängst, noch irgendwelche Kaffeetassen oder sonst wie Sachen mit ins Spiel zu bringen, dann kriegst du halt da, dann kriegst du das dann, das Finanzt hat halt so richtig den Dudel im Hirn, weil dann sind da so versteckte Dienstleistungen, weißt du, die dann irgendwie geleistet werden und dann muss das irgendwie unter Umständen alles ganz anders abgerechnet werden. Und dabei ist das ohnehin schon so ein Problem, wenn du mit US-amerikanischen Unternehmen zusammenarbeitest, mit solchen Kleinstspenden hin und her, bis die mal geschneit haben, dass sie sich mal irgendwie mal die Umsatzsteuergesetzgebung in Europa mal geben müssen, um überhaupt diesen Scheiß mal richtig zu verbuchen und richtig auszuweisen und die richtigen Paragraphen darauf zu schreiben, dass man das überhaupt legal angeben kann beim Finanzamt, hat schon sehr lange gedauert. Da mussten sie richtig von überzeugt werden. Am Anfang, das wäre eigentlich überhaupt nicht wichtig, weil Europa eh unwichtig und wir verstehen das irgendwie auch alles gar nicht. Und ihr immer mit euren Rechnungen da in Deutschland, was ist denn überhaupt eine Rechnung? Ich meine, kauf mal was in den USA und dann kauf mal ein Stück Software und dann sag mal, hier Rechnung irgendwie, Invoice. Dann kriegst du so eine E-Mail, da steht drin so Invoice, 5 Dollar. Aber es gibt halt da auch nicht so viele Anforderungen, muss man auch verstehen. Also es läuft hier einfach anders. Und unser Fragenkatalog, der sich halt an so einem einzelnen DIN A4-Rechnungszettel abarbeiten muss, der ist ja auch unerreicht. Also was so Steuernummer und unser Steuer-ID und bla, und Adresswohnung, das muss irgendwie alles richtig korrekt spezifiziert sein. Ich verfolge jetzt Patreon nicht so richtig. Also ich benutze das ja nicht als Anbieter und sammel da kein Geld ein. Deswegen weiß ich jetzt nicht, inwiefern sich das jetzt gerade im Backend noch verbessert hat. Da mögen sich Dinge getan haben. Gibt auf jeden Fall noch einen ähnlichen Anbieter, der jetzt hier aus Deutschland sogar aus Berlin kommt.
Kurze Anmerkung noch. Also die Fee ist 5% of your pledges.
Bei Patrons 5%.
Ja und dann gibt es aber halt noch die die Processing-Fees fürs Auszahlen, die aber angeblich üblicherweise unter 5% sind. Also je nachdem, wie die Leute ihre pledges abgeben, fallen halt bei PayPal oder was auch immer noch mal Processing-Fees an.
Genau, dann komm ich gleich noch mal drauf zu, weil das trifft jetzt insbesondere und meiner Meinung nach auch für Patreons zu. Auch wenn das nochmal ein anderer Fall ist. Es gibt jetzt hier Steady, kommt aus dem Crowdreporter-Universum, die ja auch so im Prinzip mal als Crowdfunding-Plattform gestartet haben und Steady ist im Prinzip so ich sag mal so das deutsche Patriot. Ähnliches Modell, du bist dann so auf der Seite, sagst hier hallo ich will Geld, gib mal. Und hier zahlt der, irgendwie machst du den Account bei Steady, klickst mich an, zahlst halt Geld an und wenn du halt 10, 20 Leute unterstützt über diese Plattform, dann wird halt auch nur einmal im Monat bei dir abgebucht. Was dir persönlich ja eigentlich relativ egal sein kann, ob das einmal oder mehrmals abgebucht wird, wenn es nichts kostet. Aber schon, sagen wir mal jetzt für den Abbuchenden, nicht ganz unerheblich ist vom Aufwand her. Und dann wird das halt da in die Rotation gegeben und wird dann eben auch einen Cut von weggenommen und dann landest es wieder bei dir. Soweit die Theorie. Praktisch, und das ist jetzt auch etwas, was mir gerade zu den letzten Wochen jetzt, als ich hier irgendwie diesen ganzen Steuerwahnsinn durchgeritten habe, auch nochmal so richtig klar geworden ist, gibt es ja dann dieses Problem mit der Umsatzsteuer. Wenn du jetzt in Deutschland sowas machst, und du willst so der Proxy sein, und du willst eigentlich ein Kundenverhältnis haben mit den Leuten, die da einzahlen, damit haben sie aber dieses Kundenverhältnis nicht zu mir durchgereicht. Das heißt, jemand, der mir Geld gibt, ist in dem Moment nicht mehr mein Kunde, weil er das mir ja nicht gibt, sondern gibt es ja dem anderen, der es mir dann gibt. Das sind aber dann zwei entkoppelte Dienstleistungen.
Also zweimal Umsatzsteuer.
Ja. Was egal wäre, wenn es sich um dieselbe Umsatzsteuer handelt, was zum Beispiel in meinem Fall nicht der Fall ist. Weil ich kann halt, dadurch, dass das sozusagen, also ich produziere ja quasi urheberrechtliches Material und bin dann so quasi vor dem Finanzamt im Prinzip Radiojournalist. Also genieße quasi dann dieselbe Einstufung.
Kannst du dich nicht mal als Künstler irgendwie da...
Ja, das ist ja im Wesentlichen das. Das sind 7%.
Das andere sind aber 19.
Das andere sind aber 19. Das heißt, die müssen 19% draufschlagen beim Entkundenbezug sozusagen. Die sind dann schon mal irgendwie erstmal weg, weil davon bleibt ja nur der Nettobetrag übrig, der dann irgendwie zu mir geht. Weil die 19% die da eingenommen werden, die gehen ja direkt wieder ins Finanzamt. Das heißt, du hast ja schon mal 19% von deinem Euro sind sozusagen schon mal 19% weg. Dann wird das irgendwie an mich durchgereicht und ich muss davon dann auch nochmal 7% abziehen. Vorher werden aber davon nochmal 10% abgezogen. Weil das ist ja auch noch die Vieh. Die selbst ich jetzt richtig erinnere, das hängt dann so ein bisschen vom Business-Modell ab, was du willst, also wenn du dann du kannst ja auch so als Zahlungsdienstleister, das müsstest du sozusagen machen, dann könntest du sowas auch umsatzsteuerfrei machen und so weiter. Also unterm Strich 30% ab 25-30% verschwinden einfach in dieser ganzen Transaktion. Einfach nur in diesen Steuerreibungen for nothing. Also ohne dass jetzt hier irgendein nennenswerter Mehrwert geschaffen worden wäre. Und ich muss auch mal so ein bisschen zunken, wenn mir Leute so, ich bin ja wirklich sehr dankbar dafür, aber ich krieg dann halt manchmal so PayPal 1 Euro. Ich sehe aber halt auch, dass PayPal sich von diesem 1 Euro halt 37 Cent einfach wegschneidet. Ja, Gebühr. Weil die ist halt prozentual und Mindestbetrag. Das heißt von so einem von denen dann nochmal Umsatzsteuer runter geht. Also das halbiert sich quasi. das ist halt einfach alles nicht effizient. Das sind einfach keine Modelle. Und das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt immer die Schuld dieser Firmen. Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, dass wir quasi in unserem Geldsystem eigentlich für diese ganze Mikrobezahlung und vor allem auch für dieses Unterstützungsdurchleitungs haben wir einfach gar kein Modell. Das ist einfach ein Problem. Man kann das, wenn ich das richtig überblicke, aber da bin ich nun wirklich noch nicht so tief eingetaucht, dass ich das jetzt hier mit Sicherheit sagen könnte. Auch von dem, was ich so gehört habe, wenn man sich als Zahlungsdienstleister in diesem BaFin-System registriert, dann quasi auch als Moneyagent unterwegs ist, dann kann man solche Sachen auch Umsatzsteuer frei machen, entteilen und so weiter. Aber es geht so oder so einfach immer irgendwie Geld weg. Sprich, man muss dann auch ein Case machen, wenn man jetzt so ein Hub sein möchte, dass man auch wirklich einen Mehrwert darstellt. Sowohl für die Leute, die sagen, ich mach das jetzt über den Hub, als auch, insbesondere, für die Leute, die darüber was beziehen können. Klar, jetzt kann man noch mal sagen, mich kennt ja keiner, auf Steady werde ich ja vielleicht gefunden, so kommen die Leute vielleicht überhaupt. Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Versprechende. Du bist auf der Plattform und die Plattform treibt dir dann quasi so die Spenderschafe einfach so zu, die dann irgendwie so, oh, wem kann ich noch mein Geld geben? Ah, hier! Das ist ja noch jemand. Klar, mag sein, kann auch funktionieren. Ich glaube, das hat aber begrenztes Potenzial, weil es am Ende ja dann doch immer noch so eine eins-zu-eins- Beziehung ist zwischen Leuten, die irgendwie was machen und Leuten, die das irgendwie genießen und in irgendeiner Form sich erkenntlich zeigen wollen, weil es halt kostenlos im Angebot ist. Und ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ist schwierig mit diesen ganzen Zahlungssystemen.
Also am besten Briefe, Geldschein rein.
Nö, das Beste ist halt einfach... Also ich meine, wenn jetzt einer die Metaebene unterstützen möchte, ist das Beste einfach SEPA-Dauerauftrag. Also weniger Abzüge und weniger Arbeit gibt's nicht. Ja, ist so.
Aber bei mir steht ja da kein Kontum, also für mich Bitcoin bitte.
Denn es möchte Bitcoin haben. Das ist ein... Weiß ich nicht, wie gut man Bitcoin automatisieren kann. Gibt's schon einen Dauerauftrag?
Als Cromatite-Tools gibt's da klar, kann man da automatisieren. Also Cron-Job.
Aber da gibt's ja auch Transaktionsgebühren.
Ja, aber du kannst ja die aussuchen.
Da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. Das Bitcoin-Thema, das rufen wir gleich nochmal auf.
Nicht, wenn du hier noch eine Stunde flatter redest, weil da haben wir keine Zeit.
Nein, ich bin jetzt auch fertig. Ich wollte nur mal diese Gesamtmenge-Lage darstellen und auch mal auf diese mir oft gestellte Frage, warum ich denn an diesen Plattformen nicht teilnehme. Um es nochmal auf den Satz runterzubrechen. Problem ist, diese Plattformen bieten wenig, machen viel Arbeit und nehmen sehr viel Geld weg von dem, was fließt. Das sind so drei Dinge, wo ich sage, ey, da reiße ich mich jetzt nicht drum. Das ist nicht unbedingt jetzt ein Gewinn. Erstmal ist es ein aktiver Geldverlust, von dem, was bezahlt wird, bleibt einfach so viel zwischendurch hängen an Steuerwörfer und nominellen Dienstleistungen, die am Ende für mich aber keine sind. Dann muss man sich eben auch noch immer wieder Gedanken darüber machen, diese Plattform zu machen. Dann sind die noch nicht mal in der Lage, Rechnungen auszustellen, wo einfach mal die Scheiße so dargestellt ist, dass es auch wirklich vermittelbar ist, was Sache ist. Und du hast dann noch durch diese Entkopplung der Dienstleister unter Umständen eine Aufweichung deiner eigenen Position, wie du sie beim Finanzamt deklarierst. Das macht die Sache halt einfach nicht einfach. Insofern, Spenden für die Freak Show, Spenden für die Metaebene. auch bei den anderen Podcastern nutzt diese goldene Gelegenheit. Sepa ist einfach das billigste, direkteste, am einfachsten zu administrierende und am besten funktionierende System. Und fertig ist die Laube.
Außer dass, wenn du deine Kontodaten öffentlich hast...
Du dann nochmal diese Scammer-Problematik hast, da muss ich dann auch alle zwei Wochen mal wieder irgendwelche blöden Netflix-Abo weghauen und so weiter. Vielen Dank auch dafür. Weil du natürlich auch bei diesen blöden Online-Banking-Systemen kein Blacklisting machen kannst. Ich meine, wo ist denn der Scam-Button?
Oder Blacklisting wäre noch besser eigentlich.
Nein, das geht nicht. Also erstmal wäre es schon mal schöner, wenn man mal so ein Subkonto machen könnte mit gib mir doch mal nochmal eine zweite Nummer.
Für Lastschrift oder sowas wäre ein Whitelist schon gut.
So ein Incoming-Only-Ding wäre schon mal gut. Gibt es auch teilweise. Ich habe auch schon mit verschiedenen Banken irgendwie rum experimentiert. Alles nicht so einfach. Und dann mögen die das wieder nicht, wie das ist. Und nachher, damit haben wir aber nicht gerechnet, es kommen nachher Spenden und so. So können wir ihnen das kontinuierlich nicht anbieten, Herr Prittlar. Mach mich fertig. Gut, da bin ich auch immer auf der Suche nach anderen Optionen. Am Ende funktioniert so, ist eigentlich auch kein großes Problem. Nur warum man jetzt auf seiner eigenen Onlinebanking-Seite, in meinem Fall bei der Sparkasse, einfach sagen kann, hier Fraud, ihr kennt die Kontonummer, merkt sie euch. 20 Leute haben die jetzt geklickt, da gibt es ein Problem. Ich meine, ein besseres Frühwarnsystem können die sich gar nicht vorstellen. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich jeder, der jetzt hier zuhört und bei der Bank arbeitet, der lacht sich jetzt wahrscheinlich schon wieder schlapp und denkt sich nur so, oh ja, oh ja, das habe ich hier jeden Tag.
Die lachen sich schlapp, weil sie wissen, wie ihre Systeme gebaut sind und sich denken, nicht in einer Million Jahre.
Ja, an der Stelle nochmal Danke an alle, die mich unterstützen über die Jahre. Das hat mir hier viel ermöglicht und ich hoffe, das kann hier auch noch lange so weitergehen.
Ja, ich und Hucke, wir sagen das auch, glaube ich, auch wenn wir den kleineren Anteil kriegen, weil wir sind ja so gesehen zwar Gast, aber die Kosten hast ja du auch hier mit dem Studio und alles und Miete und Zeug. Aber wir holen uns natürlich da auch immer kleine Gadgets von dir. Gerade Hucke sagte, du kaufst immer deine Gadgets von dem Spendengeld.
Naja, mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Weil reicht nicht, ne?
Also jetzt bei Flatter sammelt sich in einem halben Jahr so viel an wie sonst mal in einem Monat oder so oder noch oder ein ganzes Jahr. Also das ist schon sehr zurückgegangen. Und bei Bitcoin kommt so alle... Naja, wobei durch den Kursanstieg hat es sich jetzt glaube ich auch in einen zweistelligen Euro-Betrag. Schon vervielfältigt, aber...
Aber deine Amazon-Wunschliste funktioniert.
Na, ich hab zu teure Sachen drauf irgendwie. Da kam jetzt auch schon lange nichts mehr.
Bei Bitcoin, wenn ihr da ein Euro-Spend macht, das geht schon, aber dann setzt halt die Gebühren, die Transaction-Fee, setzt die halt einfach deutlich runter. Dann dauert es von mir aus einen Tag, bis das ankommt, weil der Blog voll ist und so weiter. Aber das macht ja bei einer Spende irgendwie nichts. Weil ich weiß ja nicht, wann ihr Cent gedrückt habt. Das ist halt einfach irgendwann da. Das geht schon. Also ihr müsst jetzt nicht ein Euro schicken und dann 50 Cent Transaction-Fee bezahlen. Das wäre bekloppt. Macht das nicht. So, jetzt wollen wir doch noch ein bisschen Mac machen.
Ja, ich denke, das könnte man mal.
Die passende Sendung, oder?
Der passende Kanal.
Na, müsst ihr noch Review von der letzten Sendung machen, glaube ich? War da irgendwas?
Damit könnte man anfangen, ja. In der Tat. Jetzt hab ich so viel geredet, jetzt rede ich gleich weiter. Also ich hab das Thema jetzt hier schon eine Weile vorangetrieben mit...
Du bist auf der Suche nach dem perfekten, schnellen Speichermedium für dein Mac Pro.
Ich wollte es halt mal pimpen.
Er wollte dich auch mal beeindrucken.
Er wollte weiter raus und naja, es wird schwierig, weil ich hab das ja alles schon gemacht.
Ja, deswegen hab ich die Gelegenheit genutzt, dass es nicht gar war.
Hast du einfach mal unsere Sendung gehört von vor zwei Jahren, weil da haben wir das schon beredet.
Nö, hab ich bestimmt schon wieder alles vergessen, aber die Dinge haben sich ja auch ein bisschen weiterentwickelt, vor allem auf dem Markt. Also die Produkte, die da unter Umständen erwähnt wurden, mag es gar nicht mehr so geben. Vielleicht noch mal kurz im Rückblick, was ich letztes Mal so previously und Pimp My Mac, ging es sozusagen um die Frage, wie kriegt man halt seine SSD maximal schnell zum Laufen in einem Mac Pro? Und der erste einfache Schritt war, ich meine halt immer an dem SATA 2 Kabel, wo normalerweise die CD-Laufwerke dranhingen, dran hatte.
Dann halt so maximal 300 Megabyte durch, eher 280, mehr geht da nicht, ne?
150 halt.
Was? 150? Nö, dann ist das aber SATA 1 oder was?
Mehr ging da auf jeden Fall nicht rüber.
Dann ist das noch SATA, ja genau, die Laufwerke sind glaube ich SATA 1. Sind sie ja, da müsstest du 280 so durchkriegen.
Ja, war aber nicht so.
Ja, dann könnte sein, dass die nur SATA 1 sind für die Laufwerke und dass die vier Slots, wo man die Platten so reinschieben kann, dass die SATA 2 sind. Das könnte mal auch Sinn machen eigentlich, so bis wenn du nur 150 da durchkriegst, weil die anderen kriegen da schon, also wenn du eine Platte in so einen Slot da schiebst, kriegst du ja schon mehr als 150, wenn du willst.
Und SATA 3 sollte eigentlich die 6 Gigabyte, 6 Gigabit, Gigabit, aber was ist denn die 6 Gigabit?
Na durch 8 und plus Overt, also wahrscheinlich durch 10 so. Da gehst du dann so in Richtung, weil ich hatte das ja in meinem vorigen Laptop, das war ja SATA 3, da hat die SSD so 500 bis 550 Megabyte die Sekunde gemacht.
Also das habe ich jetzt nicht, ich habe jetzt irgendwie mit der Samsung-Platte, kriege ich jetzt mit dieser Karte, mit der ich es reingesteckt habe, also die PCI-Karte, wo so ein SATA 3-Slot drauf ist, wo man die Platte direkt auf die Karte draufschrauben kann. Link in der letzten Sendung habe ich jetzt hier so 330 Megabyte pro Sekunde in beide Richtungen.
Hat dein Mac ein Problem?
Ich habe vor zwei Jahren mir halt so eine M2 SSD geholt, die eigentlich in einem MacBook Pro verbaut wurde, also die hat jemand auf Ebay verkauft, das war so der Tipp aus MacRumors. Habe mir den passenden Adapter dafür geholt, der auch ein bisschen special ist, weil das ja eine extra Apple-Card ist und nicht diesem Standardformat da entspricht. Und ich wollte aber die haben, weil damals war Trim nur mit Apple-SSDs und sonst nicht, deswegen wollte ich unbedingt eine Apple-SSD haben, habe mir die besorgt, eingebaut und ich komme so auf 600 Megabyte die Sekunde. Und heutzutage muss man das aber nicht mehr so teuer machen, weil jetzt auch die nicht-Apple-SSDs haben jetzt Trim. Das heißt, man kann jetzt hier auf diese Standard-Samsung zugreifen. Und ich weiß aber, dass ich damals eigentlich hinterher war, hinter dem Goldenen Gral, wie er sagt, nee, dem Heiligen Gral. Das war irgendwie nur so eine spezielle Apple-Karte, die mit so einer speziellen Buchstaben-Endung war. Da gibt es bei MacRumors so einen riesen langen Thread drüber. Und die hat anderthalb Gigabyte die Sekunde gemacht, aber die kriegst du, das ist jetzt der feine Gold-Shop, das kriegst du einfach nicht mehr. Auch bei Ebay, vielleicht verkaufe das einmal, da will man so viel Geld haben, dass es sich nicht lohnt. Aber da war ich eigentlich hinterher, aber das war dann zu teuer auch. Und ja, jetzt ist wahrscheinlich der Weg halt dieses, diese Samsung SM951 und dieser Lycom DT120-Adapter, das ist sozusagen Standardzeug. Ich hatte so einen anderen Adapter, weil das Apple-Ding hat sich natürlich wieder nicht an irgendwelche Standards gehalten.
Also meine Frage, mit der ich quasi in der letzten Sendung hier rausgegangen bin, war dieses so, wie ist denn das jetzt, wenn ich jetzt nicht eine SATA-SSD-Platte nehme, auf eine SATA-PCI-Karte Adapter draufschraube, sondern wenn ich quasi SATA einfach fallen lasse, den neuen M2-Anschlussstandard nehme und mir dann entsprechende Module draufschraube, da müsste es doch eine Lösung geben. So, das war so ein bisschen...
Du meinst, wenn du dann halt nicht SATA, sondern n-form e nimmst?
Zunächst einmal ging es nur um diesen M2-Stecker, weil das ja sozusagen das Format ist, in dem man heute den ganzen Scheiß bekommt.
Den hab ich auch, aber der ist nicht, wie gesagt, Apple Standard, der ist leicht anders. Deswegen brauchte ich einen anderen Adapter, aber der Format war sozusagen auch M12.
Also soweit ich halt bis zur letzten Sendung vorgedrungen war, war halt einfach erstmal die Information, M2 ist halt einfach nur der Anschluss. So, den gibt es in verschiedenen Ausführungen und der codiert dann halt...
In ziemlich vielen sogar.
Ja, genau, aber im Wesentlichen, in der ist das eigentlich auch zwar nur ein anderer Stecker, aber immer noch SATA. Oder wird da drüber halt NVMe gesprochen, also quasi direkt PCI und damit eben dann eben auch dieses Bottleneck dieses SATA-Protokolls weg. Vor allem dann eben für SSDs mit dem Vorteil, dass da eben einfach eine sehr effizientere Durchsatz für viele kleine Operationen gemacht werden kann, was dem Ganzen halt noch mal einen richtigen Boost gibt. So, dachte ich mir, da müsste es doch eine Lösung geben, hab so ein bisschen geschaut und es gibt doch da so Karten und hab nach Erfahrungen gefragt, die sind dann auch fleißig eingerauscht per Mail und vor allem auch in den Kommentaren. Könnt ihr gerne noch ein bisschen nachlesen. Kurz zusammenfassend ist die, alles nicht so einfach. Wenn man so eine NVMe-Karte sich holt, also eine PCI-Karte, die so ein M2 drauf hat mit NVMe-Anschluss und dann eine entsprechende NVMe-SSD da reinsteckt, geht das?
Aber?
Aber man kann nicht davon booten. Warum? Weil das eFie, also die Firmware vom Mac Pro, das nicht kennt und nicht davon booten kann.
Man muss kurz wieder reingrätschen. Was aber cool ist, was der Mac Pro kann, was damals vor zwei Jahren, als ich die Karte geholt habe, was die PCs nicht konnten. Mein Mac Pro konnte halt von diesem PCI-Steckplatz, der das ist, wo dieser Adapter drin steckt, er konnte schon von diesem Ding booten, was normale PCs nicht konnten, weil das BIOS nicht von PCI-Karten, also von so einem SATA-Dings, da irgendwie booten konnten, der Mac Pro schon. Deswegen, als sie damals diese M.2-Karten da getestet haben.
Aber da war das noch SATA.
Aber das konnte er immerhin, was schon andere PCs nicht konnten.
Der Begriff, der mir jetzt sozusagen noch gefehlt hat, ist, dass es jetzt hier im Wesentlichen um die Frage geht, was ist denn das eigentliche Anschlussinterface in das System rein? Und da ist halt NVMe sozusagen das, was man heute haben will. Und die Alternative dazu ist dieses AHCI, also dieses Host Controller Interface, dieses Allgemeine. Und wenn du heute noch eine SSD findest, die halt mit AHCI spricht, dann kannst du die in deinen Mac Pro reinstecken und dann kannst du auch davon booten. Weil eben das EFI sagt, ah, hier Platte AHCI, kenne ich, ah, da lässt sich irgendwie eine Disk ansprechen, Gophoid. Und das ist sozusagen eigentlich so das Beste, was man eben haben kann, wenn man auch noch davon booten will, was ja durchaus wünschenswert ist. Man kann sowas halt auch betreiben als Second Disk, dann geht es halt auch mit NVMe mittlerweile, aber eben nicht mit booten. Und wie es mir scheint, so die letzte wirklich verfügbare M2-basierte Karte, die aber so langsam aus dem Markt rausgeht, ist halt diese Samsung SM951. Die gibt es halt auch in einer NVMe-Ausführung jetzt nur noch und auch noch in einer alten Ausführung und in dieser alten Ausführung ist sie aber de facto kaum noch zu bekommen. Aber, und das ist sozusagen dann der Tipp der Woche, es gibt noch da von Kingston ein Produkt, wo du quasi eine Karte gleich mit dem ganzen SSD- gezottel drauf machst, was ja letztendlich aufs gleiche rausläufst, d.h. steckst du da eine Karte rein, hast 960 Gigabyte Kapazität da drauf und das Ding hat eine AHCI-Interface und kann man reinstecken und kann man davon booten und alles ist gut. Habe ich jetzt selber nicht ausprobiert, aber mehrere Leute haben mir bestätigt, dass das eine absolut korrekte Lösung ist, die halt auch wirklich nennenswerte Transferraten liefert. Kostet jetzt hier bei Amazon, zum Klicken, 560 Euro für einen TeraByte. In viel, viel, viel, viel, viel schneller.
Und das ist auch immer noch ein Modul, was man da runternehmen kann, ja?
Da ist ein Modul drauf.
Ja, das sieht ja schon auch nach einem M.2-Modul aus.
Ja, sieht danach aus, ob das jetzt...
Ist da einer, der sich so ein Ding kauft? Mal gucken, ob er es mit diesem D-Link-Adapter auch betreiben kann. Dann wüsste man, dass ob das so ein Standard ist. Ja, sieht schon so aus. Ich meine, das ist da die eine Schraube, die Lücke. Das ist schon genau so ein Ding.
Aber das ist jetzt so einer, von dem man nicht booten kann, ne? Doch.
Die steckst du rein und du kannst davon booten. Weil die AHCi spricht? Weil die AHCi kann und weil sie sich so am Mac Pro halt anbietet als eine Festplatte, von der man booten kann. Und ich finde auch ehrlich gesagt, wenn du das jetzt mal mit den M.2-SSD-Karten derselben Kapazität vergleichst, ist das preislich kein Nachteil. Also wenn du Adapter plus M2 zusammenrechnest, bei den anderen Lösungen...
Ja, aber Adapter kostet 20 Euro.
Ja, man muss halt dazu rechnen. Und mag sein, dass du jetzt noch was günstigeres findest, aber es geht auch nicht sehr weit nach unten. Also du bist auf jeden Fall in diesem 500-Euro-Plus-Segment drin und hier hast du halt eine Karte, die du reinstecken gehst und hast einen Terrabyte und GroVoid und das ist, wenn man jetzt einen Slot frei hat. Also hätte ich jetzt nicht schon so eine SSD noch gehabt, ja und der SATA 3 Adapter wäre jetzt mal so die schnelle Lösung gewesen, dann wäre ich da vielleicht auch drauf gegangen. Ich überlege mir das noch, ob ich die Investition machen will, weil schnell ist immer gut, aber es ist halt in Anführungsstrichen nur ein Terrabyte.
Aber sag mal, hast du eigentlich alle vier PCI-Slots belegt?
Na ja, bis noch einen frei.
War da irgendwie deine Audio-Karte da irgendwie mit drin?
Audio, Grafik und jetzt halt die Platte. Einen hab ich jetzt noch. Also dann würde ich das Ding auch noch reinschieben, dann hätte ich irgendwie noch eine langsame SSD und eine schnelle SSD.
Vollausbau.
Dann hab ich Vollausbau.
Musst du dir nur noch schnelle CPUs endlich machen.
Ja, musst du nur noch schnelle CPUs reinschälen. Das kriegen wir noch hin. Das Ding wird richtig durchgepimpt.
Bisschen im letzten Winkel.
Ich kann dir genau sagen, was passiert, wenn du fertig bist mit Pimpen.
Pimp My Mac ist wirklich eine sehr gute Bezeichnung dafür. Das ist so richtig Pimp My Ride mäßig. So Spoiler noch dran, irgendwie dicke Puschen und so. Du hast keinen Spoiler an deinem Mac.
Naja, so eine Grafikkarte ist ja...
Ist doch der moderne Spoiler.
Außen siehst du dem Ding nichts an. Ich bin so understatement mäßig unterwegs. Ist ja ein Mac Pro. Ist ja schon, genau. Der hat auch schon ein Oldtimer Kennzeichen. Nee, aber warte, warte, guck mal, eine wichtige Sache, die du noch unterschlagen hast, was vielleicht wichtig ist, also glaube ich jedenfalls, und zwar hast du da was geschrieben von NVMe512. Byte-Blöcke geht nicht, an 4K-Blöcke geht schon. Kannst du dazu noch was sagen?
Ah ja, richtig, und zwar, ursprünglich gab es die Aussage, dass diese NVMe-Karten nur gehen, wenn man noch so einen Third-Party-Treiber installiert.
Ja, das will man ja nicht.
Was man nicht will, aber was Leute auch getan haben und was halt auch geht.
Das ist übrigens von den gleichen Typen, die auch hier unsere Grafikkarten, den EFI-Flash machen, hier in Netcast, ist das netcast.org, der hat den von irgendeinem Profi sich machen lassen, sich den Art lizenziert oder wie auch immer und verkauft den irgendwie da oder so. Also da gibt es irgendwie was, die haben da gefummelt.
Ja und die Information ist aber die, dass wenn du eine NVMe-SSD hast, die auf 4 Kilo Byte-Sektoren basiert, nicht 4 Kilo Byte, 4 Kilo Byte-Blöcke. Meine ich hier Kilo Byte oder Megabyte? 512, 4 Kilo Byte?
Bytes meinste eigentlich sogar.
Was?
512 Byte-Blöcke und 4 Kilo Byte-Blöcke, glaube ich jedenfalls. Ist wie bei den Festplatten, die mit diesem Advanced-Format irgendwie kamen, wo sie einfach die Blockgröße erhöht haben, damit sie weniger Metadaten haben, damit mehr auf die Platte draufpasst.
Genau, 512 Byte zu 4 Kilo Byte, also ich habe hier Kilo Byte geschrieben. Also 512 Byte-Sektoren, das ist das alte.
Blöcke.
Sektor heißt das.
Nee, Sektor, da können ja auch mehrere Blöcke drin sein in einem Sektor, oder? War das doch früher so, du kennst dich doch mal aus, du bist auch so ein alter Sack. Weißt du, Sektoren und Tracks und so, da waren Blöcke drin. Aber wir meinen jetzt die kleinste Einheit von so einem Speichermedium, das ist doch der Block, deswegen heißt es auch Block, wie man weiß.
Entschuldigung, in diesem Internet hier steht überall Sektor. Nennst, wie du willst, auf jeden Fall gibt es eine kleinste Einheit und 512 Byte ist quasi old school und die neuen Dinger sind halt alle vier Kilobyte. Also die granularste adressierbare Einheit in dieser SSD ist halt bei den neuen vier Kilobyte und dafür ist alles in Mac OS on Board und du brauchst diesen Third Party Treiber nicht. Das ist jetzt eine Aussage, die ich rausgelesen habe aus dem Feedback. Ihr installiert eine Karte, eine PCI Karte, die einen M2 Slot hat für NVMe Anschlüsse. Holt euch eine entsprechende NVMe SSD mit M2 Anschluss, die vier Kilobyte Sektoren hat. Das steckt ihr in den Mac Pro, soll gehen, aber man kann nicht davon booten. Andere Variante, Kingston HyperX Predator PCIe 960 Gigabyte oder kleiner für bescheiden Geld kaufen, ist dann fast genauso schnell, also die macht auch irgendwie so 1,5 Gigabyte pro Sekunde, rockt auch richtig hart und hat einen korrekten Preis-Leistungs-Faktor, so wie ich das so sehe und du hast halt auch Booten und gerade Booten macht ja nun den Speed. Also du willst auf deiner Boote...
Ich boot nie, meine Kiste...
Ja, aber da sind die ganzen System-Files drauf, die am laufenden Meter benutzt werden.
Die sind alle nach drei Minuten.
Du hast ja auch in der Regel deine Home-Direktorien da rumliegen und den ganzen Klimm-Bimm. Ja, was weiß ich. Auf jeden Fall schadet es nichts.
Und vielleicht ist es einfach...
Ehrlich gesagt, manchmal schalte ich meinen Rechner einfach aus und boot einfach nochmal, weil es so schön schnell ist.
Das machen nur Leute, wo das System nicht performt oder die keine Ahnung haben.
Weil sie zu langsam mit CPUs haben.
Zum Beispiel. Oder weil sie Fehler suchen und nicht wissen, was es sein könnte. Und was ich aber nochmal kurz sagen will, gerade hier bei SSD und bei Speed, weil viele sagen, es geht immer um die Megabytes pro Sekunde oder inzwischen geht es vielleicht sogar schon um die Gigabytes pro Sekunde. Aber das ist nicht das einzige, was man da messen sollte. Also gerade was NVMe bringt, ist nämlich erstens die Latenz geht nochmal deutlich runter. Das heißt, wie viel Millisekunden oder inzwischen vielleicht schon Mikrosekunden gebraucht wird, bis die Daten wirklich dann bei der CPU angekommen sind vor dem Flash. Das ist wichtig. Das ist da deutlich, deutlich schneller. Und dann, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hat die NVMe, die hat auch mehr Cues. Das heißt, wenn da 100 Prozesse gleichzeitig auf die Disk zugreifen wollen, dann hat diese NVMe da überhaupt gar kein Problem mit und kann die auch alle einzeln bearbeiten und machen und tun und kommt überhaupt nicht ins Schwitzen, auch wenn die nur immer ein paar Bytes von einer Platte wollen, was ja eigentlich Bytes lesen immer die Datenrate ziemlich runterzieht. Und das AHCI oder auch SATA, die haben nicht so viele Cues und die werden dann, wenn da viele parallel zugreifen, dann das kriegen die nicht so geregelt und dem NVMe, dem ist da eigentlich alles egal. Ich glaube, die haben, AHCI hat 32 Cues, NVMe hat 32.000 oder so ein Scheiß. Weil es ist ja alles nur noch Software und da wird einfach wird einfach gnadenlos gelesen, wie es geht. Genadenlos gelesen.
Auf jeden Fall im Vergleich zu den Ursprungszeiten, wo diese Rechner mal auf den Markt gekommen sind, wo man froh sein konnte, wenn man von seiner Festplatte 10 Megabit pro Sekunde runter bekommen hat, hat sich da schon einiges getan. Ich meine, wir reden hier von Faktor 100.
Ne, deutlich mehr. Also, als ich mal ganz früher meine, das Älteste, was ich mich erinnern kann, wo ich mal was Größeres kopiert hab, Amiga irgendwie, zwei Festplatten, irgendwie so im Subgigabyte-Bereich irgendwo noch.
Wahrscheinlich. Ich hab jetzt von den Zeiten, der gebutscht und dieses Big Pros geredet, nicht von Computern. Ich meine, das ist ein C64 von einer Data, das hätte 30 Bytes pro Sekunde geholt.
Ne, ne, ich mein schon Amiga schon von Festplatten, da hab ich 20 Megabyte von einer Platte auf die andere kopiert und das hat eine halbe Stunde gedauert. Und ich war da und konnte nicht glauben, dass diese 20, wie viele Milliarden Bytes da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Millionen, ja, 20 Millionen Bytes, oder? Dass die überhaupt angekommen sind, ohne dass was kaputt gegangen ist. Ich dachte, jedes Bit geht da jetzt sauber rüber und fällt nicht um so wahr. So war es damals.
30 Bytes pro Sekunde hatte ich. Okay, es gibt's gibt's gibt's.
Haben wir das SSD und M2 jetzt abgeschlossen da so?
Würde ich mal meinen, vielleicht noch so als kurze Ergänzung. Man kann, wenn man es billig haben will und noch Platten rumliegen hat, natürlich auch sich einfach so zwei SATA 3-Dinger holen und da irgendwelche Raids bauen. In 10.11 war doch diese Raid-Funktionalität aus dem Disk Utility in US-10 rausgeschmissen worden. Das ist übrigens in Sierra wieder gekommen.
Ich hab das noch nie benutzt.
Man kann das jetzt wieder einrichten.
Aber wenn ich irgendwas mit Raid oder irgendwie sonst wie, dann ZFS.
Kann man auch machen.
Fasse ich gar nichts anderes mehr an.
Oder bald AFS.
Na ja, bin ich ja noch nicht überzeugt, muss ich sagen. Na ja, hab ich auch.
Ist ja noch nicht da.
Ist noch nicht da, kein Check-Summing. Nee, Jungs, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich benutze es ja schon, auf dem iPhone. Also so wie alle wahrscheinlich, die hier zuhören, oder viele.
Ja, möchtest du dem SSD-Thema noch ein anderes Pimp My Mac-Thema?
Na, Pimp My Mac, haben wir da drüber noch was und da drunter noch was. Das ist auch Pimp My Mac. Also ich hab ja irgendwann, ich glaube, hatte ich das schon mal erwähnt in der Sendung? Ja, ich glaube schon. Da hab ich einen X-Surf vor dem Tod gerettet, kurz vor der Mülltonne bin ich noch dazwischen gesprungen und hab das eingefangen, das arme Tier. Und der Vorbesitzer hat noch gesagt, das Tier zickt rum und budet manchmal sporadisch und das Netzteil zickt, so die Pumpe macht es nicht mehr so richtig, das Herz könnte man jetzt sagen. Hab ich mit nach Hause genommen, machte erstmal nicht so den Eindruck, ich hab irgendwann schon, ich hab irgendwie was doll gebaut, also so GCC irgendwie, alle Prozesse, also beide CPUs machen voll, dann drück ich Ctrl C, weil ich dachte, ich will das doch nicht bauen, bumm geht der Rechner aus. Also nicht weil Last gekommen ist, sondern weil ich Last weggenommen hab. Das konnte das Netzteil nicht so vertragen, dass plötzlich der Rechner keinen Strom mehr wollte und es einfach ausgegangen. Und solche Sachen kamen dann öfter, da dachte ich, okay, hat der Vorbesitzer vielleicht doch recht, vielleicht ist doch irgendwas mit dem Netzteil nicht okay. Und dann hab ich mal gegoogelt und gemacht, was dann so ein neues Netzteil kostet und hier und da oder ob es Ersatz gibt und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und hab dann eine Seite gefunden, die da auch einer mal in den Chat schmeißen kann. Hier diese seanhogan.com, da ist er. Bisschen höher, bisschen höher, der Link, der da ist. Bisschen höher, ja das, genau. Und der auch erzählt hat, der hat zwei so alte X-Surf G5 und beide innerhalb von einer Woche taten nicht mehr so richtig und Netzteil 400 Dollar hat er auch keinen Bock gehabt. Und dann ist er mal, hat er sich überlegt, dass er eigentlich doch mal wieder seine Lötfähigkeiten austesten könnte. Und dass er mal die Kondensatoren, weil das so das übliche, was so kaputt geht, in so einem Netzteil, die einfach mal durchtauscht. Und das Coole an seinem Blog-Poster ist, dass er erstens da auch ein Bild hat, wo er sagt, welche Kapaz... ja also Kondensatoren, welche Größe die haben und wie die genau heißen, damit man auch, wenn man das selber auslötet, nicht so den Überblick verliert, weil das sind schon einige. Und da dran habe ich mich gehalten, habe die alle rausgeschmissen, bin jetzt zu unserer Super Apotheke gegangen bei Sego und habe gesagt, hier einmal diese ganzen Kondensatoren, hatten so ein paar nicht passend, habe ich größere genommen und so. Was man eigentlich bei einem Netzteil auch gar nicht so machen sollte, teilweise habe ich wieder gehört, aber ist alles gut gegangen. Jedenfalls habe ich alle getauscht, eingeschaltet, bumm geht. Also nie wieder Fehler seitdem. Also wieder ein Hackerpunkt, erst der erfolgreiche Netzteil repariert. Und ich habe hier auch einen Kommentar hinterlassen bei dem Typen, den hat er nach ein paar Wochen dann auch durchmoderiert. Und zwar die vier fetten, also in dem Bild, wenn ihr das jetzt da aufgemacht habt, in seinem Blogpost, die vier fetten Kondensatoren da rechts oben, die sind alle ganz am Ende im sogenannten 12-Volt-Rail dran. So ein Netzteil hat immer so Rails, also 5-Volt-Rails, 12-Volt-Rails, manche haben zwei 12-Volt-Rails, aber der Trend geht, glaube ich, in einen Rail, weil dann kann man eins gleichmäßig belassen und muss das nicht so verteilen. Jedenfalls die sind an dem 12-Volt-Rail dran. Und sind aber auch verlötet an einen sogenannten Ground-Plane. Das heißt, die ganze Fläche, die du jetzt da auf der Platine siehst, das ist eine Massefläche. Und diese Massefläche zieht, wenn du da löten willst, deine ganze Hitze natürlich auch weg, weil das alles mit Kupfer ist da drunter, mit Metall sozusagen belegt ist. Und wenn du da löten willst, haut deine Wärme ab und du kriegst das einfach nicht heiß genug, um diesen Kondensator da auszulöten. Außer das ist so ein Monsterlötkolben. Das ist aber wieder nicht so gut für die Platine, weil dann verlötest du da Sachen oder zerstörst irgendwas, wie auch immer. Jedenfalls meine Empfehlung wäre, diese vier Klopper, weil die sind wahrscheinlich gar nicht kaputt, die lässt man einfach drin und lötet nur diese kleinen Dinge aus. Und wenn es da nicht tut, kann man diese vier schweren Teile da immer noch auslöten. Aber wahrscheinlich geht es dann schon längst und man lässt die in Ruhe und spart sich eine Menge Arbeit. Außer die Profis haben natürlich Profi-Equipment und die machen die einfach raus und wieder rein. Aber so der Normalsterbliche, der irgendwie nur so eine kleine Lötstation hat.
Hilft es vielleicht mit so einem Gaslötkolben das zu machen, dass man da die Wärme gezielter...
Nee, ich hab schon ziemlich gute Lötkolben hier und der hat es einfach nicht geschafft. Ich hab die schon rausgelötet bekommen, das ging, aber dann war da die Rest... Das Loch war noch nicht wieder frei und selbst mit Absaugpumpe und mit Kupfer hier dieses Zeug mit Lötlitze, genau. Ich hab das Zeug da nicht frei bekommen, hab da gefummelt und gemacht und getan. Am Ende, ich musste mir was einfallen lassen, weil ich wollte ja mein Netzteil wieder haben, ich hab das beim Kumpel gelötet und wollte das unbedingt noch fertig werden, hab ich von meinem, wie immer als Nötlosung, von meinem Schweizer Taschenmesser die Nadel rausgenommen, hab da heiß gemacht, mit der Nadel durchgestochen, ist ja eine Stahlnadel, ne? Und hab die dann dadurch das Loch frei gemacht, dass wenn ich entlöte und die rausziehe, das Loch dann übrig bleibt, dass ich da dann durchschieben kann und so. Weil wenn das Loch erstmal da ist, dann zieht sich das Lötzchen ja auch zu Seite. Aber so zusammenhält, durch diesen Effekt, geht das ja nicht auseinander. Und so hab ich's dann irgendwie hingekriegt. Also ich hab da wirklich ein paar Stunden, sagen wir mal zwei, nur für diese scheiß vier Dinger da gesessen. Also ja, klar, wenn man das richtige Equipment hat, somit, es gibt welche, die heizen und saugen so gleichzeitig die Pumpen ab. Du saugst das Lötzchen ja da so raus, aber sowas hab ich halt nicht. Und deswegen hab ich da gesessen wie ein Hung.
Aber es heizt und saugt.
Der Heinzelmann oder so.
Wie auch immer.
Aber ein Erfolgserlebnis auf jeden Fall geht wieder repariert und Dennis glücklich.
Sonst eine Frage, bei diesen dicken Kondensatoren hast du die vorher entladen oder hast du einfach aufgepasst?
So dick sind die nicht und die haben ja auch nur 12 Volt. Also die hatten 2200 Mikrofarad, also 2,2 Millifarad, das ist gar nichts.
Also sind die jetzt nicht so einer Faustgroßenklappe?
Nein, nein, nein, die sind so daumendick oder so. Die sind schon die fettesten so von der Ecke, aber der richtige, den sieht man hier auf dem Bild nicht, der ist weiter links im Bild. Das ist so ein Teil, der ist so riesengroß und der ist da festgeschraubt und der hat schon eher so ein bisschen Bums. Der ist ja auch auf der hochstromigen, also hochspannungsseite, da wo halt die Netzspannung ankommt. Und der hat wahrscheinlich eher so, keine Ahnung, bis 300 Volt, weiß ich nicht, wie viel Farad, aber die kleinen Dinge haben ja nur bis 12 Volt, da kommt energiemäßig nicht so viel raus.
Also die reichen nicht, um dich so an die Wand zu setzen?
Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Siehst du, da steht ja hier C104, das ist so 2200 Mikrofarad bis 16 Volt, aber der muss ja nur bis 12 Volt machen, also das Netz schiebt ja da nur 12 Volt raus, man nimmt immer ein bisschen mehr, das ist so nach oben so ein bisschen extra und dann kann man sich die Energiemenge ja da ausrechnen, also ja. Ein Farad war, glaube ich, kann eine Ampere Sekunde speichern, war das so? Ich glaube ja. Und dann kommt es auf die Volt-Zeit.
Das heißt, du hast die Kapazität erhöht oder nur ein neuer mit gleicher Kapazität?
Nee, ich hab eigentlich genau bei Segor die gleichen geholt, bei manchen hat er sie aber nicht richtig da gehabt und dann nimmt man, dann kann man größere nehmen, so grundsätzlich bei so einem Kondensator. Manchmal nimmt man aber auch einen gewissen Kondensator, um eine Zeit zu bestimmen, nämlich wie lange der Kondensator braucht, bis er voll ist, weil man irgendwas zeitlich so regeln will. Dann sollte man eigentlich nicht einen größeren nehmen, weil dann dauert es ja länger oder irgendwie so, das sollte man nicht so machen. Die meisten hiervon nehme ich aber an, sind Stützkondensatoren, die einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass wenn halt plötzlich die CPU sagt, gib mal ordentlich Strom, dass der Kondensator dann diesen Anspruch erst mal befüllt, bevor das Letzte insgesamt irgendwie nachliefern kann und so. Und der kleine einen Mikroverrater, der ist schon ziemlich klein, der könnte sein, dass der da irgendeinen Timing regelt oder was auch immer. Also ich habe ein paar größer genommen, aber es hat funktioniert und es ist nichts explodiert. Bisher heißt es auch nichts, also ich denke mal ist alles okay. Hat der Typ übrigens auch gemacht, hat er auch geschrieben, mir den einen hat er nicht da gehabt, hat dann einen größeren genommen. Und ich habe sonst überhaupt keine Ahnung von Netzen. Da ich ja gerade noch ein anderes Projekt habe und in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen bestimmt so 2.000, 3.000 Lötpunkte gelötet habe, denke ich es geht einigermaßen.
Also ich glaube, löten und Strom.
Ist nicht so deins, hatten wir auch schon mal.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Löten und Strom, auf jeden Fall. Und der Kerlchen ist leider komplett an mir vorbeigegangen.
Löten ist ja jetzt nicht so das Schwere.
Ich habe letzte Woche hier gesessen und versucht, ein Kabel an einen Audiostecker von meinem Kopfhörer anzulöten.
Ja, so ein Fummelkram oder was?
Ich hab's nicht geschafft.
Und wen hast du?
Viele? Bisher noch niemanden. Ich war erstmal ein bisschen beleidigt und verzweifelt und fühlte mich schlecht.
Erstmal die Technik verflucht.
Ja, weil es sah einfach irgendwie... Also es war jetzt nicht ohne, aber es sieht nach einem lösbaren Problem aus. Aber es ist einfach...
Wichtig ist irgendwie einen guten...
Lötenbäumen hab ich.
Ja, die Spitze muss gut sein. Die darf nicht verrostet, korrodiert oder was auch immer sein. Die muss halt gut sein. Das Zweite ist, dein Lötzern muss gut sein. Am besten, wenn da ein bisschen Flussmittel drin ist. Weil das ist wichtig. Das Flussmittel sorgt dafür, dass das heiße Blei ist es ja heutzutage nicht mehr. Sondern eigentlich irgendwas anderes. Dass die Oberflächen auch oxydfrei sind, besser halten und weiter und so weiter.
Ich hab einfach diese ganze Lötlogistik nicht drauf. Mit wie kurz oder lang mach ich die Strippen? Wie isolier ich die ab? Wie löte ich die vor? Wie rumhalte ich die daran, damit die danach dann auch in diesen kleinen verschraubten... Ich hab mir extra über Aliexpress so kleine verschraubbare Audiojacks gekauft, also Audio-Stecker gekauft, die halt auch noch in so ein iPhone-Size-Cover-Dingloch reinpassen. Also du kriegst halt eine Menge Stecker, aber die passen halt nicht alle in diese Standard-Aussparung.
Du willst so ein dreieinhalb Klinke, so klein? Nee, ich hab versagt. Und vor allem, wenn du dann auch diese Billigkabel, das ist ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig Kupfer oder was auch immer, wenn du dann zu lange löst, das oxidiert alles. Wenn das oxidiert, verbindet sich das nicht ordentlich. Wenn du kein ordentliches Flussmittel hast, was das alles wieder wegätzt, was auch nicht so gesundheitsmäßig alles nicht so toll ist, aber das muss halt passieren. Oxid muss alles wegätzt werden. Die Oberflächen müssen total sauber und fettfrei sein, sonst stört das auch alles. Also wenn du da zu lange mit den Fingern drehst und verzwirbelst, damit du das nicht so auseinanderdingst, dann ist auch wieder scheiße, zu viel Fett dran. Das sind so die feinen Sachen links und rechts, die man alle so beachtet. Das lötet ja auch keiner mehr. Das ist ja wenig. Aber wir haben im Club Lötstation, zwei Stück, einmal mit Blei, einmal ohne. Wir haben auch schon da schicke Sachen. Letztens hat sogar jemand so eine Luftdüse-Dings da uns geschenkt oder dauergespendet, wie auch immer, wo man halt so mit heißer Luft löten kann. Das geht ja auch so für SMD und so, wenn man... Ach so, und jetzt jedenfalls, jetzt kommt ja noch die Werbeeinblendung für den XSurf. Also ich habe den XSurf geschenkt bekommen, aber nur mit zwei Platten, zwei Platteneinschüben von dreien. Also wenn jemand noch irgendwie so einen Platteneinschub hat, und zwar XSurf G5, weil die G4s hatten IDE, dieser G5 hat schon SATA, mit dem IDE-Zeugs kann ich nicht anfangen. Sowas hätte ich gerne, wenn ihr das nicht habt, aber ihr habt noch so ein Lehrmodul, was gab von Apple auch, wo keine Platte drin ist, aber wo man wenigstens das Ding zumachen kann, damit der nicht da Luft zieht an der Stelle, wo das unnötig ist, würde ich auch sowas nehmen. Hauptsache, die Optik stimmt wieder. Was ich anzubieten hätte, als jemand, der vielleicht tauschen will, ich habe fünfmal XSurf G4-Module. Die habe ich zu Hause, die könnte ich anbieten. Bei mir passt sie nämlich, die sind nämlich ein Stück länger. Die kann ich leider auch nicht mal als Lehrmodul nehmen, weil die sind einfach 3-4 Zentimeter länger. Aber wie gesagt, fünf Stück. Und ich glaube, der G4 konnte, vier Stück konnte man bei dem vorne reinstecken, ich habe fünf. Wir gucken ja mal.
Auch weiterhelfen.
Ja, und dann, um das Pimp My Mac jetzt noch schnell zu Ende zu machen, ziehe ich das auch noch schnell durch. Und zwar hat mir jemand im Club erzählt, das hat jetzt einen bisschen längeren Weg genommen, dass auch die bei Bits und so, die haben auch so Mac-Pros und Vergnügen an diesem Gerät, wahrscheinlich wie viele Leute auf dieser Welt. Aber einer von denen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung hatte, hatte Probleme, dass sein Rechner immer mal wieder ausgegangen ist. Ich glaube, wenn er stark belastet wurde, also wenn es heiß wurde. Und der hat dann nach vielen Hin und Her probieren, auch mit irgendwelchen Foren oder Apple-Support-Foren und so, den Tipp bekommen, dass er mal den Lüfter volle Pulle macht, schon vorher. Ob er dann weniger abstürzt, wenn er den künstlich runterkühlt schon. Und das wurde dann wohl besser. Und das Endergebnis war wohl, dass beim Mac Pro ist ja dieser riesen CPU-Kühlkörper, wovon du ja zwei hast. Ich mit meinem Single-Ding habe da nur einen so großen von. Dass da drunter, wenn man den runternimmt, ist noch mal so ein kleiner Kühlkörper. Und da drunter befindet sich der North Bridge Chip. Also sozusagen, dass das Chip sehr teilt.
Da wo die eigentliche Systemlogik des PCs quasi drin ist.
Genau, wo das ganze CCI gehändelt wird und so weiter. Das Einzige, was da nicht mehr gehändelt wird, bei unseren Xeons ist halt der RAM-Controller. Der ist jetzt auch in die CPU gewandert. So jedenfalls diese North Bridge. Da ist auch wohl ein Problem, meinten die, bei mir funktioniert ja noch alles, aber dass da auch die Kühlpaste irgendwann mal trocken und brüchig wird und dass dann die Kühlung von dem Ding nicht gewährleistet ist und dann, wenn es heiß wird, stürzt halt eben der Rechner ab. Das heißt, wer da so eine Probleme hat, könnte an der Stelle auch mal gucken, dass man die mal neu macht, dort die Kühlpaste. Das Problem ist auch, dass da zwei so Plastinopsis sind, die diesen Kühlkörper auf dem Motherboard festhalten, mit so Federn wohl. Und diese Plastinopsis können aber auch mal irgendwie abbrechen. Das könnte auch ein Grund sein, warum der Kühlkörper da nicht mehr so perfekt drauf sitzt. Und da kann man zumindest mal gucken, wenn man Probleme hat. Mein Tipp wäre aber, wenn alles läuft und man mit irgendwelchen Tools gucken kann, dass die North Bridge nicht allzu heiß wird, dann Finger davon lassen. Ansonsten hatte der wohl, wenn ich es jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe, der sich diese Plastiknopsis aber auch bestellt in gleich mehreren und wer da auch Probleme hat und sich die kaputt gemacht hat oder kaputt sind, könnte dann mal dort anfragen. ByBits und so. Hier, Timmer, guck mal, da solltest du gleich mal sofort zuschlagen. Da im Chat gibt es jemand, der 2x X 5670 hat. Das sind 3,2 Gigahertz mal 6 Kerne. Das ist das, was du haben willst, weil für umsonst willst du die sofort nehmen. Gekauft sozusagen. Wir nehmen die.
Zum ersten, zum zweiten und erst recht zum dritten.
Der Tim braucht die ganz dringend, weil sein Reaper ist langsam.
Rumliegen klingt gut. 2,93 Gigahertz.
Echt?
Wieso?
Aber 5680 ist doch 3,3.
5670.
Ja und 80 ist 3,3. Da müsste 70 doch mehr sein als 2,9.
Er versteht das schon alles.
Ich weiß das.
Du kannst das ja mal nachforschen.
Ja, ich kenne die doch alle auswendig eigentlich. Klasse, 2,93.
Die einzige Frage ist, ist da noch der Kühlkörper drauf?
Der Heat-Spreader meinste.
Ja, oder muss man den noch absäbeln?
Ja, ich denke mal, der wird dann noch drauf sein. Ist egal, nehmen wir erstmal.
Das wär mal eine Spende. Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es mit dem Mac, oder? Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da noch Themen haben, aber das Ding ist durch.
Das Ding ist durch.
Der Fisch ist gelutscht. Bitcoin hätten wir noch.
Bitcoin muss unbedingt mal zusammengefasst werden.
Ja, aber da brauche ich so ein bisschen einen der Fragen stellt, weil da gehen immer so wirre Sachen ab. Wenn mich einer da so ein bisschen auf den richtigen Pfad leitet, dann kann ich auch erzählen, was ich so weiß.
Okay, möchtest du Bruder Dennis wieder auf den richtigen Pfad bringen?
Also, ich habe jetzt nicht so viele Fragen.
Keine Ahnung, mit Bitcoin, ja, verstehe.
Also, es war ja eigentlich so einiges passiert. Und wir haben, glaube ich, in den letzten Tagen ja überhaupt nichts geredet. Es gibt so eine kleine Transaktionsgebührkrise, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, das ist dieses ewige Ding, dass die Blöcke sind voll, die Gebühren steigen dadurch, weil sonst kriegt man seine Transaktionen ja nicht durch, weil die Miner natürlich besonders, also wenn da 30.000 Transaktionen sind, aber davon nur die Hälfte in den Block passt, also es ist eigentlich viel weniger noch, aber dann nehmen die Miner natürlich nicht nur die, wo die Transaktionsgebühren hoch sind, weil verdienen sie ja meist, wenn sie den Block dann berechnen. Deswegen die mit wenig Gebühren oder gar keine Gebühren, die werden einfach nicht gemeint, weil im nächsten Block ist ja wieder voll. So und auch ist das halt die Gebühr und der Trick, dass halt deine Transaktion möglichst schnell in so einem Block landet. Und dadurch sind die halt schön angestiegen und die meiner freuen sich natürlich.
Und wie hoch sind so die Average? Gibt es da irgendwie?
Da da jetzt auch ganz viel Fake und Fad unterwegs ist, wo die halt Scheiß erzählen, ist das, weiß nicht, ob auf alle Infos da sowas geben kann, aber es kann schon sein, haben Leute berichtet, wo ich das auch glauben kann, dass die 20 Euro wohin schieben und 50 Cent Gebühren bezahlen oder so. Was ja eigentlich nicht so der Sinn von Bitcoin sein sollte, kommt natürlich aber auch auf die Programme an, die jetzt so automatisch Gebühren berechnen und dass die Leute da das nicht von Hand irgendwie noch so ein bisschen nachregeln. Das ist schon gerade nicht so schön, weil die Blöcke sind einfach seit ewigen Zeiten voll. Und da streiten sie sich, ob sie halt die Blockgröße einfach erhöhen oder ob sie das anders regeln und ob sie jetzt Seqwit aktivieren, diese Segregated Witness, oder ob sie das nicht machen. Und das ist halt alles schwierig und da musst du eine Extrasendung machen, Mann.
Ja gut, wir müssen jetzt nicht so ins Detail gehen. Aber ich meine, wenn man sich mal jetzt generell den Bitcoin-Markt gerade anschaut, stellt man fest, Kurse sind steigend. Steigend und ich glaube, haben auch das damals so gehypte Hoch mittlerweile auch überholt, ne?
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt schon wieder eine Weile her. Die sind danach ein bisschen runter, wobei runter auch wirklich relativ ist, also gar nicht viel. Inzwischen sind sie schon wieder ganz schön krass oben. Also jetzt gerade aktuell, jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen runter, gut. Aber 1180 knapp, das ist schon ganz schön fett oben. Also und vor allem ist es sehr stabil oben. Das gab es so vorher noch nicht, als das vor, wann war das jetzt? Ende 2013, da so krass oben war, das war ja wirklich nur ganz kurz und dann war es ja auch gleich wieder weg, das war, als die Blase geplatzt ist, ne? Jetzt ist es so weit oben, ohne dass da wirklich eine Blase zu sehen ist. Also es mag eine sein, aber es ist sehr, sehr langsam, füllt sich das, die Blase. Wenn sie denn platzt. Wenn sie, wenn sie platzt auch nicht, sondern sie lässt immer so ein bisschen Luft ab. Also es ist, die ist relativ stabil gerade, würde ich sagen. Wenn man das dann überhaupt so ausdrücken kann. Ich stehe ja da immer nicht auf diese Terminologie, die die so haben, weil man kann da eigentlich nichts vorhersagen. Diese eine Anstieg im Frühjahr, das war ja als diese Winkelforce-Brüder, die da beim Facebook beschissen wurden, wenn man das so sagen kann. Die haben ja in Amerika irgendwie so ein Bitcoin-Fond, wollten die anmelden oder sich genehmigen lassen. Und davor ist halt ganz krass der Bitcoin gestiegen. Das war glaube ich bis zum 9. März oder irgendwie so. Und das wurde dann aber abgelehnt, da war der Hype wieder so ein bisschen vorbei. Und die wollen das aber jetzt nochmal probieren und sich das nochmal versuchen. Und das wurde ihnen auch genehmigt, dass sie das nochmal probieren dürfen. Hat diese SEC da beschlossen. Das kann auch sein, dass es dadurch jetzt nochmal so hochgeht. Weil wenn die diesen Bitcoin-Fund da irgendwie durchkriegen, dann ist natürlich wieder ein weiteres dickes Business, was sich mit Bitcoin beschäftigt. Das treibt natürlich den Kurs immer nach oben. Weil die brauchen dann auch welche.
Also 1350 Dollar ist der absolute Peak, der hier irgendwie mal war. Oder sagen wir mal hier von etablierten Kursen 1270. Und als wir diese hoch Super-Hype-Phase hatten, da war das irgendwie das Beste bei 1161.
Also schon deutlich drüber.
Deutlich drüber. Ja, vor allem man merkt auch nicht so eine krasse Aufregung. Also es war ja dann total gehypt und es hat sich irgendwie langsamer aufgebaut, aber es geht doch relativ straight nach oben. Also irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, die Sache solidiert sich.
Ja, aber wenn man unten mal guckt, wird auch gerade trotzdem viel weniger gehandelt als damals, als das so krass innerhalb von ein paar Tagen so hochgeschossen ist. Also das heißt, das ist ein ganz normaler Anstieg, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Ja, welche Gründe auch immer das sind.
Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen wie Kaffeesatz irgendwie.
Ja, Kurse halt, Währungskurse. So, aber trotzdem, es wird teurer zu handeln. Vielleicht hat auch das einen Einfluss auf diese geringeren Trader in Kram.
Ja, da gibt es halt diesen Krieg, die einen Leute sagen, und ich würde mal auch sagen, das sind alles auch User, die uninformiert sind, die sich dann, ey, warum sollte ich so viele Gebühren bezahlen, das ist doch scheiße, mach doch einfach diesen fucking Blog größer, dann passt mehr rein und alles ist gut. Könnte man sagen, ist halt auch die schnelle Lösung, würde auch funktionieren, aber skaliert halt nicht auf Dauer, weil dann ist der Blog in zwei, drei Monaten wieder voll und dann darf man ihn wieder größer machen und du kannst nicht irgendwann 5, 6, 7 MB Blöcke alle 10 Minuten weltweit verteilen und die müssen ja auch gespeichert werden und von denen entsteht ja alle 10 Minuten einer. Das heißt, das skaliert nicht und die richtigen Core-Developer, die da wirklich schon lange programmieren und sich das auch, sag ich jetzt mal, so algorithmisch und wissenschaftlich da rangehen und ein bisschen vorausschauen, das Durchdenken, was man da so macht, haben halt da andere Lösungen, so wie Sidechains und dieses Segregated Witness und Lightning Networks und so. Und die gehen das halt alles ein bisschen schlauer an, finde ich. Und das ist gerade so der Krieg, dass die einen Leute sagen, ne, mach doch hier schnell größer. Und die anderen sagen, ne, wir wollen das ordentlich programmieren und das dauert halt ein bisschen. Und da ist gerade der große Streit. Und jetzt letztens kam halt raus, dass ein chinesischer Miner, der halt Bitcoin Unlimited unterstützt, die halt eben einfach nur schnell mal größere Blöcke wollen, dass der das halt will, weil der irgendwie bei seinem Mining so einen Asic Boost unterstützt, der halt nicht funktionieren würde, wenn die Segregated Witness aktivieren und ach, das ist alles kompliziert und jeder hat da seine eigene Agenda, weil jetzt geht es halt nicht nur um Technik, sondern auch um viel, viel Geld.
Okay, diese Bitcoin Unlimited, davon habe ich nämlich auch gehört. Das ist so ein bisschen, ist das ein Fork?
Ja, das ist so ziemlich der gleiche Code, aber da drin ist schon eingecoded, dass sie die Blöcke doppelt so groß haben wollen. Also die wollen da gerne, glaube ich, zwei Megabyte Blöcke haben. Und wenn alle Leute Bitcoin Unlimited fahren würden, dann würde das ja sozusagen umschalten, weil es ist ja so eine Konsensus, so eine Mehrheitsentscheidung. Und da gibt es halt einen Typen, der das Roger wäre, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, der das da irgendwie pusht und macht und tut. Und dann kommt es natürlich darauf an, ob diese Bitcoin Unlimited-Jungs, ob die da die Minor hinter sich haben oder nicht, weil die Minor sind ja am Ende die, die die neuen Blöcke erstellen, weil die finden die ja. Und das ist alles so entscheidend, wer so dahinter steht. Und Bitcoin Unlimited hat aber in letzter Zeit nur Ärger. Die haben bei den wenigen Änderungen, die sie machen, weil eigentlich nehmen die ja nur den normalen Code von den Bitcoin Core-Developern und bauen da ihre Änderungen ein. Aber selbst bei diesen wenigen Änderungen haben sie es schon. Mehrere Fehler haben sie verkackt. Jetzt gab es gestern oder vorgestern wieder einen Typen, der mit einem Core irgendwie alle Bitcoin Unlimited-Notes einfach abschießen konnte. Die sind einfach alle gecrashed. Und also es ist einfach, das sind keine richtigen Developer, die da dran arbeiten, sondern nur so Leute, die so ein bisschen rumfuschen und da, ja, meinen, sie können mit ihren simplen Ideen irgendwie schnell mal mehr Transaktionen in einen Blog zu packen, irgendwie durchkommen, aber ich, ja, finde das, ja, gar nicht gut. Und vor allem sorgt das für eine Menge Ärger und meiner Meinung nach auch noch für einen schlechten Kurs. Also wenn es diese Probleme nicht geben würde, dann wäre der Kurs noch ganz woanders, weil das ist ja schon eine große, ähm...
Limitierung.
Ne, eine große Unwissenheit, sondern...
Ungewissheit?
Ungewissheit, wie das Bitcoin so weitergeht. Ob das nun die sind oder die anderen. Also es sorgt halt für eine Menge Stress und eine Menge Aufregung. Und die ganzen News auch sind immer voll davon. Bitcoin an Limit oder nicht? Oder warum sind meine Gebühren so hoch? Warum ist meine Transaktion noch nicht durchgekommen? Und so, da gibt es halt ganz viel. Und alle, wie gesagt, meiner Meinung nach, die Uninformierten schreien immer ganz schnell, ja, mach doch einfach den Block größer, weil das ist das Erste, was einem so einfallen würde. Und ganz klar war auch meine erste Idee, so, dann mach den noch einfach größer. Aber wie gesagt, das kann man halt, das skaliert nicht. Das kannst du zwei, drei Mal machen und dann stehst du wieder da und musst ja doch irgendwann was Richtiges einfallen lassen. Und warum nicht gleich noch ist der Bitcoin jung? Lieber jetzt das ordentlich machen und ein bisschen mal ein paar Tage Gebühren bezahlen, als wenn es dann irgendwie 10 oder 100 Mal mehr User sind als jetzt. Weil dann werden Umstellungen viel, viel schwerer.
Aber mittelfristig muss man natürlich eine Lösung gefunden haben.
Wir sind ja dabei. Das ist nicht so komisches, mathematisches Zeug.
Man erhöht nicht den Block, sondern man hängt noch was dran.
Segregated Witness sorgt dafür, dass am Ende für eine Transaktion wohl auch weniger Platz gebraucht wird. Gleichzeitig hat es auch noch ein paar Nebeneffekte. Sorgt es auch dafür, dass man weniger... Diese Malability, die es schon mal gab, dass man eine Transaktion mit so einem Hash und mit so einem Hash irgendwie anzeigt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es genau das ist, aber auf jeden Fall kann man weniger bescheißen durch diese Segregated Witness. Und das soll schon mal das deutlich besser machen, wie viel Transaktionen pro Megabyte dann so gehen. Das ist ja wichtig. Und das ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auch die Grundvoraussetzung für die Lightning Networks, wo man so Sidechains irgendwie hat. Aber das wird schon alles sehr technisch. Da erzähle ich bestimmt eine Menge Schrott, weil da muss man es genau wissen. Das weiß ich nicht.
Zum Thema Genauwissen gab es ja neulich den Talk im Club von einem Bitcoin-Core-Developer. Das hatten wir, glaube ich, dann in der Sendung vorher hier noch angekündigt. Aber ich glaube, es hat dem nicht reflektiert. Ich konnte leider nicht da sein, habe mir den Talk allerdings danach nochmal angeschaut.
Ja, von Matt Corallo. Das ist einer der Core-Developer. Da war ich auch sehr froh, dass wir den nach Berlin irgendwie einladen konnten, weil der ist auch ganz cool, eigentlich sehr jung, aber kann gut erklären auch. Aber ich glaube, an diese Probleme, über die wir gerade reden, da hat er sich gar nicht so richtig ran getraut. Das war gar nicht so richtig Thema bei seinem Vortrag. Wahrscheinlich sind die auch schon ein bisschen genervt, dass sie sich da immer rechtfertigen müssen, weil da sagen ja auch ganz viele, dass diese Core-Developer, dass die jetzt alleine bestimmen, was mit den Bitcoins passiert und so. Das ist sehr nervaufreibend für die natürlich, weil die werden die ganze Zeit dauernd beschossen, dass sie ja eigentlich schlecht für Bitcoins sind. Dabei sind es die, die die eigentliche Arbeit machen.
Also ich erinnere mich jetzt im Detail gerade nicht mehr so ganz genau dran, aber er hat ja auch sehr viel zu diesen Energiefragen gesagt. Weil man so ein bisschen berichtet, wie so diese Bitcoin-Miners in China, wie die so arbeiten und das die ja teilweise... Also es ist ja immer dieses Argument mit, oh, wir verbrauchen so viel Strom nur, um irgendwie unsere Währungen zu berechnen und bla bla bla. Das ist ja schlecht für die Ökobilanz und pipa po.
Deswegen glaube ich, weil es gab auch einen Vortrag vorher im Berliner Club von einem Jasek und der ging auch um Bitcoin, aber dann auch eine Menge darum, wie viel Strom das denn verbraucht und warum dieser Strom, der zu anteilmäßig so und so viel aus Kraftwerken kommt, wie dreckig der ist und so weiter und so fort. Also er hat sich eine Menge damit beschäftigt und der Coralle wollte dem wohl ein bisschen den Wind aus den Segeln nehmen. Ich glaube, der hat den gehört oder so, weil der ist zwar Ami, aber er hat wohl eine Weile hier gelebt oder kann sehr gut Deutsch. Genau, und irgendwie hat er den wohl auch gehört und hat ein bisschen erzählt, dass es ja ein bisschen anders ist.
Genau, ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade nicht mehr so richtig an alle Details, hätte ich mir nochmal anschauen müssen, aber ein paar Sachen waren in Erinnerung geblieben. Unter anderem, dass diese Bitcoin-Miner in China vor allem an Stellen sitzen, wo von Kraftwerken zu Zeitpunkten Energie produziert, so Stauseen waren das glaube ich im Wesentlichen und so was, die dann einfach nicht abgenommen wird, dass es immer ein richtiges Problem ist.
Das ist ein riesengroßes Land und die haben viel auch Wasserkraftwerke und die sind halt weit weg von den großen Metropolen auch. Da setzen sie halt so ein Wasserkraftwerk hin, weil sie vielleicht mal eine Firma bauen wollten oder weil das Dorf in der Nähe Strom braucht. Und natürlich lohnt es sich nicht so ein riesen kleines Ding hinzusetzen. Wenn sie ja auch was ordentliches hinsetzen könnten, die haben anscheinend was ordentliches hingesetzt an Wasserkraftwerk und dann bleibt halt eine Menge Strom übrig und das nutzen die Miner dann mehr oder weniger für umsonst die Reste, weil die da keiner braucht und die über 1000 km lange Leitung irgendwo hinzuführen, würde zu viel Verlust haben. Deswegen macht das keiner, das lohnt nicht so richtig. Und da würden die wohl den Strom für Bitcoin-Mining benutzen.
Ja, den PC kannst du überall hinstellen und so. Kannst einfach so dezentral Strom, der ohnehin anfällt, einfach mal nutzen.
Ob das stimmt, kann ich jetzt auch nicht so sagen, weil das weiß ich natürlich nicht. Aber ich hab schon auch Bilder gesehen, wo die so Mining-Farms in China, das sind keine Fabrikheilen, sondern mehr oder weniger so sechs Pfähle, die im Boden stehen, wo so ein Dach drüber ist, aber die haben gar keine Seitenwände mehr, weil das Ding muss ja eh belüftet werden. Das heißt, die haben nur so eine Art Dach oder Regenschirm, da drunter stehen halt Regale neben Regale, wo Miner drinstehen. Hauptsache, es kann nicht drauf regnen, aber der Wind darf da schon ordentlich durchpfeifen. Die kosten auch nicht viel, diese Heilen dann natürlich schnell mal aus dem Boden gestampft. Und da machen die dann ihr Mining irgendwie. Und dann auf einer Seite so große Lüfter rein, auf der anderen Seite raus und dann pustet es da einfach so durch.
Und Luftfeuchtigkeit ist auch kein Problem?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Das ist wahrscheinlich wie in Holland beim Campen, bloß nicht ausschalten solange geht es dann.
Ja eben, die Dinger sind ja so heiß irgendwie. Die Feuchtigkeit wird erst ein Problem, wenn sie sich setzen kann und nicht wegdampft. Also Feuchtigkeit ist wahrscheinlich kein Thema.
Nee, eher ist komplett trockene Luft ein Thema, weil dann hast du eine hohe statische Aufladung, weil durch feuchte Luft hast du weniger statische Aufladung. Weil deswegen willst du nicht ganz ganz trockene Luft haben. Deswegen haben ja so Server-Räume auch, halten die Luftfeuchtigkeit auf einem gewissen Level, damit du nicht so statische Aufladung hast.
Du kannst ja auch im Dschungel einfach mal ein paar Mining-Boxen hinstellen.
Bloß nicht ausmachen aber. Was jetzt hier noch einer erzählt hat von, da kenne ich mich aber auch nicht so ganz aus, aber ich erwähne das trotzdem mal. Und zwar gibt es ja noch so einen genannten Altcoin, den gibt es auch schon ziemlich lange, und zwar Litecoin, kennst du ja bestimmt auch. Und die haben dieses Segregated Witness, das wird ja über so einen Prozess aktiviert, wenn so und so viele Prozente der Nodes irgendwie das signalisieren, dass sie das gut finden, wird das aktiviert. Und bei dem Bitcoin jetzt auch. Und die bei Litecoin haben das auch gemacht, aber schon ein bisschen vorher. Und einer meinte, dass das irgendwie vorhin, gerade wohl fast während der Sendung, dass sich dieses Segregated Witness für diesen Litecoin aktiviert hat. Was, weil man nur Bitcoin macht, natürlich nicht so wichtig ist. Aber wenn die die Technologie schon testen und auch wie das sich aktiviert durch diesen Konsensusprozess, dass die jetzt schon so ein bisschen vortesten können und dass man bei denen auch sieht, ob es funktioniert, ob es nicht funktioniert, wo es noch Bugs hat und so weiter. Dann hat ja Bitcoin vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen den Vorteil von den Altcoins, weil vorher war es ja immer nur andersrum, dass die Altcoins sich einfach nur bei Bitcoin abgucken. Und jetzt kann sich vielleicht Bitcoin bei Litecoin auch was abgucken, weil die schneller und einfacher umschalten konnten. Das war wohl vorhin. Da gibt es eine Seite, die heißt litecoinblockhalf.com/segwit.php, also S-E-G-W-I-T. Da steht zwar, da ist segregated witness active, no. Aber der Prozess hat wohl schon gestartet, dass er sich jetzt aktivieren wird. Und das meinte der Typ im Chat auch, wäre ein kleiner historischer Moment. Was war das? Notfall.
Ich weiß nicht, meine Uhr hat gerade einen komischen Ton von sich gegeben.
Aber sehr komisch, ne?
War das dieser Notruf?
Kommt dieses Tsunami-Bawning an, das müssen wir alle in den vierten Stock. Hochwasser in Berlin.
Ja, immer diese Uhren, wenn man irgendwie... Das ist noch so ein Fehler bei dieser Apple Watch, wenn du so in deine Hosentasche fasst und dann so eine Jeanskante ist ja relativ hart und dann drückst du halt genau auf die Crown drauf und löst die ganze Zeit immer irgendwelche Aktionen aus.
Und jetzt hat sie dich gewarnt, so lass das mal.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab das noch nie gehabt, ich hab das noch nie gehabt, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie so ein Fünscher. Egal. Ich hab hier gerade so einen kleinen Artikel gefunden, wo dieses Segregation Witness in einem einfachen Satz erklärt wird.
Ja, dann hau mal raus.
Also hier heißt es im Kern das Segregated Witness, also eine Art Soft Fork ist, der, wenn er aktiviert wird, der transaktionserzeugenden Software erlaubt, die Transaktionssignaturen, also die Witnesses von dem eigentlichen Block zu separieren, also die Segregation sozusagen, so dass da halt mehr reinpasst, Punkt. Das ist the Short Technical Version. Und da gibt es noch eine längere Version, die hab ich jetzt noch nicht gelesen, aber ich werf das hier einfach mal ins Slack. Also im Kern ist das einfach eine Methode, die sozusagen hinzugefügt wird, ohne dass man die Blockgröße vergrößert, sondern dass man die Kapazität dieses Blocks vergrößert.
Genau, ist aber auch nicht so viel, aber es hat halt auch noch eine Menge, wenn man dieses trennt, wohl eine Menge andere Side-Effekts, die man halt irgendwie positiv ausnutzen kann. Also es ist die Grundlage für viele gute Sachen, die dann danach kommen können. Deswegen, dass ein paar mehr Transaktionen an die Block passen, ist bei segregated witness gar nicht so das Entscheidende, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab. Weil so viel mehr ist es halt auch nicht. Also nicht, dass es dann für den Rest aller Zeiten reichen würde, sondern...
Naja, es muss jetzt erstmal umgebracht werden und irgendwie ist die Verbreitung deshalb bei 33%.
Genau, das heißt, alle Leute, die irgendwie sollten mal die neueste Bitcoin-Version installieren, das ist 0.14.1 seit ein paar Tagen. Und damit signalisiert man dann auch, dass man segregated witness unterstützt, glaube ich. Aber am Ende müssen es wahrscheinlich auch die meiner machen. Aber mein Tipp ist, lasst den Finger von Bitcoin Unlimited. Das sind Leute, die keine Ahnung haben.
Wieso kann sich diese Bitcoin-Core-Software eigentlich nicht selber aktualisieren? Das würde doch mal echt helfen.
Ja... Was? Könnte. Ist doch noch nicht mal signiert, oder?
weiß ich.
Obwohl, zwischendurch schon. Da kam keine Meldung mehr, oder? Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Kann ich dir gleich sagen. Ich tausche das mal gerade aus, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Welche Version hat sie denn? 014 oder noch älter?
014.0 Und was ich überlegt habe, es gibt ja jetzt so Hardware-Wallets, die man, glaube ich, über USB anschließt. Hast du damit schon mal irgendwelche Bekanntschaft gemacht?
Hab ich schon gemacht, aber noch nicht so wirklich benutzt. Aber da gibt es so einige. Aber wenn man die benutzt, dann muss man halt auch dem Hersteller der Firmware von diesem Ding vertrauen und so. Also letztens hat mir wieder einer was gezeigt, das ist ein USB-Stick, so ein ganz kleines Ding. Da kann man wohl irgendwie Geld draufschieben. Das benutzt man so. Also da wird einem so ein Filesystem angezeigt. Das gibt es ja kein GUI, also dann steckst du das rein. Da ist so ein Filesystem, gehst rein. Da liegen so gewisse Dateien, die kannst du dir durchlesen. Also das ist sozusagen so virtuell dieses Filesystem. Und da liegen auch Keys und Schlüssel und Zeug. Da kannst du den Bitcoins draufschieben. Und du kriegst sie auch nicht da wieder runter, außer du drückst auf dem USB-Key so einen kleinen Touchring irgendwie und dann gibt er die erst wieder frei. Das heißt, du kannst da Geld draufschieben. Und jemand kann sich angucken, dass die da drauf sind. Und dann kann er sich auch sicher sein, dass du die da noch nicht runtergeholt hast. Sonst würde das Virtual File-System dir ja auch nicht mehr anzeigen. Dann kann man das sozusagen auch so weitergeben. Oder du kannst das halt darauf speichern und warten, bis du irgendwann diesen Button drückst. Also das kann in deinem Rechner drinnen bleiben, wenn jemand dein Rechner übernimmt, die das klauen kann und so. Aber die richtige Hardcore-Version, davon ist ja dieser Tresor. So T-R-E-Z-O-R. So Jungs aus der Tscheche-Slovakie, glaube ich. Oder Tschechei wie auch immer. Und, ja. Da wird auf dem Gerät, sogar in so einem Display wird die Transaktion angezeigt. Die wird dann auf dem Gerät ausgeführt. Da kann dir gar keiner mehr irgendwie was klauen. Und die bauen auch gerade an dem neuen Tresor V2 rum. Der soll dann auch ein bisschen mehr können. Das ist so die rechts unten Variante von Hardware-Wallet. Das heißt dein Rechner, egal wie der übernommen wurde, der kann gar nichts. Du kannst mit dem die Überweisung, die du machen willst, schiebst du mit so einem Webgui oder was auch immer in diesen Tresor rein. Der Tresor zeigt das auch direkt in seinem Display an. Du kannst genau gucken, von wo das Geld wohin geht. Und musst auf den Tresor klicken, ja genau das will ich. Das heißt, wenn dir der Hacker irgendeine andere Transaktion unterschiebt, dann siehst du in dem Display, ne, das stimmt aber gar nicht. Und dann drückst du einfach diesen Knopf da nicht. Und das ist das einzige, wie es hilft. Und so sollte das eigentlich bei diesen HBCI-Chipkarten auch mal sein, dass sie das anzeigen. Ist ein bisschen weit weg vom Thema jetzt, aber jedenfalls haben die das dann nie gemacht, weil sie jetzt ja, ja, ihre Bestätigung übers Web mit irgendwelchen grafischen Geschichten machen. Aber eigentlich hätte das bei diesen HBCI-Chipkarten auch so sein können. Aber nie zu Ende gemacht.
Vielleicht noch so, äh, Nachtrag. Ich, ja, such grad aus und nach, hab mal so geguckt nach so alternativen Wallets, ob überhaupt mal so andere Software gibt's ja eigentlich nicht wirklich was, viel ist wieder eingestellt worden.
Ich traue denen auch nicht und hab auch nicht Lust, irgendwie jetzt da irgendwie die alle durchzuprobieren, ist mir zu blöd. Ich nutze den Standard-Wallet, äh, aufm Mac. Und aufm iPhone hat man auch schon in der Sendung dieses Bread-Wallet, das finde ich eigentlich am coolsten. Und für Android kann ich immer nur die, das Bitcoin-Wallet von Andrea Schildbach empfehlen, der auch hier die Öffis geschrieben hat. Der hat so die Android-Wallet. Und den kenne ich auch und da weiß man, kannst du vertrauen und so.
Kannst du vertrauen, ist korrekt.
Aber alles hier mit Bitcoins und so, weil muss einfach so sein wie immer ohne Gewehr, weil ist so.
Ja, kann morgen alles schon wieder vorbei sein.
So sieht es aus.
Außer man hat einen Waffenschein.
Ja, ich habe ja letztes Mal hier berichtet, hast du wahrscheinlich nicht so richtig nachgehört, meinen ganzen Steuerfugrahmen, den ich so in Angriff genommen habe.
Ja, hast du ja gestern erzählt.
Ja, habe ich dir dann gestern nochmal ein bisschen berichtet. Und in dem Zusammenhang ist mir auch aufgefallen, wie inkompatibel so allgemein Finanzsoftware ist mit Bitcoin. Weil, wenn du heutzutage halt so Eurohandling und Dollarhandling-Software machst, dann ist so der Gedanke, dass man irgendwas mehr als zwei Nachkommastellen hat, irgendwie hat sich da noch nicht so richtig durchgesetzt. Also abgesehen auch von dem Fakt, dass BTC ja noch kein ISO-Currency-Symbol ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das nochmal ändern wird, aber ist wohl derzeit noch nicht so. Ist das sozusagen nicht etabliert, auch wenn es ja eigentlich etabliert ist? Und ich warte nochmal so ein bisschen auf ein Software, die halt einem zumindest mal so den Stand der Wolle, also es würde ja schon ausreichen, wenn es sich irgendwie mit der Wolle so weit synchronisiert. Muss ja nicht die Keys vorhalten, aber dann zumindest mal die Transaktionen als solche, dass man die zum Beispiel, wie es jetzt in meinem Fall schön wäre, so in Money-Money mal reinwirft, aber auch Money-Money kommt halt mit mehr als zwei Nachkommastellen nicht klar.
Also irgendwie nicht.
Und nicht vorgesehen. Und dementsprechend kann ich das da halt auch nicht abbilden. Abgesehen davon, dass es halt auch keine Software gibt, die einem einfach mal schnell ausrechnet, was das jetzt eigentlich alles gerade mal wert ist, was man denn da in seiner Wallet hat. Kann ja auch so schwer nicht sein. Es gibt diese Kurse zum Download und so weiter. Kriegt man schon irgendwie raus und dann, ja.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch immer nur so eine temporäre Sache, dieser Wert von irgendwas. Es kann ja vor einer Stunde anders sein als in einer Stunde. Deswegen, am Ende hast du halt Bitcoins.
Ja, aber in dem Moment, wo ich zum Beispiel eine Einnahme habe über Bitcoin, muss ich sie halt zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo sie getätigt wird, auch in Euro bewerten.
Bist du sicher?
Ja.
Ganz sicher?
Nicht erst, wenn du auch das umsetzt in diese Währung?
Nein.
Ja, aber dir kann auch einer irgendwie ein Bild spenden, was irgendwie, dann bewertest du das auch. Jetzt gerade ist das nichts wert, weil der Künstler kennt keiner. Und dann verbuchst du da steuermäßig 10 Euro. Und zwei Jahre später ist das 100.000 wert. Und dann meinst du, ist das okay?
Ich meine das jetzt erst mal gar nicht. Ich muss das ja irgendwie verbuchen. Und dem Finanzamt kann ich halt von Bitcoin nichts erzählen. Das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen wie so eine Wertpapieranlage, wie so eine Aktie, die halt einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man sie kauft oder verkauft, einen Eurowert darstellt. Und in der Bewertung, was denn dann das, was man da hat, gerade wert ist, was ja unter Umständen auch manchmal eine Rolle spielt, so nach dem Motto, wie viel Geld haben sie denn da noch auf der Kante und als Sicherheit und Pipa Po? Und du sagen kannst, naja, hier, ich habe diese Bitcoin und das ist jetzt nun zu viel wert. Dann muss ich auch das ja irgendwie bewerten. Jetzt kann ich natürlich immer einen Taschenrechner rausnehmen auf irgendwelchen Webseiten, mir irgendwelche Kurse rauslesen, aber...
Ich kann das Argument ja mal anders angreifen. Und zwar, wenn du Bitcoin kriegst, wer bestimmt denn dann, wo du fragst, wie viel der Wert ist? Also es gibt keine offizielle... Ist ja nicht so wie beim Euro, da gibt es wahrscheinlich den offiziellen Umrechnungsgruß, den man steuerlich da irgendwie nehmen kann. Den gibt es bei Bitcoin aber nicht. Also irgendeine Bude in Hongkong bietet dir andere Dollars an für deine Bitcoins als irgendeine Bude hier in Berlin oder in den USA oder von mir aus in Venezuela, wo die Bitcoin-Preise gerade hochschießen. Also überall hat so ein Bitcoin doch einen ganz anderen Wert. Und welchen sollte man da nehmen? Also vor allem kannst du ja immer den für dich günstigsten ja dann aussuchen oder wie? Also ich unterschreibe dir einen Zettel, wo ich sage, deine Bitcoins sind für mich 10 Cent das Stück wert. Du musst dann auch ganz wenig nur versteuern.
Also für mich würde das auch eigentlich viel mehr Sinn machen, in dem Moment, wo das in Euro wandelt sozusagen, zu versteuern.
Also es kann sein, dass ja auch alle voll daneben liegen, aber solange das Finanzamt auch nicht sagt, wie man mit so einer virtuellen Währung umgeht, und das tut es ja nicht so richtig, solange, finde ich, ist das so, als wenn ich dir ein Bier ausgebe.
Ja. Also ich kann ja gar nicht sagen, wo die ihre Zahlen herhaben, aber so eine Quelle ist hier irgendwie finanzen.net, da gibt es halt irgendwie mal so eine Aufstellung von BTC, wo du das halt einfach mal runterladen kannst. Und ein kleiner Tipp, den vielleicht auch nicht jeder kennt. Also ich hatte so das Problem, ich wollte mal in einer, in einem Spreadsheet, ich sage ja nicht, ich sage nicht Excel-Tablette. Ich sage ja...
Spreizblatt.
Excel-Tablette ist auch gut. Also ich wollte einfach diese Kurse mal haben, um es ausrechnen zu können. Und jetzt gibt es irgendwie keine Quelle mit hier CSV, Runterladen, Export, sondern die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich jetzt bisher gefunden habe, vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch eine andere, weil es sollte irgendjemand einen Ort kennen, wo Bitcoin zu Euro-Kurse, historisch...
Da gibt es da schon ganz viel, aber wie gesagt, die haben alle ihre eigenen Preise.
Die Frage, wie sie diesen Preis jetzt ermittelt haben, das kann ja irgendwie ein Mittel über die gängigsten Börsen sein, es kann sich an irgendeine Börse ranhängen, das ist im Prinzip auch egal, weil soweit sind die ja auch alle nicht auseinander. Du hast, wenn du dir irgendwie Bitstamp und was ist noch so populär gerade angesagt? Kraken oder so und so was. Genau, machst du ja irgendwie so einen Mittelwert und dann hast du ja irgendwie auch Kurs und so. So weit dürften die ja dann auch nicht so auseinander liegen, diese ganzen Bitcoin-Börsen. Oder? Hast du das mal verglichen?
Die liegen teilweise ganz schön auseinander, vor allem weil auch in China gibt es ganz viele Börsen, die alle schummeln, also die sagen, ihre Umwälzung an Bitcoins pro Tag wäre so und so viel. Dabei kann das gar nicht sein, wenn man sich so eine Blockchain anguckt. Also die schummeln einfach ohne Ende und ich glaube, die manipulieren damit auch die Kurse. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du sagst, wir haben hier so einen Schummelexchange, der sagt, der Bitcoin ist voll viel wert. Wenn alle, die dann den Kurs nach einem Gesamtdurchschnitt anzeigen, die ziehst du damit ja dann auch nach oben, wenn du einen virtuellen Exchange machst, den es gar nicht gibt, der aber ganz hohe Bitcoin-Preise hat. Also da ist ganz viel Fusch an diesem Markt. Deswegen, ich sagte, man kann den Bitcoin-Kurs nicht so bestimmen. Am Ende ist es das Wert, was du irgendwann dafür kriegst, wenn du ihn umtauchst. Vorher ist alles...
Ja, ich meine, auch beim Aktienmarkt ist das ja genauso. Ich meine, du hast auch einen nominellen Kurs, der irgendwie von Börsen ausgegeben wird. Aber welchen du dann letzten Endes in dem Moment erzielst, hängt dann in der nächsten Sekunde von ganz anderen Faktoren ab. Aber das ist halt etwas, woran man sich orientiert. Und ich kann dir jetzt auch nicht sagen, wo jetzt zum Beispiel Finanzpunkt etwas her hat. Ich sage nur, das ist zumindest überhaupt mal eine Quelle, wo man sowas kriegt. Also du kannst zwar überall...
Bis wann zurück?
Bis ordentlich. Also...
Ja, vor 2009 gab es keine.
Ja, das ist auch schön. Mal gucken, wie die Kurse 1998 waren, als es Bitcoin noch nicht gab. Ah nee, da haben sie auch wirklich nichts. Da haben sie jetzt hier nur den...
Ich meine, 2008 oder einfach 2008 bis 2009, da dürfte ja nichts kommen eigentlich. Ja genau, dann 2009 ging es los.
2009 ging es los.
2009 bis 2010. Oder dann haben sie auch noch nichts. Ja, die haben halt ganz früher gar nichts.
Okay.
Haben die überhaupt irgendetwas?
2015.
Ab 2015.
Naja, immerhin. So. Aber es ist halt der einzige Ort, wo ich ein Datum eingeben kann.
Nee, oben ist das neueste Datum. Du musst jetzt mal runter scrollen. Ja, aber dann wird es ja weniger.
Ach so, richtig.
Also, 2005 bis 2013 geht es los. Also so knappes halbes Jahr bevor damals dieser Riesenpeak war.
Okay, also jetzt quasi vier Jahre. So, jetzt neben dem Thema. Jetzt befinden sich diese Zahlen ja nicht in einer CSV-Datei, SQL, irgendwas, was man runterladen kann. Sondern sie befinden sich in einer HTML-Tabelle. Wie kriegt man das jetzt am schnellsten in Tabellenform?
S, E, D, A, W, K und wie heißen sie noch? Ja, das sowieso.
Nicht so direkt.
Das machst du dann so in seinem Safari, Copy and Paste und denkst dir nur kurz.
Hätte ja sein können.
Weil du kriegst es halt nicht in etwas, du kriegst halt irgendeinen Text-Blob, den du sicherlich irgendwo reinpasten kannst, aber schon gar nicht in ein Spreizblatt. Oder in eine Excel-Tablette. So, und die Lösung heißt, ich hab dann lange geguckt, ob es da auch Plugins geben muss, blablabla. Alles viel zu kompliziert. Die Lösung heißt Firefox. Firefox ist der einzige Browser, der, wenn du eine Tabelle markierst und dann Copy machst, ins Clipboard tatsächlich eine tabellarische Repräsentierung rein nimmst, die du dann tatsächlich mit Paste in Numbers und vermutlich auch in Excel benutzt, die du ja nicht reinpasten kannst und dann hast du dein Spreadsheet. Gut zu wissen. Wenn ihr mal eine HTML-Tabelle habt, deren Inhalt ihr gerne in einem Spreadsheet hättet, Firefox ist die einzige Anwendung, die ich für Firefox hab, aber die ist geil. Und das find ich großartig. Irgendjemand sagt, man könnte noch Kontroll beim Markieren gedrückt halten, kann mich nicht dran ändern. Ich hab das einfach nur so markiert, Copy, fertig. Auf jeden Fall muss ich in diesem ganzen Wallet und Handling, Mark, noch ne Menge tun. Und dann hab ich ja versucht, alle meine Konten irgendwie zu konsolidieren. Das ist ja so ein Drama, hab ich das letztes Mal schon erzählt. Also teilweise... Du fasst dir so einen Kopf... Skrill, wir hatten das ja vorhin, dieser Paypal-Ersatz, dieser gescheiterte... Ey, ich exportier da den Kontoauszug, der quasi das repräsentiert, was auf der Webseite steht, wo drauf steht, wo hast du alles übertragen und dein Kontostand ist Null. Und dann lässt du dir einfach mal die Transaktion auf diesem Konto ausgeben, die in einem bekloppten Format kommen, wo du dann erstmal beigehen musst, weil Kommapunkt irgendwie alles ein bisschen durcheinander ist. Fix das, machst da das Spreizblatt Excel Tablette raus und dann geht das nicht auf. Du kommst einfach nicht auf die Null. Das kann einen echt wahnsinnig machen. Also ich hab da so viel Rechercherei gesteckt, irgendwie um diese ganzen Fehler auszugleichen und diese ganzen Darstellungen und so. Das ist auch bei PayPal ein ähnliches Problem. Man hat wirklich das Gefühl, diese ganzen Leute, die da in diesem Fintech-Bereich sind, so mit JavaScript und so kommen die irgendwie ganz gut klar. Aber so von Buchhaltung und Plus und Minus und so scheinen die nicht so viel zu verstehen. Das ist wirklich ein Rätsel und das sag ich und ich versteh da nicht viel von.
Wenn das mal das Einzige wäre, wovon diese Fintech-Unternehmen keine Ahnung haben.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn sie von irgendetwas auf jeden Fall Ahnung haben müssen, dann ist es doch mal die Kernangelegenheit von Plus und Minus von ihren Scheißkonten.
Was ich mir letztens mal gedacht hab, da setzt noch ne Klammer auf, heutzutage ist ja so Microservices große Architekturthema. Alles muss in Microservices sein und Monolithen sind schlecht und jedes Team darf dann seinen eigenen Microservice in der Lieblingssprache implementieren. Aber dann ist es ja dann auch so, jede Sprache oder Runtime hat ja seine unterschiedliche Rundungs- und Floating-Point-Precisions und so. Wenn du dann jetzt im Bankenwesen unterwegs bist und dann die Zahlen immer so von einer Runtime in die nächste schickt, ob das nicht auch ganz krude Effekte haben könnte.
Also hier gibt es ja auch einen Datenbanken, nimmt man ja nicht dann Floats, sondern für Geld nimmt man Dezimals. Also wo man halt die Stellen bestimmt und dann wenn man da was abzieht, dann auch nicht da Rundungsfehler kommen, sondern dann wird bei dem anderen auch entsprechend abgezogen. Damit immer am Ende wieder die perfekte Summe reinkommt.
Tja, aber wenn du dann in deinem Fintech-Unternehmen die letzte Schrei NoSQL-Datenbank benutzt.
Die kann jetzt auch Floats speichern, dann ist das voll genau. Wie ihr Kontostand ist 0,000016666677777.
Ich kam in einer Schule, wo der Lehrer meinte, ihr habt doch schon teilweise Taschenrechner. Jetzt wollen wir noch mal gucken, wie gut er ist. Was denkt ihr, wenn ein Tipp zu eins geteilt durch drei und wenn dann wieder mal drei tippen? Ja, ganz klar, kommt eins raus. Dann macht mal alle getippt, nichts, nichts, dann kommt noch eins raus. Also bei manchen schon. Bei ganz vielen stand dann 0,99 da. Also selbst da, weg war's.
Dann gehen sie verloren. Mit der Unendlichkeit haben die das nicht so.
So, ich hab jetzt noch ein Bitcoin-Thema, hau ich mal raus. Und zwar so ein bisschen auch für die Leute, die immer noch denken, diese Bitcoin-Core-Developer, die sind ja alle doof und stinken nach Lulu. Und zwar gibt's von, also, mein Argument auch, warum ich denke, warum die ja nicht so schlecht sein können, ist, weil die das schon seit Jahren machen. Und wenn jemand seit Jahren, also, weil den wird ja unterstellt, dass sie Bitcoin kaputt machen wollen, wenn ich seit Jahren schon an Bitcoin rumschraube und hätte das erstens vor Jahren schon kaputt machen können und würden da nicht so tolle Sachen halt einbauen, wie sie das halt gerade tun. Und ich hab jetzt hier mal im IRC ein Video gepostet, vielleicht jemand kann da mal cross-posten in Slack rüber, weil da bin ich nämlich nicht. Da gibt's bestimmt einen, der hier in beiden drin ist, der kommt da gleich. Ja, da gehöre ich halt hin. Und da gibt's einen, diesen Peter Wille, aus Belgien, glaube ich, ist er. Der war auch auf dem Kongress, auch ein cooler Typ. Und du weißt doch, die Bitcoins haben doch dieses Adressformat. Also vorne ist immer eine Eins, dann kommt irgendwie, was war das? Base 58 oder irgendwie so was Komisches, was dann halt die Adresse ist. Und da ist wahrscheinlich auch Teil davon ist so eine Shack-Summe, damit man nicht aus Versehen eine kaputte Adresse hat, weil wenn dein Geld an Adresse geht, die es nicht gibt, ist es ja auch weg, also die Bitcoins. niemanden zu cross-posten, das ist ja eine Schweinerei. Los Jungs, cross-posten von Irk nach Slack bitte.
Macht das doch selber.
Na ich bin nicht im Slack, muss ja starten hier, wie ich hoffe.
Kriegt das hin hier? What will er? Context? Nee, hab ich nie gesagt, Context, ich will Slack. Hab ich keinen Slack mehr? Das war auf der Web. Ja ich mach das nicht, das geht hier alles nicht so schnell. Jedenfalls hat er einen Vortrag gehalten, wie sie sich überlegt haben, wie sie halt ein neues Format für Bitcoin-Adressen einführen. Und das ist so eine halbe Stunde Vortrag, glaube ich. Wie sie sich halt Hash-Algorithmen einverlassen, damit man nicht, also damit die die Adresse halt gehashed ist, damit sie nicht falsch sein kann. Wie sie halt von Base 58, was irgendwie Pain in the Ass war, beim Programmieren und so weiter. Ich glaube sie gehen runter auf Base 32, kann das sein? 36? Irgendwie sowas. Und wie sie noch viele Error-Corrections in ihr Adressformat einbauen. Also so ein richtig schön technischer Vortrag, wo man auch nicht alles von verstehen muss. Aber wie man sieht, wie der Typ sich da hinsetzt, auch mit richtig viel Rechenpower, das so Sachen durchcheckt, mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten und so, warum er welche Entscheidung trifft. Also wie er so sehr, meines Erachtens, wissenschaftlich an dieses Problem rangeht, um die bestmögliche Lösung für sein Problem zu finden. Und der Vortrag hat irgendwie sehr Spaß gemacht. Und den kann man auch mal gucken. Wenn man sieht, wie man sich so reinsteigert, um irgendwie, äh, das, ein, also die, wie Bitcoin-Adressen dargestellt werden, um dieses Problem zu lösen, da weiß ich nicht, wie man dann noch denken kann, die Jungs da wollen irgendwie Bitcoin kaputt machen. Also, das ist irgendwie Blödsinn.
Tja, wenn wir nur den Link hätten.
Ja, na, Jungs, hier im ÖV, kann doch nicht sein, dass ihr nicht, niemand von euch ist im Slack, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Du bist der Einzige, der da noch liest.
Nein, alter, die sind locker, lass mal aufklappen.
Drei.
Nee, eher so 80 oder so. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt hier so schnell mal ins Slack komme, keine Ahnung.
Kannst du mir den Link per Einmessage schicken.
Ja, kann ich. Ja, ist ja gar kein Wind wieder, das kann auch kein Tumbleweed sein.
Hast du geschickt, kommt nicht an. Doch, da, jetzt.
Ja, geht doch.
Oh Mann.
Nee, nicht mal.
Welchen Sound hat eigentlich Tumbleweed?
Machst du immer noch mal so einen Flash?
Dass wir das immer noch da haben.
Find ich voll gut.
Also Flash ist bei uns noch nicht ausgestorben.
Ich finde, wir könnten den ja mal umdeuten, weil manchmal muss man die schlechten Sachen, weil eigentlich ist es ja nicht gut, wenn wir bei Flash jetzt immer das Adobe Flash im Kopf haben, weil das will man ja loswerden. Eigentlich so gesehen hat es das ja nie gegeben. Das muss ja raus aus dem Kopf. Und wenn du den Jingle jetzt wieder ein bisschen länger machst und den zu Ende singen lässt, Savior of the Universe, richtig? Weil das kommt ja gleich danach, oder?
Ja.
Genau, wenn du das so verlängerst und immer wenn wir voll tolle Technik haben, drückst du diesen Flash-Button, dann wird nämlich in unseren Köpfen dieses Flash steht dann für was Tolles, so wie es ja auch eigentlich sein sollte und nicht für Adobe Flash. Was hältst du davon?
Hast du heute den Film gesehen? Du hast doch immer alle Filme gesehen. Hast du bestimmt auch Flash Gordon gesehen.
Ja, klar, Mann. Aber, weißt du, wenn es richtiger Trash wäre, würde heute keiner mehr kennen. Das heißt, es war guter Trash.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Aber ich kann mich komischerweise immer noch nicht kennen. Aber guck mal, Huckel sagt zum Beispiel, Blade Runner ist doch 80er-Jahre-Hitch. Oder? Da waren deine Worte so ungefähr.
So hab ich das nicht gesagt.
Ja, aber so circa.
Ich habe mich nur schwerlich unterhalten gefühlt. Ja, ich weiß, das trifft dich tief ins Herz.
Das trifft mich nicht ins Herz, das trifft mich ins Hirn. Weil das ist einfach, das kannst du mir nicht erzählen, Huckel. Das kannst du mir wirklich nicht erzählen.
Ja, das doch. Ich kann das schon auch verstehen, wenn man das Jahre später guckt und schon ganz andere Filme kennt, dass das nicht mehr so rüberkommt. Wenn du deiner Oma sagst, Casablanca war nicht so doll, dann sag dir auch, was?
Das ist halt einfach, ja. Anyway, jetzt lass uns nicht wieder über Bläderlander sprechen. Das haben wir in dieser Sendung wahrscheinlich auch schon gefühlt, 23 Millionen Mal gemacht.
Außerdem ist gerade voll Bläderlander Zeit, weil es geht ja gerade um AIs und so. Das heißt, es wird eigentlich mehr demnächst zum Thema als früher. Jetzt geht es gerade richtig los, wo das, was in dem Film bequatscht wird, eigentlich, wenn man mal genau aufpasst, auch interessant wird. Aber lasse das.
Jetzt kannst du noch auf den Zug aufspringen und sagen, ich fand das ja auch früher schon geil.
Nee, geht ja nicht. Hatte ja nie gesehen, außer vor kurzem.
Hat wahrscheinlich nicht mal den Directors Cut gesehen.
Nur den Directors Cut?
Was mussten wir leiden damals in den 80er Jahren? Hast du jeden möglichen Schnitt vorgesetzt bekommen von allen geilen Filmen, die dann irgendwie vollkommen niedergecuttet wurden? Auch bei Brasil war das so ein Thema.
Nee, ich hab hier die richtigen Condenseure um mich für solche Werke.
Bei Brasil gibt es auch einen...
Das stimmt, aber du brauchst noch mal so ein Loser Attitude Adjustment Tool.
Oder? Nee, ich brauch hier so mit Live-Kommentar noch. Gibt's auch vom Regisseur. Also jetzt hier in der Szene, da guck jetzt mal hin, weil da ist die Lampe und die ist dann später, die wird dann nochmal wichtig werden.
Von Brasil gibt's ja auch eine Criterion Collection Edition, wenn dich der Film so begeistert.
Die hab ich auch schon rauf und runter gesehen. Die hab ich im Regal stehen und die ist sehr geil. Also die sind immer gut, wenn man Filme besonders mag, die noch eine besondere Bedeutung haben. Diese Criterion Editions haben halt in der Regel, oder immer, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, immer auch noch mal so ein Directors-Komment-Track. Und dann kann man sich quasi den Film anschauen, kennt man halt schon, geht nur noch darum, die Szenen zu sehen. Und man hört die ganze Zeit den Kommentar vom Regisseur oder anderen wichtigen, beteiligten Kameraleuten vielleicht, weiß jetzt im Einzelnen nicht so, die dann halt für jede Szene erzählen, ja, was ihnen dazu einfällt, was da schwierig war, wie es dazu kam, blablabla, was da so die Hintergründe war, Anekdoten und so weiter. Und bei Brazil war ich halt so überzeugt davon, dass ich jedes Detail kenne, also alles, und natürlich war es nicht so, und ich hab dann doch noch eins gefunden, was ich noch nicht kannte. Aber nur eins.
Für den wahren Fan hat er auch noch was gelernt.
Ich hab den Film allein 15 Mal im Kino gesehen damals und war dementsprechend nicht ganz gut getunt. Den kannte ich echt auswendig. Naja, aber ich bin ja auch alt. Ich darf das.
So. Ja, und zum Thema Zukunft hätte ich jetzt noch einen kleinen Beitrag. Was ich ja mache, wenn ich so auf Reisen bin, hab ich mir von einem Kollegen angewöhnt, dann kaufe ich mir tatsächlich den Economist. Ja, ist das geil, das war gerade schön. Beide anderen Anwesen gucken gerade so in der Gegend umher. Ich sage, ich kaufe den Economist, beide Köpfe drehten sich zeitgleich in meine Richtung. Na ja, wer von euch hat denn den Economist schon mal gelesen? Einmal im Jahr oder so?
Ich glaube, ich habe den bewusst bestens mal im Buchladen kurz durchgeblättert oder gelesen.
Ist das die Zeitung, die so rosa ist?
Nein, das ist die Financial Times, glaube ich. Das ist eine Zeitung, die rosa ist. Der Economist ist ein Magazin, er erscheint, glaube ich, wöchentlich. Er kommt aus England und ist halt so Wirtschaft und Politik im globalen Kontext. Das ist so eine Zeitung, da sind die Werbeanzeigen auch für Chefetagen und so. Director oder Boarddirektor stehen da drin und nicht so, wir brauchen jetzt eine Putzkraft oder so was, sondern so richtig high profile Jobs.
Da ist es so politikur, so eine Zeitschrift, die so explizit in die Führungsetagen adressiert.
Genau, es geht halt, also es ist wirklich sehr viel Politik und sehr viel Wirtschaft. Zusammenhänglich hat er auch mal hier einen Artikel erwähnt, wo es um Disney ging und Pixar und wie die so eigentlich gerade ihr Universum stricken und so weiter. Und ein Kollege hat das immer so auf Reisen sich so ein Heftchen gekauft und hat mir dann immer mal so Artikel gesagt, hier liest das mal, wird dich bestimmt interessieren. Und ja, tatsächlich kann ich so einen Economist, gerade irgendwie auf so einem Flugzeug oder einer Bahnreise irgendwie, kann man den richtig gut so wegnuspern, weil eigentlich jeder Artikel interessant ist. Und natürlich haben die so ihren eigenen Blickwinkel, wie so jede Publikation, also Spiegel oder Taz oder Neues Deutschland oder was auch immer. Jede Zeitung hat ja auch so seinen persönlichen oder ihren persönlichen Duktus oder Perspektive oder Filter. Und so ist es natürlich bei denen auch. Die haben schon immer ganz klare Positionen, die sie auch nicht schüchtern sind, so auszusprechen. Ja, also die sind jetzt zum Beispiel gegen den Brexit gewesen. Das haben sie auch in mehreren Artikeln mehrfach begründet, wieso und warum. Also die beziehen schon auch klar Stellung. Und das ist irgendwie, ja, keine Ahnung, so ein interessantes Themenmischmasch, weil es, ja, weiß nicht, viele verschiedene interessante Artikel. Unter anderem hatten sie einen Artikel über eine Firma, ich glaube, die aus Frankreich kommt, hatte ich in den Show Notes, die Sprachsynthese machen. Und zwar reichen denen mit diesem neuen Algorithmus oder was auch immer Verfahren, was sie entwickelt haben, halt wenige Sekundensprache von einer Person, also irgendeine Aufzeichnung, um die Stimme dieser Person dann zu imitieren. Kannst du mal auf den Link klicken, da bitte gerade. Also die, ja, da in dem Workflowey. Na, wo ist es? Da ist es, ja. Da unten, dieses Lyre.
Lyrebird. Das ist natürlich ein geiler Name. Du weißt warum.
Weil es der Vogel ist, der die Geräusche immer nachmacht.
Ja, das ist der Vogel, der so alles nachmachen kann. Kennst du nicht dieses großartige, das Supreme Lyrebird-Video?
Wo der Vogel plötzlich anfängt, das Klickgeräusch der Kamera nachzumachen.
Ja, und Motorsägen und alles Mögliche.
Nein, das kenn ich nicht. Können wir das nachher gleich gucken, dann?
Ja. Auf Video ist das immer so eine Sache, das muss man halt mal in echt mitkriegen.
Ja, also anyway, eigentlich wollte ich ja nur vom Hölzchen aufs Stückchen kommen. Der Economist schreibt über das Lyrebird. Das ist mal so ein Stück Zukunftstechnologie, die ja wirklich extreme Implikationen haben kann. Was ich sehr spannend fand an der Website, ich glaube, in dem Economist-Artikel ging es auch ein bisschen um die ethischen oder die Implikationen, was alles mit Sprach, Confirmation und so weiter legitimiert werden kann. Da gibt es oben auch ein Menüpunkt Ethics, wo sie selber auch schon darüber reflektieren, was jetzt eigentlich mit ihrer Technologie oder ihrem Produkt, was sie so anbieten, bedenklich werden könnte, weil auch in Gerichtsverfahren Tonband oder Stimmenaufnahmen auch unter anderem als Beweismittel und so weiter.
Ja, das haben sie doch gesagt. Das ist doch hier auf Band.
Genau, und das ist schon krass. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, was sie sagen, wie lange die Sprachaufzeichnung sein muss. Sie sagen auf jeden Fall noch, es ist jetzt kein flüssiger... Also man hört noch sozusagen die Ecken und Kanten, aber sie sind sich halt ziemlich sicher, dass sie die auch noch größtenteils wegkriegen. Und wie gesagt, sie brauchen im Vergleich zu vorherigen Verfahren einfach sehr, sehr viel weniger Material.
Der ganze Duktus irgendwie, du musst das doch da auch drin wieder finden. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt die Stimme von, wenn du da so eine halbe Stunde Talk von Barack Obama reingehst und damit dann irgendwie über eine Aufzeichnung von Trump, irgendwie, dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wie, also es klingt vielleicht nach so einer Stimme.
Kannst du dir mal die, weiß nicht ob sie auf der Webseite hier direkt die Demos hatten, aber es gab, doch da oben ist ja Demo. Kannst du dir mal, ah ja, Soundcloud Video Player. Kannst du dir mal in Ruhe geben, aber auf jeden Fall fand ich das jetzt mal so ein Produkt oder eine technische Entwicklung, die schon auch so einen gewissen Effekt haben könnte. Oder mal so ein paar Türen öffnet oder andere schließt.
Ach guck an, hier kommen sie tatsächlich mit Donald Trump, Barack Obama und Hillary Clinton. Politicians discussing about Lyrebird.
Also da sind auf jeden Fall ein paar Stellen, wo es schon ganz gut funktioniert. Es wäre jetzt mal interessant zu wissen, wie viele Samples sie jetzt brauchen, um diese etwas verschrobene Variante hinzukriegen. Ja, wie gesagt, wenn sie das jetzt wirklich zu ihrer Versprechung warm machen und sagen, dass sie das alles noch besser hinkriegen, in kürzerer Zeit, was sie auf jeden Fall die ganze Zeit proklamieren, das könnte schon echt fies werden dann.
So, dann gleich mal, warum dieser Vogel-Name so geil ist. Das hier ist so ein berühmtes Video. David Attenborough in BBC Wildlife läuft hier durch den Wald und stellt uns gleich den Supreme Lyrebird vor. Der kann schön singen, pass auf. Also an sich kann er schon mal sehr schön singen.
Um Frauen zu verspüren, nahe zu kommen und seine Pflügel zu admen, singt er die komplette Song, die er sich machen kann.
Es ist eine sehr überzeugende Impersonation! Und noch besser. Man kann die Worte von mindestens 20 verschiedenen Spezies imitieren. Er hat auch, in seinem Versuch, seine Rivalen zu singen, andere Geräusche in der Wiese zu hören. Das war ein Kamerashutter. Man sieht hier den Vogel im Video. Deswegen heißt diese Software so. Das ist Superb Lyrebird, das ist der geile Vogel, der ganze Italien ist voll mit solchen Videos.
Das glaub ich aber, also das mag schon sein, dass es stimmt, aber das muss man trotzdem mal echt gehört haben, damit es wirklich ankommt.
Das sind Zeiten des YouTubes und der Montage.
Man glaubt gar nichts mehr, ne?
Was man übrigens hier noch mal kurz sagen kann zu dem Economist, das ist tatsächlich, der Economist ist tatsächlich auch eins der wenigen so Verlage, Verlagshäuser, wie auch immer, die das mit dem Internet schon ganz gut verstanden haben. Also die haben auch einige Apps und machen auch Podcasts und die sind schon echt gehaltvoll auf jeden Fall. Also das muss man ihnen auch durchaus zuschreiben. Ja, Ende der Economist-Werbeveranstaltung.
Das tut sie auch eine Menge im Podcastbereich, im Politpodcastbereich vor allem. Das finde ich auch sehr bemerkenswert. Also gerade hier diese Revolution, die da jetzt gerade in den USA anrollt, dieser notwendige Widerstand, Resistance, organisiert sich halt auch extrem viel in Podcasts. Und das sind auf jeden Fall die interessanteren Einblicke in das Geschehen. Wer so ein bisschen Hoffnung haben will, kann sich zum Beispiel Podsafe America anhören und so was. Sehr unterhaltsam und sehr bringt eine ganze Menge interessante Einblicke in das Geschehen und den ganzen Wahnsinn, der sich da gerade entwickelt.
Ja, ich will jetzt auch noch was machen, wo du kurz so ein YouTube-Video mal anschneiden kannst. Und zwar, da ich ja hier gerade so viel, ich bau ja gerade halt hier so einen alten 68K-Computer, das ich vorhin erwähnt hab, wo ich auch löten muss und so weiter. Und da ist halt auch viel Digitalkram, Logik, Bausteine, also aus dieser 74er-Baureihe und so. Und wenn du auch meintest, das ist alles so ein bisschen an dir vorbei gegangen, dann gibt's da, habe ich jetzt gerade entdeckt, eine sehr schöne Videoreihe von einem Typen, der das wirklich richtig gut erklären kann. Wenn ich es irgendwo anders richtig gelesen habe, dann ist er auch bei Khan Academy angestellt, wenn ihr das kennt. Die haben auch immer so Tutorials, also ohne Ende. Und jedenfalls hat der auch so eine Reihe, schau mal da drauf, auf welchen Link soll ich das klicken? Building an 8-Bit-Breadpod-Computer. Und der hat halt einen 8-Bit-Computer. Das ist das Channel-Info-Video. Wenn du so gar keinen Plan hast, der fängt so richtig an mit, wir haben hier Strom, wir haben hier eine LED, wenn wir die jetzt anschließen wollten an 5 Volt, was passiert dann so? Zeigt der da auch, die würde nämlich erst mal durchknallen und zeigt dann, wie du berechnest, wie viel Strom diese LED kriegen muss, damit die halt eben schön leuchtet, so wie der Hersteller das sagt, wie es sein soll. Also der sagte, wie du das berechnen kannst. Und dann geht davon immer, also hängt...
32 Videos.
Genau, hängt immer so ein bisschen dran und du kommst immer ein Stück weiter, der erklärt da Transistoren und wie die funktionieren und hier und da. Und der erklärt erstens sehr, sehr gut, also man versteht's, ohne dass man irgendwie eine Ahnung haben müsste und baut immer drauf an. Also das ist ganz minimal redundant, weil das nächste Video immer noch so ein bisschen schnell mal so vom letzten Video erklärt. Wahrscheinlich dafür, dass die alle dann einzeln verdaubar sind und sie sind immer auch relativ kurz, immer so, keine Ahnung, die kleinsten so 5 Minuten, ganz viele so um die 10 und dann gibt es manche dicke Brocken, die sind dann so 20 Minuten lang. Er baut eine CPU, genau. Kein Rechner, sondern er zeigt, wie die CPU von innen funktioniert. Und die CPU hat innen einen Bus und als ich mir das angeguckt hab, wenn du dir so guckst, was er da so macht, eigentlich seine CPU mit ihrem Bus ist eigentlich auch nichts weiter als ein großer Computer, weil der hat auch wieder einen Bus und Geräte, die an so einem Bus hängen. Also ist eigentlich dasselbe nur eine Stufe drübergesetzt. Das heißt, das kann man auch gut vergleichen. Und der erklärt halt richtig schön unten, dass er halt eine Clock braucht und er braucht Register, wo das gespeichert wird. Und er erklärt, wie gesagt, am Anfang, wie die LED funktioniert, weil er will ja auch die einzelnen Datenleitungen mit den LEDs visualisieren. Das heißt, dein Computer sieht auch immer, was gerade auf dem Bus ist, was im Register ist und was auf dem Adressdecoder so drin rumhängt und so weiter und so fort. Und erklärt wirklich alles. Und ich hab jetzt die ersten, keine Ahnung, 15 Folgen gesehen oder so und ich find's wirklich richtig gut. Man lernt da was. Also ich komm da ganz gut mit klar. Und jeder, der sich auch schon mal so ein bisschen für sowas interessiert hat, da ist das genau das Richtige. Das ist nicht zu schwer, nicht zu leicht, sondern er geht schön von unten ran und erhöht dann sozusagen immer so den Schwierigkeitsgrad ein bisschen. Oder vielleicht noch nicht mal den Schwierigkeitsgrad, aber gewisse Sachen, die er am Anfang erklärt hat, macht er natürlich dann später nicht mehr mit Transistoren, steuert er die LEDs, sondern dann erklärt er, welcher Baustein so zum Beispiel Flipflops darstellt und so, dass man dann da so einen 74, 173 Baustein nimmt und so weiter. Aber am Anfang erklärt er das noch richtig mit Transistoren, wie das einzeln gehen würde und auch warum das so funktioniert und zeigt auch, wenn man es anders machen würde, was denn der Fehler dabei wäre oder warum das so nicht geht, wie man sich das vielleicht erst naiv so denken würde. Also er führt einen da wirklich richtig gut dran. Also wer Interesse hat, das ist genau das Ding. Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das gar nicht so genau. So richtig britisch kann man nicht raushören, amiemäßig aber auch nicht. Ich würde mal sagen, er hat ein sehr gutes normales Englisch.
Für geeignete Werte von normales Englisch. Hochenglisch.
Wenn ich es jetzt nicht so raushören kann, denke ich mal.
Ist es wahrscheinlich amerikanisch.
Ich muss ja sagen, als ich jetzt in England unterwegs war, und da bin ich ja auch von London nach Southampton mit dem Zug gefahren und hab da so die Gespräche überhört. Das britisch-englisch gefällt mir schon ganz gut. Irgendwie das sowohl...
Das hat mehr Melodie.
Ja, und das hat auch mehr Vokabeln gefühlt.
Ja, sicherlich. Andere vor allem.
Mehr Varianz Dinge auszudrücken. Oder die geben sich Mühe für Dinge auch, schönere Metaphern und so.
Oh ja, ich denke es ist.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Wir haben jetzt schon ganz ordentlich ins Horn gestoßen, oder? Ich glaube, wir sind durch. Huckelt schon lange, wie immer.
Ja, nicht wie immer, aber heute.
Dann habe ich noch einen kleinen Tipp für Leute, die ihr iPhone verlieren. Zweitens so Anzeigen wie, haha, ist gesperrt für den Dieb. So wenn man denkt, das ist klaut, ist nicht so gut, sondern so irgendwie eine Adresse, wo man sich melden kann, wenn man es findet, ist schon sehr praktisch, wie ich letztens festgestellt habe.
Woran hast du das festgestellt?
Na, weil ich konnte den Besitzer eines iPhones nicht ausfindig machen, weil da schon nur stand, gesperrt, Smiley.
Was hast du denn gemacht?
Ich hab meine SIM-Karte, die PIN entfernt, hab die dann dort eingelegt, damit das Telefon nach Hause telefonieren kann. Das ist dann wohl angekommen irgendwann beim Besitzer. Dem wurde meine Nummer nämlich übertragen.
Aber es war ein iPhone. Ich frage mich, ob nicht der beste Weg, ein iPhone zu seinem Besitzer zurückzubringen.
Zu Apple zu gehen.
Und es einfach am Apple Store abzugeben und zu sagen, guten Tag, ich hab ein iPhone gefunden, können Sie... Sie wissen doch... Also ich meine, wer, wenn nicht Apple, ist in der Lage, dem Besitzer dieses Telefons ausfindig zu tragen?
Ja, weiß ich nicht, genau, ich hab auch gegoogelt, irgendwo stand, du kannst alles machen, aber bei Apple brauchst du gar nicht hinlatschen.
Und was hast du jetzt gemacht? Du hast deine SIM-Karte...
Genau, die aber gesperrt wäre, weil da ist ja eine PIN drauf, das heißt, ich hab erst die PIN entfernt, dass es keine braucht, weil das Telefon war ja gelockt, das lässt dich ja nichts machen. Dann hab ich die da reingelegt, dadurch, dass keine PIN war, konnte sie nutzen, hat irgendwie LTE gemacht, dann hab ich's da eine Stunde liegen lassen, dass sie sich irgendwie melden kann, oder dass da eine neue Nachricht kommen könnte, weil vorher stand halt immer nur da gesperrt. Und da ist aber nichts passiert, dann wollte ich meine SIM-Karte halt wieder haben und hab die wieder zurück in mein Telefon gemacht und mein PIN auch wieder aktiviert und irgendwann später hab ich dann von dem Besitzer eine SMS bekommen, weil er meine Nummer bei sich bei Find My iPhone gesehen hat. Und dann konnten wir kommunizieren.
Ach du legst eine andere SIM-Karte an und er macht das Find My iPhone und dann kriegt er die Telefonnummer angezeigt, weil die nicht echt...
Anscheinend.
Oder vielleicht kriegt er auch so eine E-Mail so, ihr iPhone hat sich gerade mit einer anderen Telefonnummer irgendwie...
Ich hab's nicht selber gesehen, könnte man ja noch mal irgendwann ausprobieren, ist ja nicht so schwer. Einer sperrt einfach, dann der andere steckt in die SIM-Karte rein irgendwie so.
Nee, aber das ist ja okay, ist ja eine interessante Strategie eben.
Aber eigentlich kann man ja eine Nachricht auf dem Gerät anzeigen lassen und da kann man ja zum Beispiel eine E-Mail oder eine Telefonnummer von jemand anderem hinterlegen.
Aber warum hat er sich nicht selber angerufen?
Was?
Warum hat er nicht sein Telefon angerufen?
Da war keine SIM-Karte drin.
Ach, da war keine drin? Ein Telefon ohne SIM-Karte?
Warum auch immer, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht wurde die auch schon entfernt, weil irgendwie lost and found, wie auch immer. Aber da war jedenfalls erstmal keine drin. Und selbst dann, das Telefon war ja leer, ich habe es ja wieder aufgeladen, hätte ich ja auch die PIN von dieser Karte nicht gehabt und hätte die ja auch nicht nutzen können. Also deswegen einfach meine eigene reingebracht.
Na gut, aber dann hätte er sich halt anrufen können.
Könnte.
Wenn die gesperrt ist. Wollte ja auch wohl gesperrt sein. Also das heißt gesperrt. Nicht gesperrt, sondern mit PIN halt. Und solange du nicht anlockst, ist die ja nicht benutzbar. Was eher komisch ist, warum man bei so einem iPhone, was gesperrt ist, weil jetzt jemand verloren hat. Kann ja sein, ich verliere mein iPhone, ich sperre das, weil weiß ich, wo das ist. Irgendjemand findet das, der kann da sozusagen nichts mitmachen. Also auch angenommen, er sorgt dafür, dass das Ding wieder Strom hat. Das war, sagen wir mal, aus. Er lädt es wieder, er hat wieder Strom. Aber da muss man erst irgendwie eine SIM nehmen, die PIN entfernen und da reinschieben. Also mich wundert es, warum man nicht einfach einen Wählern auswählen kann, obwohl es gelockt ist. Also das könnten sie ja wenigstens erlauben, dass es halt nach Hause telefonieren kann. Das Feature fehlt mir so ein bisschen. Oder ich hab was übersehen, vielleicht geht das ja sogar irgendwie. Aber meine einzige Idee war dann einfach, meine eigene SIM reinzulegen.
Ja, so ein Notfallverständigungs-SIM.
Du kannst ja noch nichts auslesen, wenn es irgendwie erst mal WLAN hat. Okay, du könntest dann irgendwie dazugreifen, aber das kann ich ja, wenn ich meine SIM dann reinlege, auch. Also so oder so. Ich hab dem Ding Netz besorgen können. Aber für Leute, die vielleicht nicht so viel Fummelahnung haben, die könnten dann wenigstens da schnell mal schon mal das WLAN auswählen und könnten dafür sorgen, dass dieses Telefon da WLAN hat. Und dann hätte ich es sogar anlassen können, hätten wir es einfach da in die Ecke gelegt, mit WLAN die ganze Zeit, mit Strom. Und dann hätte der gesehen, ja, das ist jetzt die ganze Zeit da. Dann hätte er vielleicht keine Telefonnummer gesehen, aber hätte da vorbeikommen können oder so. Okay, durch den Trick mit der SIM-Karte hat er mich natürlich auch anrufen können, weil ein WLAN kann man nicht anrufen. Vielleicht ist es absichtlich so, dass man nur mit SIM-Karte Netz kriegt, damit man es halt macht.
Ich glaube, die am allermeisten Leute, wenn die ein iPhone finden, kommen nicht auf die Idee, ihre eigene Pin von ihrer SIM zu entfernen, um die dann da reinzustecken, damit das iPhone Internet hat, damit der Besitzer irgendwie wieder das sieht.
Ja, also der eigentliche Weg ist, der Telefon sollte sagen, hier sind WLANs, lass mich mal da rein. Ich brauche Netz, ich will nach Hause telefonieren, gib mir Netz. Und der User, der das findet, sollte das machen können. Und dem, der es verliert, dem sollte ganz deutlich auch mal bei Find my iPhone beigebracht werden, so vielleicht ist es geklaut, aber vielleicht ist es doch eben doch nicht geklaut oder wie auch immer. Macht da irgendwie was, dass man nicht kontaktieren kann, damit man das zur Not zurückgeben kann.
Aber immerhin, durch die SIM-Karte hast du das Telefon schon mal in die Lage versetzt, sich zurückzumelden und vor allem auch die eigenen Positionen zu melden. Du hast ja Glück gehabt, dass da nicht irgendwelche schweren Jungs mit dicken Keulen vor deiner Tür standen. Was machst du mit meinem iPhone?
War ja nicht meine Tür.
Das war genau der richtige Kommentar hier. Heute mal ein bisschen kürzer wegen schwacher Besetzung.
Kürzer war doch gar nicht kürzer.
Doch, halbe Stunde, naja, egal. Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Macht's gut, bis dann.
Tschüss.
Wink, wink.